GOOD AFTERNOON WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN TODAY'S HEARING OF A
NATURAL RESOURCES COMMITTEE.
UNTIL WE ESTABLISH A QUORUM ARE
GOING TO BE OPERATING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
FIRST UP WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AGUILAR CURRY. TO PRESENT AB ONE
FORTY FOUR BEFORE WE DO THAT I
JUST WANT TO ANNOUNCE THAT THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE PROPOSED
CONSENT.
ITEM FOURTEEN AB NINE THIRTY
THREE PETRIE-NORRIS I AM TWENTY
AB TWELVE THIRTY SEVEN
AGUIAR-CURRY ITEM TWENTY ONE AB
TWELVE FIFTY TWO ROBERT RIVAS.
ITEM TWENTY TWO A. B. THIRTEEN
HUNDRED TO COME LONGER DOVE ITEM
TWENTY FOUR A. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY TWO MULLIN AND ITEM
TWENTY EIGHT AB SEVENTEEN
SEVENTY FRAZIER.
THANK YOU AND THE HEARING WILL
BE TELEVISED ON CAL CHANNEL.
TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AGUIAR-CURRY MAY BEGIN THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
AB ONE FORTY FOUR REQUIRES THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL TO
RECOMMEND A COORDINATED STRATEGY
FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS.
ASSOCIATED WITH FORESTRY
AGRICULTURE AND URBAN WASTE
ORGANIC WASTE.
REDUCING WILDFIRE LANDFILL HAND
HOW BURNING OF ORGANIC WASTE
ACROSS THE SECTORS IS CRITICAL
TO MEETING OUR EXISTING CLIMATE
AND AIR QUALITY GOALS.
HOWEVER THE STATE LACKS A
COORDINATED STEP STRATEGY AND
FUNDING PLANS TO MAXIMIZE THE
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF THESE
ORGANIC MATERIALS.
BENEFICIAL REUSE SUCH AS COMPOST
BIO ENERGY OR SOIL AMENDMENTS
CAN SUPPORT NICK CARMINE CARBON
EMISSION REDUCTIONS.
APPROVED AIR QUALITY AND OTHER
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC CO
BENEFITS.
AN AGORA AN ORGANIC SCOPING PLAN
WILL PROVIDE LONG TERM
TECHNOLOGY NEUTRAL AND DATE
INFORM RECOMMENDATIONS ON HOW TO
SUPPORT AND INCENTIVIZE THE
BENEFICIAL REUSE OF ORGANIC
WASTE.
IT WILL BE DEVELOPED BY THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSEL WITH
INTER AGENCY SUPPORT.
AND IT WILL CONSIDER AND BALANCE
THE IMMEDIATE NEEDS OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES DISPROPORTIONATELY
EXPOSED TO ENVIRONMENTAL
POLLUTION.
INCLUDING WILDFIRE SMOKE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT A
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COMPOST COALITION.
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE AND
THE CALIFORNIA LOW CARBON FUEL
AND ENERGY COALITION.
THANK YOU BEFORE WE GO TO THE
WITNESSES JUST FOR ALL THE
WITNESSES AND AUTHORS WHO WERE
PRESENT WE'RE GOING TO BE
BECAUSE WE WERE VERY LONG AGENDA
TODAY AND NEXT AT THE NEXT
MEETING AND PROBABLY FOR THE
REST OF TIME.
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOW THREE
WITNESSES WITH A MAXIMUM OF TWO
MINUTES EACH AND WE ARE GOING TO
BE USING.
THE TIME KEEPER AND WE ARE GOING
TO CUT YOU OFF SO PLEASE STAY
WITH IN THOSE TWO MINUTES YOU
WILL NOT BE ABLE TO FINISH HER
TESTIMONY THANK YOU WITH THAT
WELCOME AND YOU MAY PROCEED.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JUST MULLIN
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMPOST
COALITION I CAN DO TO WILL AND
TO TWO MINUTES I THINK THE THE
CITADEL.
WE KNOW THAT COMPOST IS PROBABLY
THE BEST FROM MY PERSPECTIVE THE
WAY TO ADDRESS SOME OF THESE
ISSUES BUT WE'RE NOT THE ONLY
GAME IN TOWN WE NEED A
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH AND
REALLY A PULL TAB MOVING THIS
FORWARD THANK YOU.
THAT WAS A ROLE MODEL THANK YOU
[inaudible]
CALIFORNIA.
WE WOULD AUTHOR THEORIES OF
REALLY AGGRESSIVE POLLS NUMBER
ORGANIC WAY.
OVER THE LAST TEN YEARS.
AND FRANKLY WE'RE NOT QUITE
ENOUGH AN ORGANIC WAY SECTOR
THAN OFFICE POINTS OUT THE FACT
THAT THERE ARE CONFLICTING
PERMITTING INSTRUCTIONS ARE
REQUIREMENTS.
FOR DIFFERENT FACILITIES
OCCASIONALLY -- BUT OCCASIONALLY
DURING THE MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
FRIENDLY THING IS THE MORE
DIFFICULT APARTMENT REQUIREMENT.
THAT HAPPENS BOTH BUT THE WATER
BOARDS AND WHAT THEY ARE
DISTRICTS.
WE DON'T WANT TO DIS INCENTIVIZE
ENVIRONMENTAL ACTION.
AND THEN -- IT REALLY NO EFFORT
HAS BEEN MADE -- TO COORDINATE
THEIR AGRICULTURAL WASTE BEFORE
SHE WAY SWEAT THAT STUFF COMING
OUT OF URBAN FACTORS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU KELLY BOY WITH A
CALIFORNIA.
I WAS WITH MY THANK YOU.
KELLY BOY THE CALIFORNIA LOW
CARBON FUEL AND ENERGY COALITION --
US SO HIT MYSELF WITH REMARKS TO
THE OTHERS SPEAKERS BUT ALSO
JUST POINT OUT WE DON'T HAVE A
COMPREHENSIVE STRATEGY ACROSS
AGENCY ACROSS SECTORS.
THIS IS A KEY WAY TO GET A SENSE
OF THE VOLUME -- IN EACH OF
THOSE SECTORS APPROPRIATE
INCENTIVES AND ALLOW EVERYTHING
TO MOVE FORWARD.
UNDER THE STRATEGIC GROWTH
COUNCILS AGES WE WE THINK IT'S
THE RIGHT MOVE AT THE RIGHT TIME
THANK YOU FOR ENTRY AN
INTRODUCTION.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND WE'RE
GONNA HAVE YOU MOVED TO THE SIDE
ACTUALLY [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NEED A GOOD FOR THE COALITION
FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS AND
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. TO
CHECK OUR INTERACTIVE CULTURAL
COUNCIL CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JOHN CALDERON CALIFORNIA BY MEN
ENERGY ENOUGH ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT.
JOSIAH YOUNG WITH THE BIO ENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. THREE IS A BROKERAGE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY ALLIANCE
WITH FAMILY FARMERS AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES
SUPPORT TO HAVE ANY WITNESSES
AND OFFICERS ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I WILL RETURN TO THE
COMMITTEE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
THE MEMBER I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
SAY I LOVE MAKING IT DECISIONS
BASED ON DATA AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD TO WE
CAN ACTUALLY GET A GOOD PICTURE
AND A PLAN AND I LOVE TO BE AS A
CO AUTHOR.
OF THE HAVE TO HAVE A QUORUM.
YOU'RE NOT OF A QUORUM.
SO -- WITH THAT WE WILL -- WAIT
UNTIL WE HAVE A QUORUM I WILL BE
SUPPORTING THE BILL WHEN IT --
WHEN WE OPEN THE ROLE FOR VOTE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND YOU ARE ALSO HERE
FOR AB EIGHT FIFTEEN I AM?
AGAIN GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALL BEGINNING BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
WITH THESE AMENDMENTS AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN WILL INCENTIVIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO INCREASE SIR
CURBSIDE SEPARATION IN THE
RECYCLING PROGRAMS.
WHICH WILL REDUCE CONTAMINATION
RATES IN THE RECYCLING STREAM.
BY COMPARISON WHEN WE THROW OUT
ALL OF OUR RECYCLABLES INTO THE
SAME BIN GLASS BREAKS LEFT OVER
SO TO SPILLS ON COPY PAPER.
AND A RECYCLED MATERIALS BECOME
CONTAMINATED.
CONTAMINATION REDUCES THE
QUALITY OF OUR RECYCLABLES
MAKING THEM DIFFICULT OR IN PART
BEEN POSSIBLE. TO MARKET FOR RE
USE.
WE USED TO SEND OVER HALF A
WROTE CONTAMINATE RECYCLABLES TO
CHINA WHERE THEY WERE FREQUENTLY
LANDFILLS OR BURNED.
BUT CHINA ISN'T TAKING ARE
CONTAMINATED RECYCLABLES ANYMORE.
WE NEED TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO BE
MORE RESPONSIBLE CONSUMERS AND
RECYCLERS.
DUAL STREAM PROGRAMS KEEP
RECYCLED MATERIAL SEPARATED AND
CLEANER IN THE WASTE STREAM.
CLEAN STREAMS INCREASE THE
MARKETABILITY OF A RECYCLABLE SO
THAT THEY ARE ACTUALLY TURNED
INTONEW PRODUCTS.
AB EIGHT FIFTEEN WORKERS LOCALS
WITH EXISTING DUAL STREAM
PROGRAMS TO CONTINUE OPERATING
THOSE PROGRAMS AND INCENTIVIZE
THOSE WHO WISH TO TO SWITCH.
THIS WILL IMPROVE THE QUALITY
AND MARKETABILITY OF RECYCLED
MATERIALS AND REDUCE.
THE AMOUNT OF THOSE MATERIALS
THAT ARE STOCKPILED LANDFIELD OR
BURNED AT HOME -- OVERSEAS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OUR REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
PENINSULA SANITARY SERVICE MILL
VALLEY REFUSE SERVICE AND THE
GLASS PACKING INSTITUTE THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JIM MY
PERONI I'M WITH MILL VALLEY
REFUSE SERVICE -- HOLDER IN
MARIN COUNTY -- COUPLE OF YEARS
AGO WE WERE OPERATING A SINGLE
STREAM -- RECYCLING -- OPERATION
PICKING UP CURBSIDE AND WE BEGAN
TO SUFFER THE AFFECTS OF THE
CHINA NATIONAL SORT POLICY.
SO WE WERE LOOKING AROUND FOR A
DIFFERENT WAY TO COLLECT
RECYCLING AND WE TESTED A DUAL
STREAM PILOT PROJECT LAST YEAR
WE FOUND IT WAS A A GOOD WAY TO
CLEAN UP OUR MATERIAL.
AND THAT WAS THE MAJOR GOAL TO
REDUCE PROCESSING COSTS AND AND
HELP -- MAKE OUR MATERIAL MORE
MARKETABLE SO -- WE SUPPORT THIS
BILL WE THINK DUAL STREAM SEEMS
TO BE -- A GOOD WAY TO TACKLE
THE PROBLEM OF CONTAMINATION IN --
RECYCLING COLLECTION AT THE CURB.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIRMAN IN
A BOARD MY NAME'S LEE PELLEGRINI
I'M A HOLLER IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA INSOLENT
SANITARY SERVICE.
MY RELATED COMPANIES SERVICE
OVER HALF A MILLION PEOPLE WE
HAVE A BOTH SYSTEMS IN PLACE OF
A SINGLE STREAM AND DOLE STREAM
SYSTEM.
THERE'S ROUGHLY TWENTY
JURISDICTIONS AND AROUND THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY THAT HAVE DUAL
SPRING COLLECTION SOME OF THOSE
OF HAVE MOLLY BACK TO THE EARLY
EIGHTIES.
IT IS A BETTER CLEANER -- HIGHER
AND BETTER USE OF MATERIAL
COLLECTED FROM CURBSIDE.
WE HAVE JUST RECENTLY TRANSITION
TO CITIES THAT WERE SINGLE
STREAM OVER TO DUAL STREAM THE
CITY A MILPITAS IN THE CITY OF
WINDSOR AND SONOMA COUNTY.
ARE.
A RESIDUAL PERCENTAGE ON A
SINGLE STREAM COLLECTION PROGRAM
HAS BEEN AVERAGING 25% WHICH IS
GROWN WITH TO CHINA SOARED IN
THE REQUIREMENTS OF A QUALITY
PRODUCT.
OUR DUAL STREAM SYSTEMS ARE
ACHIEVING A 10% RESIDUAL FACTOR.
WE NEED TOOLS. TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE OUR CUSTOMERS
MEET THE MANDATES OF THE STATE
AND THE GOALS THEY WANT TO DO
BETTER WE ARE.
LIKE THE IDEA OF THIS A PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO BRING SOME
INCENTIVES SO WE CAN ALL DO OUR
JOB TO SAVE THE ENVIRONMENT AND
HAVE A CLEANER HIGHER BETTER USE
PRODUCT TO BE REUSED.
THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT MICROBES
IN HERE ON BEHALF OF THE GLASS
PACKAGING IS TO WHICH IS THE
TRADE ASSOCIATION OF GLASS
BOTTLE MANUFACTURERS AND
CALIFORNIAN IN THE NATION -- WE
GPI HAS BEEN A LONG SUPPORTER OF
A LONG TIME SUPPORTER OF OF OF
TRYING TO GET MORE DUAL STREAM
PROGRAMS -- IMPLEMENTED -- GLASS
CONTAINERS ADDS AS AGAIN.
AS HE NOW SAYS POINTS ON THE NOW
SAYS DOESN'T EXCELLENT JOB ON
THE WHOLE HISTORY OF OF A SINGLE
STREAM DUAL STREAM AND WHAT'S
GOING ON WITH -- CHINA NATIONAL
SOARED SO IT'S A IT'S AN
EXCELLENT DOCUMENT AND AND IN
AND DOES EXPLAINED THE PROBLEM
THAT THE GLASS INDUSTRY HAS THE
GLASS INDUSTRY IS THE INITIATOR
OF THE GLASS BOTTLE AND THEY'RE
ALSO THE END USER OF THE GLASS
BOTTLE IN ORDER
TO IN ORDER TO CLOSE THE LOOP
AND GET THAT GLASS BACK WE HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING ABOUT REDUCING
THE CONTAMINATION IN THE IN THE
RECYCLING STREAM AND AND A
DRAWSTRING PROGRAM DOES DO THAT
AS THE GENTLEMAN OF HAVE POINTED
OUT ON THE ALTERNATIVE FOR SOME
COMMUNITIES AND FORTUNE LIKE.
THE CITY OF MEAN PEAK AT THIS
EVEN TAKE IT DECIDED THAT THEIR
THEIR ANSWER TO CHINA NATIONAL
SORT WAS JUST A CUT GLASS OUT OF
THERE CURBSIDE PROGRAM IN AND
AND THAT'S NOT THE ANSWER OF
GLASS IS THE MOST RECYCLABLE
PRODUCT IT'S A GLASS BOTTLE CAN
BE A GLASS.
BOTTLE AND WE NEED TO DO THINGS
TO INCENTIVIZE DUAL STREAM
PROGRAMS RATHER THAN WHAT THE
COMMUNITIES COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT ACTUALLY.
TAKE SOMETHING OUT OF THE
RECYCLING STREAM ON IN PROJECT
THE AUTHORS HELP HELP ON THIS IN
THE FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SIGNAL WILL TAKE IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEES FOR QUESTIONS AND I'M
SORRY IS THERE ONE OR ACTUALLY A
TWEENER -- AN ACCOMPLICE OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION ON THE
BILL AS WRITTEN BUT WE
DEFINITELY SHARE THE AUTHORS --
MOTIVATION AND INTENT AND
APPRECIATE THE STAFF FOR WORKING
WITH US TO ADDRESS OUR CONCERNS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU -- ANYBODY ELSE WHO
WANTS TO TESTIFY.
THANK YOU OKAY WE'LL TAKE IT
BACK TO THE TWENTY FOR ANY
QUESTIONS MISTER CHILD JUST A
QUICK QUESTION FOR THE WITNESSES --
THEY DID THE ONE ON EACH ITEM
AND SAY THAT IT'S IT'S ACTUALLY
COST LESS TO DO.
A DOOR STREAM SYSTEMS.
THIS IS A LESS COSTLY -- MORE
MORE CAR ARE EXPERIENCED AT
INCREMENTAL COST -- TO COLLECT
MATERIAL SEPARATELY AS A DIVIDED
CART -- ANNA SPLIT TRUCK.
SO THAT WHEN YOU COLLECT
MATERIALS KEPT SEPARATE ALL
THROUGH THE COLLECTION PROCESS
YOUR MATERIALS RECOVERY FACILITY
TECHNOLOGY CAN HANDLE SINGLE
STREAM OR DUAL STREAM.
SO TO INCREMENTAL COSTS A SMALL
PERCENTAGE THE RETURN IS REDUCED --
RESIDUAL THAT COST YOU ENDS UP
IN THE LANDFILL AND IT'S IT'S
WORTH THE INVESTMENT STOP FOR
THE LONG TERM IN MY OPINION.
SEVEN ASSESSMENT YEAH I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO STATE -- THIS
NATIONAL SORT OF SOMETHING THAT
WE ALL ARE STE TRYING TO
STRUGGLE WITH AND AND TRYING TO
FIND A WAY TO TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE SO I APPRECIATE THEM.
I APPRECIATE THE CARROT APPROACH
THAT YOU'VE DECIDED UPON HERE --
BUT TO IT.
BUT THAT IT DOES COST MORE UNTIL
WE HEAR FROM WITNESSES A WE
RESPECT THEIR THAT THEY'RE ALL
FROM BAY AREA.
TYPE CITIES AND SO WHEN YOU
MOVED FURTHER OUT INTO THE
VALLEY IN DOWN THE STATE THINGS
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIFFICULT AS
YOU WELL KNOW REPRESENTING RURAL
AREAS SO.
I THINK THERE'S A WAY TO TRY TO
GET IS THERE AND I THINK WE
SHOULD ALL BE PAYING CAREFUL
ATTENTION AS IT GOES FORWARD AND
PAY ATTENTION THE COST ISSUES
BUT ALSO THAT WE USE THE CARROT
NOT A STICK. TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
OKAY -- WE STILL DON'T HAVE A
QUORUM.
OF DEALING WITH THE RECYCLING
CRISIS IS GOING TO BE A TOP.
PRIORITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
FOR MANY OF OUR MEMBERS AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR I'M
EFFORTS IN THIS AREA ALL THE
SUPPORTING THE BILL -- WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP WE HAVE MR HOLDEN WITH
.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WELCOME
YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- A. B..
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS NOTED
IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS IS
VERY SIMILAR BILL. TO MY BILL A.
B. THREE ONE FORTY SIX FROM LAST
YEAR WHICH MANY OF YOU VOTED --
TO SUPPORT.
THERE ARE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
OLD AND POTENTIALLY LEAKING OIL
AND GAS WELLS IN CALIFORNIA.
SOME OF THESE SITES ARE IDLE
DESERTED.
HAZARDOUS.
AND THOSE ARE THE FOCUS OF THIS
BILL.
LIKE ACTIVE PRODUCTION SITES
IDLE DESERTED AND HAZARDOUS OIL
AND GAS WELLS CAN LEAK POLLUTION.
FOR EXAMPLE IN TWO THOUSAND
SIXTEEN APPEAR OF IDLE OIL AND
GAS WELLS WERE FOUND LEAKING
HAZARDOUS LEVELS OF GAS IN THE
ECHO PARK NEIGHBORHOOD OF LOS
ANGELES.
LESS THAN A HUNDRED FEET FROM
NEARBY RESIDENTS.
IN ADDITION EARLIER THIS YEAR
AND OIL.
OLD OIL WELL IN MARINA DEL REY
EXPERIENCE RELEASE DURING
REMEDIATION WORK.
POTENTIAL EMISSIONS FROM IDA
WELLS INCLUDE METHANE ADVANCING.
METHANE IS A CLIMATE CHANGE GAS
MANY TIMES MORE POWERFUL THAN
CARBON DIOXIDE.
WHILE OTHER CO ADMITTED YOUR
POLLUTANTS LIKE BENZENE CAN
CAUSE CANCER.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
MAKE THIS INFORMATION ON LEAKS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
CREATING A BODY OF INFORMATION
THAT IS IMPORTANT. TO KNOW IN
THE SIZE AND SCOPE OF THE
EMISSIONS FROM IDLE AND DESERTED
WELLS.
INFORMATION COLLECTED UNDER A.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT CAN BE
USED TO CREATE A BETTER
UNDERSTANDING OF THE EMISSIONS
FROM ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S OIL AND
GAS WELLS.
LESLIE AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE DAGR TO
PERFORMERS VIEW OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF WELL PLUGIN
OPERATIONS TO ELIMINATE ERA
MISSIONS.
AND CLOSING IDLE AND DESERTED
WELLS CAN AND DO LEAK.
AND WHEN THEY DO IT CAN RESULT
IN EMISSIONS THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THAT ENDANGER THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT SIX TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AT A LOW COST
BY REQUIRING THE DATA ALREADY
COLLECTED BE MADE PUBLIC.
I HAVE WITH ME LARA NAVARRO FROM
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND TO
DISCUSS THE IMPORTANCE OF THE
LEGISLATION AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR DR.
I GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
LAUREN OF OUR I'M HERE WITH
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND -- I
WOULD ECHO MANY OF THE ASSEMBLY
MEN'S POINTS AT CALIFORNIA'S
HOME TO TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
ABANDONED AND IDA WELLS. FOR
EXAMPLE THE LA BASIN IS HOME TO
OVER SEVENTY OIL FIELDS ME THAT
A BANDED WELLS UNDERLIE MANY
HOMES AND BUSINESSES.
WHEN THESE WELLS HAVE NOT BEEN
PROPERLY SEALED THEY PRESENT A
SERIES EXPLOSION HEALTH RISK TO
BOTH HOME -- HOMEOWNERS AND
RESIDENTS AND ALSO TO WORKERS IN
THE BUSINESSES.
SYSTEMATICALLY EXAMINING WHICH
WELLS ARE LEAKING AND WHAT THE
FACTORS ARE THAT ARE LIKELY TO
MAKE THEM WEEK CAN HELP US AVOID
HAZARDS LIKE EXPLOSIONS BEFORE
THEY HAPPEN.
ADDITIONALLY METHANE LEAKING
FROM THESE WELLS IS A
POTENTIALLY IMPORTANT SOURCE OF
GLOBAL WARMING EMISSIONS AND CO
POLLUTANTS LIKE BENZENE WHICH
HARM AIR QUALITY IN AFFECT HUMAN
HEALTH -- AND WITHOUT PROPER
TESTING LIKE CONTEMPLATED IN.
THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ARE THESE
LAWS CAN LEAK FOR SIGNIFICANT
PERIOD OF TIME BEFORE IT'S
DISCOVERED THAT THEY'RE LEAKING.
SO WE BELIEVE THE BETTER
UNDERSTANDING WHICH WELLS ARE
LIKE ITALY WILL HELP US TRACK
DOWN AND SEAL MORE LIKELY WELL
AS IN CALIFORNIA.
I AB THIRTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WILL
MAKE THIS POSSIBLE ME VERY MUCH
THANK ASSEMBLYMAN HOLD AND TO
BRING IT FOR THE FOR FRONT --
THE DATA THAT IS NECESSARY IS
ALREADY BEING COLLECTED BY OIL
AND GAS COMPANIES -- UNDER
CURRENT REGULATIONS FOR WELLS
THAT THEY ARE PLUGGING.
THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY MAKE IT
AVAILABLE MAKE THAT DATA
AVAILABLE TO BOTH REGULATORS AND
THE PUBLIC WHICH SURPRISINGLY IT
ISN'T ALREADY -- SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL THANK
YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
ROCKY RESCUED COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU.
QUITE A MEET ON A WITHOUT UPON
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THERESA PROHIBITS ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOVING COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
I WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN
LUNG ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU WAS THERE ANYONE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THREE CENTERS WITH THE
WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
QUITE DIFFERENT THAN WHERE WE
WERE HERE LAST YEAR APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR'S COMMITMENT.
ON THIS ISSUE ALONG WITH STAFF --
YOU KNOW WE CURRENTLY BELIEVE
THAT THERE'S A ROBUST -- A
RUBRIC FOR IN A LEAK DETECTION
REPAIR PROGRAMS OUT WE ALSO
BELIEVE THAT THE SNAP PROGRAM IS
ALSO GOING TO PROVIDE A LOT OF
SOME OF THE INFORMATION THAT THE
AUTHOR IN THE SPONSOR SEEK.
HOWEVER YOU KNOW WE ARE
COMMITTED TO WORKING AGAIN WITH
THE AUTHOR -- AND AND AND STAFF.
TO TO OBVIOUSLY WE'VE SHARED
LANGUAGE WE HOPE TO CONTINUE A
DIALOGUE TO TRY TO YOU KNOW
MAYBE REMEDIATE SO THE
COMPLIANCE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE
REDUCE COSTS BUT ALSO MAKE IT
MORE EFFICIENT -- AS AND AS IT
RELATES THE DATA THAT THE TRYING
TO ACCOMPLISH SO FOR THESE
REASONS YOU KNOW WE HAVE AN
OPPOSEUNLESS SOMEBODY POSITION
BY YOU KNOW WOULD LIKE TO
CONTINUE THE DIALOGUE TO THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS P. ANTHONY THOMAS
WRITTEN IN THE CALIFORNIA
INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION OR STEP UP -- JUST
THE RESPONSE TO THE RESPOND TO
THE BETTER UNDERSTANDING
STATEMENT THAT THE PROPONENTS
MAY.
WE SHOULD WE SHOULD.
KNOW THAT THERE IS A QUALITY
INSPECTION REQUIREMENT BY A. R.
B. TO QUANTIFY -- ANY LEAKS --
BUT THE TESTING DEVICE CALLED AN
EAGLE ON THAT DOES MEASURE TO
FLOW THE PPM -- THE LAB GIVES
YOU FULL CONCENTRATION SO LET'S
BE CLEAR THAT THERE IS WORK
BEING DONE IN THIS AREA.
AND FOR THE STATEMENT TO AT
LEAST BE SOMEONE INTERPRETED
THAT IT ISN'T IT IS -- AGAIN WE
FUNCTION ON THE SOME OF THE MOST
STRICT.
RULES AND REGULATIONS IN THE
NATION IF NOT THE WORLD'S SOLE
WHILE -- LEAKS ARE CONCERNED BOB
IDLE AND BAND WELLS ARE
CONCERNED THERE STILL ASSETS AND
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE
FUNCTIONS AND POLICIES IN PLACE
TO ADDRESS IT -- I WILL JOIN
WITH MY COUNTERPART FROM WESTERN
STATES TO SAY THAT WE TRYING TO
DO OUR BEST TO BURKE WITH THE
MEMBER -- BUT AT THE SAME TIME I
AS WE GO FORWARD THAT SHOULD BE
NOTED IN PLACE ON THE RECORD
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
YES SOME MEMBER.
ED IS IT YOUR INTENTION TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH ALL
PARTIES AS WE WE CAME THROUGH
YOUR IT WILL LAST YEAR AS YOU
CALL IN -- I DON'T THINK IT WAS
OUTCOME YOU WANT WHEN WE FINALLY
GOT TO THE FINISH LINE.
SO I'M THINKING YOU'LL.
WE WE WE WERE -- FULLY ENGAGED
AT THE START OF THE PROCESS I
THINK WE'VE BEEN INITIATED THE
THE INITIAL CONTACT AS THEY COME
ON AND LET'S TALK ABOUT THE BILL --
WE'VE DONE THE SAME THIS YEAR --
WILL CONTINUE -- TO WE'VE WE ARE
IN RECEIPT OF OF THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKE A LOOK AT
THEM AND WILL WORK WITH THEM AS
BEST WE CAN AND I THINK WE CAN
PROBABLY GET THERE.
THANK YOU -- I AM PLEASED TO BE
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL TODAY WHEN
WE HAVE FOR THE MEMBERS HERE.
WE'LL TAKE UP FOR A VOTE TO ANY
CLOSING STATEMENTS.
ARE RESPECTED US.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
IS IT OKAY TO SAY AGAIN.
BOB THIS IS A OKAY NEXT WE HAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS WITH
[inaudible]
EIGHT THIRTY SIX OKAY.
AND YOU CAN PROCEED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK AND
ASSISTANCE AND I ACCEPT THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
WILD FIRES IN RECENT YEARS HAVE
BEEN DEVASTATING TO OUR STATE.
IN ADDITION TO BURNING OVER ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION ACRES OF LAND
RECENT WILD FIRES IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND EIGHTEEN HAVE ALSO
DEMONSTRATE HOW THEY HAVE
IMPACTS.
IN THE AIR QUALITY FOR RESIDENTS
WHO LIVE HUNDREDS OF MILES AWAY
FROM THE BURN AREAS.
THE TOXIC AIR.
CONTAINS ELEVATED LEVELS OF WOOD
SMOKE AND CONTAMINANTS FROM BIRD
STRUCTURES VEHICLES AND CONSUMER
PRODUCTS.
THIS CONTAMINATED AIR CAUSES
PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES AS A
CONTROL THE LENGTH OF THE STATE
IN BECAUSE NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS TO ARE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS CHILDREN ELDERLY AND
INDIVIDUALS WITH EXISTING ROBERT
REST RESPIRATORY PROBLEMS. FOR
EXAMPLE DURING LAST YEAR'S
CAMPFIRE THE BAY AREA AND AREAS
IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCED THE WORST AIR
QUALITY.
THE SMOKE FROM THE FIRE DROP THE
AIR QUALITY IN CALIFORNIA TO THE
WORST IN THE WORLD.
AND PROMPTED MOST SCHOOL
DISTRICTS AND UNIVERSITIES TO
CLOSE THEIR CAMPUSES.
DURING THAT TIME THE AIR QUALITY
INDEX LEVELS WERE OVER TWO
HUNDRED AND MANY REGIONS SUCH AS
THE BEAR EXPERT EXPERIENCE POOR
AIR QUALITY. FOR ALMOST TWO
WEEKS.
I THINK YOU KNOW MY DAD FIGHTS
WILDFIRES IS ENOUGH FOR THIRTY
FIVE YEARS SO IT'S SOMETHING I'M
VERY USED -- TO IN OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THIS HEARING
ABOUT US BUT THE SAD REALITY IS
I THINK THAT WE HAVE TO PREPARE
THAT THIS IS OUR NEW NORMAL.
GIVEN THE CHALLENGES THAT WERE
SAYING -- WITH WILDFIRES AND I
THINK WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARED TO HANDLE THIS.
BEING OUR NEW NORMAL.
AB EIGHT THREE SIX WILL CREATE A
STATEWIDE PROGRAM THAT WOULD
IDENTIFY VENTILATION SPACES
WHICH WERE CALLING CLEANER
CENTERS.
THESE ARE PUBLIC OF PUBLIC
CENTERS LIKE SCHOOLS SENIOR
CENTERS -- LIBRARIES PLACES
WHERE PEOPLE CONGREGATE -- THAT
WOULD BE ACCESSIBLE TO THE
PUBLIC AND STUBBLE XIN INCENTIVE
PROGRAM.
THAT PROVIDES FUNDING. FOR THESE
FACILITIES TO IMPROVE THEIR L.
AIR FILTRATION SYSTEM.
AND LIVING IN THE BAY AREA IN
THE EAST BAY MANY OF US DON'T
HAVE AIR CONDITIONERS.
SO IF YOU'RE AT HOME YOU HAVE NO
AIR CONDITIONER A LOT OF THE
BUILDINGS DON'T HAVE THAT YOU
HAVE LITERALLY NO WHERE TO GO
WHEN THESE -- TERRIBLE AIR
QUALITY DAYS COME UP SO THAT'S
THE PURPOSE OF THE BILL I WANT
TO THANK THE SPONSORS THE BAY
AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT FOR THEIR SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION.
AND INTRODUCE OUR WITNESSES
ALLEN APES AND WILL BARNET.
SORRY BARRETT.
AND I RESPECT TO RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CHAIR FREEMEN MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN
ABS I'M WITH THE BAY AREA AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT I'D
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WICKS FOR INTRODUCING THIS BILL
AND FOR OPENING COMMENTS.
AT THE STATE HAS EMBARKED ON A
LONG TERM PLAN TO IMPROVE FOREST
HEALTH BUT WE KNOW THE LARGE
FOREST FIRES WILL IMPACT US FOR
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE. SIXTEEN
OF THE WORST TWENTY AIR QUALITY
DAYS IN BAY AREA HISTORY OF
OCCURRED IN THE LAST THREE YEARS
TO THE WILDFIRES -- TO FILL A
GAP IN OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE TO THESE EVENTS --
WE'VE PROPOSED THIS BILL TO
IDENTIFY PUBLIC SPACES THAT
CONNECT ACCOMMODATE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS CHILDREN
ELDERLY SOCIO ECONOMICALLY
DISADVANTAGED AND RESPIRATORY
EARLY CHALLENGED -- DURING
WILDFIRE SMOKE EVENTS OR OTHER
HIGH PARTICULAR EVENTS THIS
PROGRAM WILL NOT CONSTRUCT NEW
FACILITIES BUT WOULD PROVIDE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR EXISTING
FACILITIES OPEN TO THE PUBLIC TO
RECEIVE INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES
TO PROVIDE INDOOR VENTILATION
INFILTRATION.
ELIGIBLE FACILITIES COULD
INCLUDE SCHOOLS LIBRARIES
COMMUNITY SAID SANDERS AND OTHER
BUILDINGS OPEN TO THE PUBLIC
USAGE SUBJECT TO THE GUIDELINE
DEVELOPMENT AS A RESULT OF THIS
BILL.
WHEN WE FIRST INTRODUCED THIS
BILL WE DID -- IT WAS A BAY AREA
SPECIFIC BILL AND AND WE
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT -- IN NOT ALL
CASES OF A BAY AREA SOLUTIONS
FOR APPLE TO THE REST OF THE
STATE BUT WE HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE IS.
INTEREST IN EXPANSION OF THE
BILL AND SO -- WITH THAT I WOULD --
ENCOURAGE YOUR I. BUT WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M WILL BEAR
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION AS A KEY TOOL TO
PROTECT PEOPLE FROM GROWING
IMPACTS OF WILD FIRE SMOKE THE
CALIFORNIA.
THE RECENT FIRES HIGHLIGHTED THE
NEED FOR THESE CLEANER SPACES
ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE MOST
VULNERABLE AND UNABLE TO FIND
RELIEF FROM ON HEALTHIER DURING
THE WILDFIRES.
ANYONE EXPOSED TO HIGH LEVELS OF
PARTICLE POLLUTION IS AT REST
BUT AS ALLEN NOTED SEVERAL
GROUPS ARE AT HIGHER RISK
INCLUDING OUR CHILDREN SENIOR
CITIZENS THOSE LIVING WITH HEART
AND LUNG DISEASE AND LOWER
INCOME RESIDENTS.
ACCORDING TO EXTENSIVE RESEARCH
SHORT TERM INCREASES IN PARTICLE
POLLUTION HAVE BEEN LINKED TO
DEATH FROM RESPIRATORY AND
CARDIOVASCULAR CAUSES INCREASED
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND EMERGENCY
ROOM VISITS.
AND THE INCREASED SEVERITY OF
ASTHMA ATTACKS FACING CHILDREN.
THE FOURTH NATIONAL CLIMATE
ASSESSMENT RELEASED LAST YEAR
NOTED THE CALIFORNIA COULD
EXPERIENCE A 74% INCREASE AND
BURNED AREA -- BY THE END OF THE
CENTURY AND THAT NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA COULD POTENTIALLY
FACE A DOUBLING OF THE BURNT
AREA.
SO WE KNOW THAT THERE'S A
GROWING NEED FOR THIS TYPE OF
RESPONSE TO WILDFIRES THE LUNG
ASSOCIATION URGES YOU TO SUPPORT
AB EIGHT THIRTY SIX AS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL TO PROTECT.
THE HEALTH OF THE PUBLIC DURING
THIS GROWING THREAT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WILL RETURN TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE I'D BE HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY AND WHEN
WE GET A QUORUM WILL BE HAVING A
VOTE ON IT.
THANK YOU DO YOU WANT TO CLOSE
OUT JUST ASK YOUR AYE VOTE OKAY
THANK THEM VERY MUCH
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
NEXT.
IS MR TANG HERE.
MR COOLEY.
UP MR COOLEY IS COMING UP RIGHT.
FOUR AB TWO AND
NINETY SIX GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES.
IT'S A PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE.
SPEAKER TODAY BECAUSE FOR IN AB.
TWO NINETY SIX AND THIS BILL
ESTABLISHES THE CLIMB INNOVATION
GRANT PROGRAM WITHIN THE
STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNSEL.
INVOLVED WAVE INTRODUCTION THE
SUBJECT MATTER I WANT TO SAY
THAT THE I'VE ACTUALLY HAD AN
INTEREST IN INNOVATION ADVOCACY
FOR LEAST FIFTEEN YEARS.
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND THREE I WAS
FOUNDER OF THE CITY OF RANCHO
CORDOVA WHICH IS OF COURSE A
TYPE OF INNOVATION.
AND I PUT TOGETHER MY THOUGHTS
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF INNOVATION.
IN A SPEECH I DID BACK THEN
WHICH I'VE OFTEN UPDATED.
BUT SO KEY IDEAS IN THE REALM OF
INNOVATION.
A GREAT COMMENT BY HARVEY
FIRESTONE WHO ONCE SAID.
THOUGHT NOT MONEY IS THE REAL
BUSINESS CAPITAL.
THE ABILITY TO BRING FORWARD A
NEW IDEA IS OFTEN THE MOST VITAL
ELEMENT IN ANY.
HUMAN ENTERPRISE [inaudible]
MARK TWAIN.
ALSO WAS A FAVORITE ON
INNOVATION HE SAYS THE MAN WITH
A NEW IDEA IS A CRANK.
UNTIL IT SUCCEEDS.
IDEAS TEST THE BOUNDARIES OF
WHAT WE EXPECT.
AND A LOT OF OUR FUTURE DEPENDS
UPON IT.
AND THEN THE LAST COMMENT ON
INNOVATION JUST AS A PRELUDE TO
THIS IS THAT.
ALL GREAT HUMAN ENDEAVOR HAS TO
EVOLVE THROUGH THREE WORDS
[inaudible]
IMPOSSIBLE [inaudible]
IMPROBABLE [inaudible]
INEVITABLE.
AND I FEEL I I AGREE WITH OUR
GOVERNOR FORMER GOVERNOR WHO.
NOTICED THE CLIMATE CRISIS IS
NEXT SUBSTANTIAL.
ONE AND SO WE ARE IN NEED OF
OUTSTANDING IDEAS TO PUSH BACK
THE BOUNDARIES OF WHAT IS KNOWN.
WHAT PEOPLE THINK IS POSSIBLE?
ON AB TWO DONE A SEARCH FOR THE
CLIMB RIVERS GRANT PROGRAM.
WILL SEEK TO ACCELERATE AND
SUPPORT THE RESEARCH INVOLVING
NEW INNOVATIONS.
THAT IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY
RESILIENT TO THE IMPACTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE.
I WANT TO SEE THE COMMITTEE HAS
OFFERED TO SUGGEST A MUCH WHICH
I AM PLEASED TO ACCEPT.
I ACTUALLY FEEL THE CHANGE
PROTECT HER FROM PROMOTE TO
CONTRIBUTE IS VERY IMPORTANT.
BECAUSE SOMETIMES THE ROLE OF
SCIENCE IS NOT TO GIVE YOU A
WHOLLY NEW IDEA.
BUT ACTUALLY TO CONTRIBUTE TO
THE IMPLEMENTATION IDEA BY
MAKING IT'S A CHEAPER MORE
FEASIBLE.
WHAT I REFER TO IS AS OF?
REDUCING THE RISK.
OF CHANGE.
AND SO WE ACTUALLY NEED IDEAS
NOT JUST THE BIG IDEAS.
BUT THE ONES THAT MAKE CHANGE
TOOK LESS RISKY MORE MANAGEABLE
MORE FEES WHEN I ACTUALLY THINK
THAT THAT CHANGE.
KIND OF MOVES MADE THAT
DIRECTION SO I'M APPRECIATIVE OF
THAT [inaudible]
ARM.
WE KNOW FOR THE FROM LAST
OCTOBER'S UNITED NATIONS
INTERGOVERNMENTAL PANEL CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THAT WE ARE SEEN CHANGES RELATED
TO CLIMATE ALL ACROSS THE GLOBE
THEY ARE LIFE THREATENING.
AND HERE IN CALIFORNIA ON
DECEMBER EIGHTEENTH ARE LA --
ISSUE IN THEIR REPORT ON OUR
CLIMATE POLICIES.
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDED THAT THE
STATE'S SUPPORT INNOVATION.
AND ADDRESS OTHER IT.
A MEANS OF SUPPORT ENVIRONMENTAL.
IMPACTS AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S
A WIDE ARRAY OF POLICIES CAN
AFFECT.
CLIMATE POLICIES GREENHOUSE
GRASS REDUCTIONS CO BENEFITS
DIRECT COSTS INDIRECT BENEFITS
ECONOMIC TRANSFERS.
ENERGY THERE THE ROLE OF
CALIFORNIA ON ALL THESE FRONTS.
IS A LEADERSHIP ROLE IN ITSELF
ONE OF INNOVATION.
FROM TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN
CARP FIRST PRODUCED ITS
RECOMMENDATIONS TO TWO THOUSAND
FOURTEEN MORE RECENTLY AND TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE KEEP
CHANGING THE CONVERSATION.
AND GLOBALLY CALIFORNIA'S LEAD
IN THAT CONVERSATION AND THIS
WILL BE A PART OF THAT.
PROCESS.
ARM.
THE BILL PROPOSED THE USE OF A
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROCESS TOWARD
MATCHING GRANT FUNDS. FOR
INNOVATIONS IMPROVE ADAPTABILITY
AND RESILIENT TO CLIMATE CHANGE.
IT DOES OFFER A DIFFERENT
ECONOMIC TOOL THEN JUST BARELY
GRANTS A PUBLIC FUNDS.
BUT INVITING PERSONS WHO WISH TO
OF RESEARCH [inaudible] TO
PARTNER WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE STRATEGIC
GROWTH COUNSEL TO FUND THESE
PROGRAMS.
AND I ACTUALLY THINK THIS IS.
IT IS VERY APPROPRIATE FOR
CALIFORNIA UTILIZE THIS TYPE OF
TOOL. TO INVITE THE PARTNERSHIP
OF OTHERS.
I CAN QUOTE THE ANCIENT AND I
GUESS WAS FROM THIRTY FOUR
HUNDRED BC ANCIENT SANSKRIT.
PROVERB [inaudible]
THE ENEMY.
OF MY ENEMY IS MY FRIEND.
I THINK CALIFORNIA IS ALWAYS A
STATUS IT IS THE ENEMY OF GLOBAL
WARMING.
THAT WANTS TO BE AGGRESSIVE IN
BATTLING GLOBAL WARMING.
AND IF THERE ARE.
INSTITUTIONS OUT THERE THAT WILL
ASSIST US IN THAT.
AND ASSIST OUR STATE.
THEN SURELY THEY ARE OUR FRIEND
ON THIS TOPIC.
IN THIS BILL AND BODIES THIS
IDEA.
THE PEOPLE WHO LIKE CALIFORNIA
ONE ABOUT A GLOBAL WARM IF
THEY'RE WILLING TO PARTNER.
A WE SHOULD BE OPEN TO THAT.
COM [inaudible]
I AM.
SO THIS BILL DOES NOT CONFLICT
WITH THE ELECTRIC PROGRAM
INVESTMENT CHARGE PROGRAM THE
EPIC CHARGE OR THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION.
FUND G. G. R. RAF.
AND I'M DELIGHTED TODAY TO HAVE
MERRY SELECCIONA AJ W. REPRESENT
THE LARA INSTITUTE TO TALK ABOUT
THE ROLE OF FUNDING FOR
INNOVATION.
SO MERRY.
HI THERE CHAIR FRIEDMAN VICE
CHAIR FULLER APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME TODAY I JOIN YOU AS A
REPRESENTATIVE MY NAME IS MERRY
SO LACKEY HI -- IT AND
REPRESENTING THE LAR TO
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINETY SIX LARA IS A LOS ANGELES
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
WITH THE CORE MISSION OF
TRANSFORMING IDEAS AND RESEARCH
INTO MARKET READY PRODUCTS.
SINCE LURCHES FOUNDING IN
NINETEEN NINETY THREE BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN --
COMMERCIALIZATION PARTNER TO TOP
FEDERAL AGENCIES INCLUDING AND I
H. ANISSA NEST NOAH AND U. S. T.
A..
AND HAS ASSISTED OVER SEVEN
THOUSAND CALIFORNIA COMPANIES
BRINGING THEIR RESEARCH TO
MARKET.
LOTUS WORK IS NASH ON A NATIONAL
SCALE THE HAS PROFOUND IMPACTS
ON THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
LIKE TO SUPPORTIVE OF THIS BILL
BECAUSE ACROSS THE COUNTRY WE
SEE IF THE ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
DOLLARS INVESTED INTO RESEARCH
YIELDS POSITIVE ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES.
WE RECOGNIZE THE BILL AUTHORS
INTENTIONS TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE BY ALLOCATING RESOURCES
FOR CLIMATE RELATED RESEARCH WE
ARE PARTICULARLY EXCITED TO BE
WORKINGWITH THE AUTHORS OFFICES
ON THE OPPORTUNITY TO BRIDGE THE
GAP.
FROM RESEARCH TO MARKET READY
PRODUCTS AND SERVICES.
THE ESTABLISHMENT OF THE CAP
CLIMATE INNOVATION GRANT PROGRAM
WOULD NOT ONLY ADVANCE
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE GOALS BUT
WILL BRING POSITIVE ECONOMIC
GROWTH TO THE STATE TO
FUNDAMENTAL ELEMENTS THAT
PARALLEL LOWER TO THE CORE
MISSION.
BASED ON WHAT LOWER TO HAS SEEN
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THIS GRANT
PROGRAM UTILIZES THE SUCCESSFUL
MODEL THAT WE SEE ELSEWHERE IN
THE U. S. WHICH IS LEVERAGING
MATCHING FUNDS.
AND THUS COMBINING MANY FUNDING
SOURCES FOR RESEARCH ESPECIALLY
PLIED RESEARCH.
BY WAY OF EXAMPLE COMPANIES LIKE
MANGO MATERIALS CAN TURN THEIR
RESEARCH AND TO MARKET READY
PRODUCTS WITH THE HELP OF
FEDERAL AND STATE FUNDING
PROGRAMS AND ACCELERATORS.
MAKE A MATERIALS IS BASED IN
BERKELEY AND PRODUCES A BY A
POLYMER FROM RECYCLED METHANE
AND CREATES BIOPLASTICS.
MAKE A MATERIALS WAS STARTED BY
THREE WOMEN ENGINEERS AND WAS
AWARDED RESEARCH UNDING BUT
THEN UTILIZED FULLER TO THE
TREES SERVICES TO HELP PROPEL
THEIR PRODUCT INTO THE MARKET.
LARGE WHO WOULD LIKE TO BE ABLE
TO PROVIDE SIMILAR SERVICES YOUR
TIME IS UP SO IF YOU CAN FINISH
UP.
ANY STATE FUNDED RESEARCH IN
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT AND AB TWO NINETY SIX
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
ANOTHER WHAT ANYONE ELSE WHO
WANTS TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL. FOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA AND
SUPPORT.
NATALIE NEXT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA TROUT AND SUPPORT.
HAVING DORKIN SOME BEHALF A
SMART IN SUPPORT.
ADAM ROBIN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
IS THERE ANYONE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ARE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
A SEEING YET NONE I WILL BE --
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL WHEN WE
HAVE A QUORUM I'M WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
AGAIN I WANT TO THANK THE WORK
DONE BY YOUR COMMITTEE STAFF
MADAM CHAIR.
AND I I QUOTED BY OLD SANSKRIT
PROVERB FULL QUOTE A MORE
CONTEMPORARY.
ONE FROM THAT RUSSIA.
RELATIVELY RECENT LIVED
INDIVIDUAL BEN FRANKLIN.
ON THE IMPORTANCE OF NOT
OVERLOOKING ANYTHING WHICH IS
WHAT THIS BILL WILL HELP MAKE
SURE WE DO NOT DO IN CALIFORNIA.
FOR WANT OF A NAIL THE SHOE WAS
LOST FOR ONE OF THE SHOE THE
HORSE WAS LOST FOR WANT OF A
HORSE THE WRITER WAS LOST. FOR
ONE OF THE WRITER THE BATTLES
LOSS FOR ONE OF THE BATTLE THE
KINGDOM WAS LOST AND ALL FOR
WANT OF A NAIL.
I THINK THAT IN THIS ERA OF
EXISTENTIAL THREATS.
WHEN LEADERSHIP IS NEEDED AROUND
THE GLOBE?
AND OUR STATE IS PROVIDED THAT
LEADERSHIP IN A DRAMATIC WAY.
I THINK BEING OPEN TO ANYONE WHO
HAS AN IDEA THAT THEY CAN MAKE
THE CASE MAY HELP US DEAL WITH
GREENHOUSE.
THE HOUSE GAS PROBLEMS WRITTEN
LARGE AS SOME RISE LA -- REPORT.
INCLUDING THAT NEW WANTS OF
CONTRIBUTING TO CHANGE BY MAKING
A BIG ASPIRATION LOOK MORE
MANAGEABLE TO DE RESPECT
ASPIRATIONS.
THIS IS A GREAT.
PUBLIC SERVICE TO CALIFORNIA'S
BUT INDEED TO THE GLOBE I THINK
A. B. FITS OUR STATE CHOICES FOR
QUESTION RIGHT VOTE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OUR IS MISTER TAYLOR HERE.
NOT WE'RE MOVING TO MISTER
MULLIN WITH AB.
EIGHT THIRTY NINE YOU MAY BEGIN
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AB EIGHT
THIRTY NINE IS A BILL TO MOVE
CALIFORNIA FORWARD.
IN OUR EFFORTS TO ADAPT TO THE
INCREASING RISKS BROUGHT ON BY
CLIMATE CHANGE.
THE COURT IN CALIFORNIA'S FOURTH
CLIMATE ESTIMATE THE ECONOMIC
COST TO CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATED
WITH DIRECT CLIMATE IMPACTS BY
TWENTY FIFTY IS ESTIMATED AT
OVER ONE HUNDRED BILLION DOLLARS
EACH YEAR.
THIS STAGGERING FIGURE IS
ATTRIBUTABLE. TO DAMAGES TO
COASTAL PROPERTIES THE POTENTIAL
FOR DROUGHTS FIRES AND MAKE A
FLOODS AND ALARMINGLY HUMAN
MORTALITY.
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE GREAT WORK
TO DATE INVESTING IN RESEARCH
AND DEVELOPING GUIDANCE IN
PLANNING AS OUTLINED IN THE
BILL'S ANALYSIS.
I INTRODUCED AB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE IN RESPONSE TO THE CALL THE
MY OFFICE IS HEARD FROM THE
NUMEROUS ORGANIZATIONS AROUND
THE STATE THAT ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THAT WE NEED TO IMPLEMENT MORE
TEETH TO OUR EXISTING EFFORTS
SIR TO ACCOMPLISH THAT THE BILL
DESIGNATES THE SECRETARY OF
NATURAL RESOURCES. TO LEAD THE
STATE'S CLIMATE ADAPTATION
STRATEGY AND TO DEVELOP A
STRATEGIC RESILIENCY FRAMEWORK
THAT BILLS ON THE SAFEGUARDING
CALIFORNIA PLAN.
CRITICALLY THAT FRAMEWORK WILL
INCLUDE RECOMMENDED ACTIONS WITH
TIMETABLES AND METRICS TO
MEASURE THE STATE'S PROGRESS IN
BUILDING AND INVESTING IN
ADAPTATION AND RESILIENCY
PROJECTS EACH STATE AGENCY
IDENTIFIED IN THE FRAMEWORK.
REPORT TO THE SECRETARY ON ITS
PROGRESS COMPLETELY THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ACTIONS.
ADDITIONALLY WE WOULD CREATE THE
ADAPTATION THROUGH RESILIENCY
ECONOMIC VITALITY IN EQUITY
ACCOUNT WHERE FUNDS FOR
ADAPTATION PROJECTS CAN BE
CONSOLIDATED WE WANT THE NATURAL
THE DIRECTOR OF STATE PLANNING
AND RESEARCH. TO DEVELOP GRANTS
AND INNOVATIVE FINANCING
MECHANISM SUCH AS LOANS FOR
EXAMPLE TO IMPLEMENTED THE
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ACTIONS OF
THE FRAMEWORK FUNDING THE
ACCOUNT COULD BE FROM EXISTING
OR FUTURE BOND DOLLARS.
ALSO WE'RE NOT CURRENTLY
ALLOCATING VERY MUCH MONEY FROM
THE G. G. R. F. TO ADDRESS OUR
CONSIDERABLE ADAPTATION NEEDS
BUT PERHAPS IN THE FUTURE WILL
CONSIDER THAT DIFFERENTLY.
IN THIS ACCOUNT CAN SERVICE THE
APPROPRIATE INSTRUMENT TO ENSURE
THOSE DOLLARS ARE SPENT
EFFECTIVELY WHERE THAT FUNDING
WILL COME FROM IS SUBJECT TO
FUTURE APPROPRIATIONS SO WE WILL
BE ABLE TO REALLY PINPOINT THOSE
SOURCES IN FUTURE BUDGET VOTES
TO SOME RICE I'M CONFIDENT THAT
THE BILL WILL ENACT A CLEAR.
CLIMATE.
ADAPTATION FRAMEWORK TO GUIDE
THE STATE OVER THE COMING YEARS
TO ENSURE WE HAVE A THOUGHTFUL
SET OF GOALS COORDINATED
GOVERNMENT ACTIONS AND
INNOVATIVE FUNDING MECHANISMS IN
PLACE.
GIVEN THE BREATH COMPLEXITY
PERVASIVENESS AND DANGER OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THIS
ACCOUNTABILITY IS NEEDED AND I
ASKED FOR THE COMMITTEES SUPPORT.
THANK YOU YOUR WITNESSES PLEASE.
BOB GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
GEORGE ON AND I'M CHIEF
SCIENTIST WITH OCEAN CONSERVANCY.
AND WE WORK FOR FORTY YEARS TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE BIGGEST
THREATS TO OCEAN HEALTH.
IN THE OCEAN AS ON LAND CLIMATE
CHANGE IS NOW THE BIGGEST LONG
TERM THREAT TO THE PLAN ITSELF.
BUT CLIMATE CHANGE IS ALSO A
MAJOR THREAT TODAY RIGHT NOW TO
THE STATE'S PEOPLE PROPERTY
ECONOMY IS A NATURAL RESOURCES.
SINCE TWO THOUSAND TWELVE
CALIFORNIA'S EXPERIENCE SOME OF
THE MOST EXTREME NATURAL EVENTS
IN A RECORDED HISTORY OF COURSE
DROUGHT RAVAGING WILDFIRES BACK
TO BACK YEARS.
WITH THE WARMEST AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES AND IF GREENHOUSE
GASES AREN'T REDUCED AVERAGE
TEMPERATURES ACROSS THE STRAIT
WILL STE OF THE STATE WILL
LIKELY BE NINE DEGREES
FAHRENHEIT WARMER.
IN JUST FIFTY YEARS WITH THE
SNOW PACK REDUCED BY TWO THIRDS
SEA LEVEL RISING BY
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FOUR INCHES.
AND HIGH HEAT HEALTH EVENTS THE
COULD LAST UP TO TWO WEEKS.
CALIFORNIA'S CAUGHT A FOURTH
CLIMATE ASSESSMENT AND THE
STATE'S THEY'VE COURTING
CALIFORNIA PLAN HAVE HELPED TO
PREPARE THE STATE BUT MORE WORK
AS WE'VE HEARD IS NEEDED.
AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE IS REALLY A
NEXT PHASE IN CLIMATE ADAPTATION
FOR THE STATE.
PROACTIVE ADAPTIVE PLANNING
ESPECIALLY IN RESPONSE TO
RAPIDLY DEVELOPED DEL VALLE
UPPING SCIENCE IS CRITICAL TO
ENSURE THAT THE STATE'S DAYS
AHEAD OF THE CHANGES.
THAT ARE UNDER WAY AB EIGHT
THIRTY NINE WILL PROVIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY. TO ENSURE THE
STATE'S PRIORITY ACTIONS ARE
BASED ON A CLEAR EYED ASSESSMENT
OF THE THREATS OVER THE LONG
TERM.
IT WILL PUT TEETH BEHIND THE
SAFEGUARDING PLAN TO ENSURE
RECOMMENDATIONS ARE IMPLEMENTED
IN A TIMELY MANNER.
THAT THEY DELIVER THE ADAPTATION
BENEFITS THAT WE DESIRE AND THAT
WE DEVELOPED METRICS OF SUCCESS.
TO ENSURE THAT WE HOLD OURSELVES
ACCOUNTABLE.
WHILE THE STATE HAS BEEN A REAL
LEADER AN ADAPTATION PLANNING
AND POLICY TO DATE IT IS NEVER
REALLY EMBARKED ON A
COMPREHENSIVE POLICY TO CREATE
GOALS REQUIRE BETTER
COORDINATION.
AND PUSHED INNOVATIVE FINANCING
A AB EIGHT THIRTY NINE GOES A
LONG WAY IN DOING THAT AND
THAT'S WHY WE ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU THE NEXT WITNESS.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS READ AT US ON
BEHALF OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
COMMISSION I HAVE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON CLIMATE
ADAPTATION HERE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS.
IN PARTICULAR -- WE'VE BEEN ABLE
TO WORK ON REGIONAL
COLLABORATIVE'S AND HAVE BEEN
ABLE TO HOST THE ADAPTATION FORM
THAT OCCURS -- HERE IN
CALIFORNIA.
BASED ON THAT WORK WE'RE REALLY
INTERESTED IN THIS BILL IN
PARTICULAR NOT ONLY BECAUSE THE
ELEMENTS THAT FOCUS ON NATURAL
RESOURCES.
BUT THE ELEMENTS OF THE BILLS
THAT THE FOCUS IS ON COMMUNITY
RESILIENCY.
WE'RE LOOKING AT AT PROVISIONS
THAT ADDRESS ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE AND PEOPLE AS WELL AS
NATURE AND SO WE WE REALLY LIKE
THAT ABOUT THE MEASURE. TWO
OTHER ITEMS WILL MENTION.
BECAUSE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
MACHINE CONSERVANCY COVERED ALL
OF THE OTHER ONES BUT THE
INNOVATIVE FINANCING ELEMENT OF
THE BILL.
WE THINK IT'S CRITICAL THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO HAVE
TO DEAL WITH A RED RATHER LARGE
BILL TO DEAL WITH CLIMATE
ADAPTATION.
IT'S GOING TO TAKE A LOT OF
INNOVATIVE FINANCING AND THE
FINANCE THOUGHTFUL APPROACH TO
DO THAT AND WE THINK THIS
MEASURE.
HELPS THE STATE YEAH GET GO A
LONG WAY IN TRYING TO DO WITH
THOSE FINANCIAL.
NEEDS.
AND THEN FINALLY THERE'S A
POLICY IN HERE THAT WE THINK IS
REALLY USEFUL MAKING SURE THAT
WE'RE ALL ROWING IN THE SAME
DIRECTION.
MAKING SURE THAT THE NATURAL
RESOURCE AGENCIES ALSO TALKING
TO THEIR INSURANCE COMMISSIONER
TO MAKE SURE THAT POLICIES ARE
LINE FOR THOSE REASONS WERE IN
STRONG SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
NATALIE LACKS ON BEHALF OF
COMMUNITY NATURE CONNECTION
FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER LAND
JUST A SANTA CRUZ COUNTY SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE MIDLANDS
NAME MID PENINSULA REGIONAL OPEN
SPACE DISTRICT AND CALIFORNIA'S
ISSUES ASSOCIATION OF LOCAL
CONSERVATION COURSE AND CANCER
NO DAY WOULD SAVE OUR SHORES IN
SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA.
IN SUPPORT.
THROUGH THE WRECKAGE ON BEHALF
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
HI JENNIFER SAVAGE SURFRIDER IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YEARS OR ANYBODY WANTED TO
TESTIFY ON IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE OF IS ANYONE FROM
THE COMMITTEE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER MOM WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
MY VOTE THANK YOU I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL AND WILL DO SO
LET ME HAVE A FORM.
THANK YOU.
AS MISTER KALRA HERE
[inaudible]
MS BURKE [inaudible]
MR O'DONNELL [inaudible]
MR GLORIA [inaudible]
STIR GALLAGHER.
AND SO THAT THE COMMITTEE -- IS
CLEAR WE'RE GOING TO BE HEARING
TESTIMONY ON THIS BILL TODAY BUT
WE WILL NOT BE VOTING ON THIS
BILL TODAY. TO GIVE THE AUTHOR
MORE TIME TO WORK WITH MYSELF
AND THE COMMITTEE -- ON
AMENDMENTS -- THE THAT I BELIEVE
THE THE BILL NEEDS -- BEFORE CAN
BE VOTED ON SO WITH THAT MISTER
GALLAGHER.
YOU MAY OPEN.
YEAH THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- APPRECIATE YOUR TIME
THIS -- THIS AFTERNOON -- MANY
PEN THAT I'M WORKING ON MY
JACKET.
OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS AND THIS
PEN RIGHT HERE ACTUALLY
REPRESENTS THE FLAG OF THE TOWN
OF PARADISE -- WRAPPED WITH THE
AMERICAN FLAG IT WAS GIVEN TO ME
BY -- FORMER MAYOR PARADISE
SCOTT LAUDER.
WHO'S HERE WITH US TODAY --
INDIA AS MANY YOU KNOW THIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT HAS HAPPENED UP IN
THESE IN THESE COMMUNITIES -- IN
BUTTE COUNTY WITH THE CAMP
FIRE'S BEEN VERY CLOSE TO MY
HEART IT'S BEEN A BIG PART OF MY
LEGISLATIVE PACKAGE -- THIS YEAR --
IN TRYING TO DO EVERYTHING THAT
WE CAN TO HELP PEOPLE RECOVER.
HIDE SO IN THAT LIGHT I'M I'M
PROUD TO PRESENT AB FOUR THIRTY
THE THE CAMPFIRE HOUSING
ASSISTANCE ACT OF TWO THOUSAND
AND NINETEEN AS YOU ALL KNOW --
THE CAMPFIRE WAS THE DEADLIEST
AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE WILDFIRE IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
AND DEVASTATED THE COMMUNITIES
OF MAY GALIA KHôNG CAL YANKEE
HILL.
AND PARADISE.
THE FIREDISPLAYS FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE.
IN THE DAYS SINCE NOVEMBER
EIGHTH I'VE I'VE TALKED WITH
COUNTLESS.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS.
WHO HAVE DETAILED THEIR HORROR
STORIES OF?
HAVE LITERALLY GOING THROUGH
HELL -- AND MAKE IT OUT ALIVE IN
THE TERROR THAT THAT WENT WITH
THAT.
BUT ALSO THE HELL OF THE
AFTERMATH.
OF THIS DISASTER OF NOT HAVING
THE SAFETY SECURITY AND COMFORT.
OF A HOME AND WE ALL KNOW THAT
IT'S YOU KNOW WE WE HAVE TO DO
IN THIS JOB WE WE TRAVEL A LOT
AND HOW GREAT IT FEELS TO BE
ABLE TO COME.
HOME. TO BE IN YOUR HOME TO HAVE
THAT -- YEAH BASICALLY THAT
REFUGE -- THAT A HOME PROVIDES.
SO MANY THESE FIFTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE DON'T HAVE THAT -- WE
HAVE -- WAY TOO MANY PEOPLE
STILL LIVING IN RV'S AND
TRAILERS [inaudible]
EVEN TENSE.
DURING THESE -- WINTER WEATHER --
CONDITIONS AND ALSO FAR TOO MANY
THAT ARE STILL HOMELESS.
AND THERE WERE ALREADY WAS A
HOMELESS ISSUE AND IN THE AREA
BUT THIS HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE FIRE.
IT WILL TAKE YEARS FOR THESE
COMMUNITIES TO REBUILD.
AND IN THE MEANTIME EVACUEES
NEED TO BE ABLE TO FIND.
STABLE HOUSING -- WHILE MANY AND
THERE'S A VERY STRONG CONTINGENT
OF PEOPLE THAT WILL CHOOSE TO
REBUILD IN PARADISE IN FACT I
HAD A MEETING THIS MORNING.
WITH MEMBERS OF THE TOWN OF
PARADISE WORKING ON REBUILDING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE IS GOING TO
BE A VITAL CORNERSTONE OF THAT.
BUT STILL OTHERS WILL HAVE TO
TRY AND FIND PERMANENT HOUSING
IN SURROUNDING AREAS OTHERS WILL
NEED HOUSING IN THE INTERIM AS
THEY START TO MAKE THOSE PLANS.
FOR REBUILDING BUT HERE'S THE
PROBLEM.
THE CAMP FIRE DESTROYED FORT
DESTROYED FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMES. 14% OF BUTTE COUNTY'S
HOUSING STOCK.
AND THE COUNTY FELL SEVENTEEN
PLACES MORE THAN ANY OTHER
COUNTY IN THE STATE ON THE
AFFORDABILITY INDEX.
THE RENTAL MARKET VACANCY RATE
ALSO FELL TO NEARLY 0%.
AFTER THE FIRE THERE IS
LITERALLY NO HOUSING. FOR PEOPLE
WHO DESPERATELY WANT TO FIND
HOUSING IN THIS AREA.
THESE COMMUNITIES HAVE A STRONG
SENSE OF PLACE AND THIS IS
SOMETHING I REALLY WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THIS IS WHERE THEY
WANT TO LIVE. TO TO WORK TO
RAISE A FAMILY.
AND IT MAKES IT EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT FOR CAMPFIRE VICTIMS
AND OTHERS TO FIND THAT HOUSING
IN THIS IN THIS REGION IN THIS
PLACE -- THAT THEY WANT TO LIVE
EVEN THOUGH MANY WANT TO STAY IN
THE AREA WHERE THEY HAVE JOBS
THEY STILL HAVE JOBS THEY HAVE.
FAMILIES THEY HAVE KIDS THAT
NEED TO GO TO SCHOOL.
THEY HAVE MANY COMMUNITY
CONNECTIONS SOCIAL CLUBS AT
THEIR INVOLVED WHEN THEY WANT TO
STAY IN THE AREA.
NOT LONG AFTER THE FIRE AND THAT
WITH MANY LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS --
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
WITH CITY MANAGERS WITH THE
COUNTY GOVERNMENT.
WITH HOUSING ADVOCATES.
REALTORS -- THE WHOLE THE WHOLE
RANGE ALL OF THEM IDENTIFIED
SEEK WAS THE NUMBER ONE
IMPEDIMENT. TO BUILDING MORE
HOUSING IN THE IN THE IN IN THIS
EMERGENCY SITUATION.
AND SO WITH THAT IN MIND WE KNOW
THAT CURRENT LAW ALLOWS SOME
HOUSING PROJECTS TO BE PERMITTED
BY CITY OR COUNTY PLANNING STAFF
MINISTERIAL E..
THERE BY STREAMLINING -- PROJECT
APPROVAL ONLY SEEN SOME BILLS
LIKE THAT BEFORE -- MOST
RECENTLY SB THIRTY FIVE FROM
SENATOR WIENER WHICH PASSED IN.
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHICH EXPANDED
THIS MINISTERIAL PROCESS THAT
HELPS IT AND ENSURE CERTAIN
INFILL PROJECTS IN AREAS.
THAT HAVE NOT MET THEIR HOUSING
GOALS CAN BE DONE I AM TRYING TO
TAILOR.
THIS BILL AB. FOUR THIRTY TO DO
EXACTLY JUST THAT BUT FOR THE
BUTTE COUNTY REGION.
THAT IS IT IS NARROWLY FOCUSED
IN A PUT IN IT APPLIES THIS
STREAMLINED MINISTERIAL APPROVAL
PROCESS FOR THE REBUILDING OF
HOMES IN URBAN AREAS OF THE CAP
AND BUTTE COUNTY THIS IS NOT
SPRAWL.
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES TO THE
URBAN AREAS OF CHICO GRIDLEY IN
ORVILLE.
AND INCLUDES PROTECTIONS TO
PREVENT DEVELOPMENTS FROM BEING
BUILT.
IN FLOOD PLAINS.
IN PROTECTED AGRICULTURAL LANDS
IN FACT IN BUTTE COUNTY WE HAVE
A LONG STANDING ORDINANCE WHICH
IS KNOWN AS THE GREEN LINE.
THAT KEEPS -- PROJECTS FROM
BEING BUILT -- IN PRIME
AGRICULTURAL LANDS IN BUTTE
COUNTY.
IT ALSO PREVENTS IT FROM BEING
BUILT ON ENVIRONMENTALLY
SENSITIVE LANDS.
THE DEVELOPMENT ALSO MUST BE
CONSISTENT WITH LOCAL ZONING AND
GENERAL PLAN DESIGNATIONS.
IF THE LAND IS NOT CURRENTLY
ZONED FOR RESIDENTIAL AND MULTI
USE RESIDENTIAL.
IT WILL NOT BE ABLE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS PROCESS.
SO IT IS A VERY LIMITED BUT IT'S
A VERY SURGICAL.
BILL THAT WILL ALLOW US TO BRING
ONLINE HOUSING STOCK IN IN
PLACES WHERE WE'VE ALREADY SAID
AS LOCAL COMMUNITIES WE WANT --
TO IT WILL PROVIDE A MUCH NEEDED
INCENTIVE TO BRING THIS ONLINE
AND SO -- AGAIN THIS BILL HAS A
LOT OF VERY BROAD.
LOCAL SUPPORT YOU SEE.
AS VERY VERY MANY LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS WHO HAVE WHO HAVE
COME ON BOARD IN SUPPORT OF THIS
YOU'RE GONNA HEAR FROM MANY OF
THEM TODAY -- SIERRA CLUB IS THE
ONLY REGISTERED OPPOSITION. TO
THIS BILL AT THIS POINT AND I
HAVE COMMITTED TO MAKING
AMENDMENTS TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS ARE OUTLINED IN THEIR
LETTER.
AND THEY WILL TALK ABOUT THAT
TODAY AS WELL.
NOT SO WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR THIRTY I
HAVE JENNIFER MORRIS -- THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE NORTH
VALLEY PROPERTY ASSOCIATION AND
TOM LANDAU -- THE CITY MANAGER
OF THE CITY OF OR BILL.
HE'LL JUST GIVE US A MOMENT ONE
OF SELFLESS A QUORUM BEFORE WE
MOVE FORWARD.
WE CAN HAVE A ROLL CALL.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HERE FRIEDMAN
HERE FLOOR FLOOR HERE CHAU
[inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN HERE GARCIA.
GARCIA HERE LONG.
MATHIS.
MATHIS HERE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY HERE MELINDA'S THE LAND
IS HERE MURATSUCHI STONE
[inaudible]
OKAY.
THE WITNESSES CAN PROCEED THANK
THANK YOU.
I'M TOM WINDOWS WITH MENTION ON
THE INTERIM CITY ADMINISTRATORS
IN YOUR BILL.
HI I WAS WITH THE CITY OF CHICO
FOR ABOUT TWENTY SIX YEARS MOST
OF IT IS OUR CITY MANAGER -- I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE TO US.
AS I SAT BACK I ALREADY HEARD.
THE CAMPFIRE REFERENCED AT LEAST
THREE TIMES IN IN WITH YOUR
PREVIOUS SPEAKERS.
THIS IS AN EMERGENCY OUR ECONOMY
IN THE REGION IS AT RISK.
YOU COUNTIES OF LOW INCOME
COUNTY WITH A LITTLE MORE THAN
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AS YOU HEARD FIFTY THOUSAND HOME
MORE BURN OUT OF THEIR HOMES.
WHEN FOURTEEN THOUSAND OF THOSE
WERE DESTROYED?
UNFORTUNATELY THE RIDGE PROVIDED
HOUSING FOR MANY OF THE REGION'S
EMPLOYEES DUE TO ITS LOW COST.
WITHOUT THESE WORKERS ARE
REGION'S ECONOMY IS AT SERIOUS
RISK.
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN SURVEYED AND
ON AVERAGE 10220% OF THEIR
EMPLOYEES HOUSING EMPLOYERS ARE
SAYING THEY'RE HAVING A HARD
TIME RECRUITING.
AND CONSIDERING OTHER LOCATIONS
ALREADY ONE EMPLOYER.
THE FEATHER RIVER HOSPITAL WITH
ITS THIRTEEN HUNDRED EMPLOYEES
IS CLOSE TO STORE.
HOUSING IS CRITICAL AND FOR A
HOST OF REASONS IS UNLIKELY TO
BE BUILT IN A TIMELY FASHION ON
THE RICH INCLUDING.
NO SEWER VICTIM TRAUMA INSURANCE
ISSUES AND COST TO BUILD.
WE NEED A FIVE TO EIGHT THOUSAND
HOUSING UNITS IMMEDIATELY.
AND WE'RE TALKING PERMITTED
EMPLOYEE HOUSING WE'RE NOT
TALKING DOUBLING UP.
WE'RE NOT TALKING FEMA TRAILERS
WHICH WHICH INCIDENTALLY HAVE
NOT YET BEEN PRODUCED.
AGAIN AS WAS MENTIONED THERE
VIRTUALLY NO VACANCIES OUR
COMMUNITY NOW.
UP THE COMMUNITY I'M WORKING IN
WENT FROM.
PROBABLY A 20% VACANCY TO A ZERO
OVERNIGHT.
INCLUDING TAKING OUR OLD
STRUCTURES THE CITY HAD
REPOSSESSED AND RE PURPOSING
THEM AND HOUSING PEOPLE IN THOSE
STRUCTURES.
HOUSING PRICES HAVE SOARED DO A
LOT TO A LACK OF THE SUPPLY.
THIS BILL I BELIEVE IT IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THE SOLUTION.
IT'S GONNA TAKE AN INNOVATIVE
APPROACH TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
AS WAS MENTIONED.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DEVELOPMENT
IS CONSISTENT WITH THE
JURISDICTIONS GENERAL PLANS AND
SEVERE INFLUENCE.
TIMING IS CRITICAL.
WE ALREADY HAVE SEEN LITERALLY
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE MOVE OUT OF
THE AREA -- FEMA'S PUT TOGETHER
A MAP WHICH I BELIEVE IS
AVAILABLE ONLINE.
SHOWS WHERE THE REGS --
RESIDENTS HAVE RELOCATED -- TO
THERE ARE NUMBER OF PROJECTS
THAT I BELIEVE WITH THIS BILL
WOULD BE BROUGHT FORWARD.
AGAIN CONSISTENT WITH EACH OF
THE CITIES AND THE COUNTIES
GENERAL PLAN.
WE HAVE A DEVELOPING CALLED
VALLEY VALLEY'S AGE WHICH WOULD
HAVE THE ABILITY TO PROVIDE UP
TO TWENTY THREE HUNDRED HOUSING
UNITS.
IN OUR AREA WE BUILD TWO TO FOUR
HUNDRED A YEAR.
HOPEFULLY WITH THESE
DEVELOPMENTS COMING ON LINE WILL
BE ABLE TO BUILD MAYBE THREE
TIMES AT BUT IT'S GOING TO TAKE.
A LARGER EFFORT TO GET THE
REGION BACK ON TRACK.
THERE'S A GATEWAY PROJECT WHICH
IS TWO HUNDRED ACRES AGAIN.
COMPLETELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
CITY'S GENERAL PLAN THREE OR
INFLUENCE IT HAS THE ABILITY TO
HOUSE. TWELVE HUNDRED TWO
THOUSAND UNITS AGAIN BILL OVER
TIME YOU CAN FINISH UP CERTAINLY --
PLEASE PASS THIS BILL IT'S ONE
PIECE OF THE PUZZLE.
I BELIEVE THIS BILL IS A
CRITICAL PIECE OF THE RECOVERY.
I WANT TO THANK THE ASSEMBLY
ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER FOR
INTRODUCING IT.
THE RECOVERY IT WAS IN CAN YOU
NEEDS TO BE A TEAM EFFORT.
I APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY FOR BEING
PART OF THE TEAM THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE TODAY TO HEAR COMMENTS MY
NAME IS JENNIFER MORRISON AND
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
NORTH VALLEY PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
THE NORTH VALLEY PROPERTY OWNERS
ASSOCIATION IS A NONPROFIT THAT
PROVIDES SUPPORT EDUCATION AND
ADVOCACY TO AREA HOUSING
PROVIDERS LOCATED IN OUR TWELVE
COUNTIES IN NORTHEASTERN
CALIFORNIA.
OUR OFFICES IN CHICO COUNTY VIEW
AND WE REPRESENT THE OWNERS OF
OVER TWENTY TWO THOUSAND RENTALS.
SINCE THE DEVASTATING CAMPFIRE
NOVEMBER EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND AND
EIGHTEEN CHICO AND YOU COUNTY
WILL NEVER BE THE SAME WE HAVE
TAKEN IN A POPULATION OF
SURVIVORS RECOVERY EFFORTS STAFF
DURING THAT TIME WE HAD A PRE
EXISTING VACANCY FACTOR OF LESS
THAN 3%.
THIS IS ABOUT FIVE TO SIX
HUNDRED HOUSING UNITS THAT WERE
AVAILABLE.
THERE WAS OVER FOURTEEN THOUSAND
HOMES THAT WERE DESTROYED IN THE
CAMP FIRE YOU COUNTY NOW HAS
LESS THAN 0% VACANCY OUR STREETS
ARE LINED WITH DEBRIS REMOVAL
TRUCKS.
MOTORHOMES AND TRAILERS.
AND AT TRAILERS WITH PEOPLE
LIVING IN THEIR CARS ARE MENTAL
HEALTH IS WEAKENING BY THE DAY
MEMBERS OF OUR ORGANIZATION HAVE
LED AND ATTENDED COUNTLESS
MEETINGS TRYING TO SOLVE OUR
HOUSING CRISIS.
I AM HERE TODAY TO SUPPORT
ASSEMBLYMAN GALLAGHER'S PROPOSED
BILL OF AB FOR THIRTY TO
STREAMLINED RECONSTRUCTION AND
YOU HOUSING IN OUR COMMUNITY.
AS I BELIEVE THIS IS ONE OF THE
BEST SOLUTIONS WE CAN QUICKLY AN
ACT.
WHAT HAPPENED IN THE CAMP FIRE
IS LIKE NOTHING ANYONE HAS
EXPERIENCE BEFORE GENERATIONS
UPON GENERATIONS HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED WE HAVE EXPERIENCED
WAYS OF HOUSING CHANGES AND WILL
CONTINUE TO EXPERIENCE MORE?
EVERY DAY THAT WE ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE A SOLUTION TO OUR
RESIDENTS IS ANOTHER DAY THAT
THEY LOSE HOPE.
AND LEAVE THE AREA.
WE'RE MISSING OPPORTUNITIES TO
MAINTAIN OUR WORK FORCE AT ALL
LEVELS INCLUDING HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS EDUCATORS AND SO
MUCH MORE.
WE NEED RELIEF AND SUPPORT OUR
COMMUNITY IS STRONG AND WILL
CONTINUE TO LIVE WITH THEIR NEW
NORMAL BUT WITHOUT THE PASSAGE
OF AB FOUR THIRTY WE WON'T BE
ABLE TO BRING YOU HOUSING STOCK
ON TO THE MARKET.
IN A TIMELY MANNER WITHOUT YOUR
ASSISTANCE PLEASE HELP US BY
PASSING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION FOR BUTTE COUNTY.
THANK YOU ARE THERE OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT MADAM CHAIR
ANOTHER MEMBERS POLIO -- ON WE
HAVE THE VIEW COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL I'M TAKING EVERY
OPPORTUNITY CAN THE THINK THE
MEMBERS AGAIN WHO HAVE ACTUALLY
GONE UP THERE PERSONALLY TOWARD
THE AREA IT'S JUST NAME IN YOUR
ORGANIZATION SO.
I VOTE ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
JOHN KENNEDY WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
AT A RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SILVIO PURRING HAVE CALIFORNIA
BUILDING INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
THE CIVIL JUSTICE CESSATION
CALIFORNIA -- ADAM FINELLI FROM
CHICO REALTOR REPRESENTS HERE
NORTH VALLEY THE CESSATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MARTY LE THE ROOM -- COLDWELL
BANKER UP IN CHICO.
POLICY ARE NORTH VALLEY REALTORS
IN SUPPORT OF BILL.
CASEY REYNOLDS MEMBER THE CHECK
A CITY COUNCIL WHERE WE ARE
STILL HAVE TWO PEOPLE SLEEPING
IN CARS I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
CAN YOU TELL ME PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF THE CHECKER CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOUR THIRTY THANK YOU.
WILLIAM SHARED IN I'M A MULTI
FAMILY HOUSING PROVIDER IN CHICO
AND I'M ALSO LEGISLATIVE REP FOR
THE INSTITUTE REAL ESTATE
MANAGEMENT SACRAMENTO VALLEY
CHAPTER SUPPORT THE BILL.
PAUL WEB A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
IN CHICO AND SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU -- LORETTA WEBER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF VALLEY
CONTRACTORS EXCHANGE FROM CHICO
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
DAMON CONKLIN WITH THE COALITION
A BUILDER EXCHANGES AND
CALIFORNIA'S FROM MY SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
HI I'M ANGELA KESSLER THE CEO OF
SUSTAINABILITY MANAGEMENT
ASSOCIATION WE REPRESENT TWENTY
EIGHT HUNDRED PLUS MEMBERS IN
EIGHTEEN COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD.
WE DO SUPPORT THE BILL I'M A
RESIDENT USED TO BE A RESIDENT
OF PARADISE IS IT POSSIBLE I
COULD TELL YOU A STORY I KNOW
I'M SORRY WE'RE GRITTY FINISH
TAKING TESTIMONY BUT THANK YOU
FOR COMING.
I AM CRISTINA TAFT AND I LOST MY
MOTHER VICTORIA TOUGH IN THE
FIRE AND I JUST THINK THAT A
PERKY MEDIA OF THIS CANNOT
AFFORD THEY USUALLY HUNDRED
THOUSAND EXTRA SINCE THE
REGULATIONS.
TOOK PLACE.
THANK YOU.
SCOTT WATER OF FORMER COUNCIL
MEMBER AND MAYOR PARADISE
TRAILER DWELLER.
IN SUPPORT.
LINDA HORTON LIONS -- I'D LOST
MY HOME MY HUSBAND SAVED HIS
BUSINESS.
ANDI'M PART OF THE LIONS --
INTERNATIONAL AND WE HAD A
CENTER AND WE SAW A LOT OF
EVACUEES.
LIVING.
CATCH TO CALC SHOULD WE NEED THE
HELP AND WERE WERE VERY MUCH IN
SUPPORT.
OF THE A. B. FOUR THIRTY THANK
YOU.
PHILLY ARISE THAT CAN'T FIRE EVE
ACCU WE SURVIVOR SPENT THE LAST
FIVE MONTHS LIVE IN RV IN A
PARKING LOT.
WITH OVER FIFTY OTHER TRAILERS --
WITH FAMILIES AND CHILDREN WITH
NO WHERE TO GO I'M IN SUPPORT.
NATHAN WILKINSON THE MERS CITY
BIGGS AND ALSO THE SON OF
PARENTS ARE SIR CURRENTLY
DISPLACED AND LIVING WITH ME SO
I'M IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MELISSA SCHUSTER PARADISE TOWN
COUNCIL SPEAKING FOR MYSELF.
I LOST MY HOME I AM LIVING IN AN
RV AND I ALSO SUPPORT THIS BILL.
MARK SORENSON CITY OF THE BIG
CITY ADMINISTRATOR AND FORMER
PLANNING COMMISSIONER COUNCIL
MEMBER MAYOR CITY A CHICO AND TO
MY DAUGHTERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
THREE MY TWO GRANDCHILDREN LOST
THEIR HOMES IN PARADISE.
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
IF THERE ARE -- YEAH WE CAN HAVE
THREE PEOPLE -- SET UP HERE AND
IF ONE OF THE WITNESSES COULD
MOVE PLEASE.
AND THAT ANYONE ELSE WILL BE
ABLE TO TESTIFY [inaudible]
AFTERWARDS
and the two minutes apiece
I'm a resident I'm grace Marvin
resident of Chico concerned
about four thirty unnecessarily
taking away the role of our
local community and planning
housing and parking and then
removing the crucial role of
the sequel -- in assessing
future developments the bill
states that it would it it's
a matter of statewide concern
rather than a municipal
affair and it applies only to
BiÃu six it also said that
seek what does not apply to
the approved projects and
more over its says that --
with respect to streamline
ministerial approach the the
county of Butte would in other
words lose control to the
state mandated local program
we are concerned about the role
of and mission of see cça and
its review of people's physical
health and safety and the need
to protect plants trees water
ways and critters in our natural
environment and any proposed
development why should we drop
those concerns about people and
nature in the nay in the name
of supposedly helping people
moreover I spoke with this
the mayor of of of
Chico and he sent you a
letter today regarding his
opposition to it and in that
letter he wrote I am white
writing his name is mayor
Randall stone I am writing to
convey my personal opposition
unless amended to at AB four
thirty I have communicated
my opposition to the bill as
currently written to author
meant to author assemblyman
member James Gallagher and
look forward to working with
the member once the preemption
to conditional land use
authority is redacted the
Chico city council did not have
an opportunity ahead of this
hearing to discuss and or issue
and oppose unless amended letter
additionally the Butte County
Board of supervisors letter of
support did not seek approved
the approval of either of the
two suit supervisors in the
Chico area overwhelmingly the
most populated city pre and
post campfire our community
is concerned about lifting
conditional land use authority
ma'am your your two minutes are
up -- if I would like one of
your colleagues to finish okay
and and we also have the letter
so unless you want to read into
the record we've lost we all
have the letter read read
this part that starting here
the city of Chico currently
has twenty five hundred single
for family units and twenty
eight hundred multi family
units of housing in various
stages of development that
are overwhelmingly not pending
city regulatory authority
I see AB for thirty as a
considerable over reach a
potential state preemption under
any circumstances let alone
potentially that opposition to
the most impacted jurisdictions
I am urging a no vote to pass
this bill to appropriations
unless amended should you have
any questions about my personal
opposition of this bill please
do not hesitate to contact me
next okay I have something
to -- I mean the main
the thing is that I mean
I have total sympathy and
empathy for the survivors
of the campfire in the fire
came within ten feet of my
own house and I was evacuated
but I am I see this
as a really stunning over
reach of power into the locally
elected representatives of Butte
county local governments as
the mayor said -- the locally
elected officials should always
have the decision making power
over their development and
since they're already fifty
three hundred approved future
residences in Chico many of us
see the logical next step is
building the opportunity sites
already listed in the general
plan which already has expensive
infrastructure in place this
would offer the possibility
of efficient public transit
walkability and particular
affordable housing quickly in
addition the sequel approval
process is there to not only
protect the environment and
the last remaining five percent
of our endangered species but
also to protect the health and
safety of the people large or
small developments which are not
able to pass carbon emissions
worsen air quality and climate
change and should not be allowed
the irony would be to approve a
bill like AB for thirty and
streamline this process on the
kinds of developments which
actually would contribute to
such disasters events disastrous
events as the campfire emerging
a no vote okay can you just
identify yourself there was
a Beth Devereaux from Chico
thank you last witness please
good afternoon madam chair and
members of the committee my name
is Molly Colton I'm an organizer
an advocate for Sierra Club
California I was also born and
raised and paradise my family
and friends lost everything in
the camp fire being from Butte
county I know first hand the
impact this bill could have on
the region and the necessity of
housing for wild fire victims
including my friends and family
I also understand the need for
environmental protection given
that our official position
on the bill is opposed unless
amended as we believe sequel
provides the opportunity
for prudent environmental
consideration we have provided
the author with for specific
amendments that we believe would
provide greater environmental
protection to the bill we've
met with the author and are
pleased that he has committed
to adopting these amendments
I am confident that we can
work with the author to reach
a neutral position and craft
a bill that would best strike
a balance between providing
affordable infill housing for
wild fire victims that best
coincides with environmental
preservation we look forward
to removing our opposition
upon seeing upon seeing the
amendments and print thank you
thank you is running body else
wishing to testify in opposition
to the bill Melissa Romero
on behalf of the California
league of conservation voters
and I line our comments with
those of Sierra Club California
thank you thank you all bring
it back now to the committee
for for comments or questions
assemblymember Melinda's
thank you madam chair I'm I'm
sorry the witnesses already
left the table of your rate
here so of the three you
don't have to come back at
me and you may sit down I'm
just of the three of you
who how many of you lost
your your home the three
to testify in opposition
seven nine if you lost your
home in the fire thank you so
here's my concern is that
from what I understand Mister
Gallagher there's some issue
with the conditional use
land permit is that correct
I think what has been brought
up is it somehow this would
take away local control -- I
I disagree with that contention
if you read the terms of the
bill -- first of all it requires
-- that these would have to go
through the planning commission
process that have to go to
this to the city council or the
board of supervisors whatever
the case may be -- it would
have to be consistent with
the general plan and zoning
so as we all know many of us
are and local government you
you do a plan the do a general
plan that you establish where
where residential is going to
be what zoned residential so
you've already planned and said
this is okay for a committee
that's worry what the building
taking place would presumably
have to coincide with whatever
the city's general plan AB
radio right hundred there's no
changing of zoning no change
in accounting the the change
would be that we're trying to
-- speed up the process by
which people could rebuild their
lives is that a fair way of
explaining it exactly bill
bring on more housing that we've
already planned for as soon as
possible so that we can house
fire victims okay thank you
thank you some of the real
amount I think you
as a member Gallagher for
bringing this forward and
certainly as someone who is
impacted whose district was
impacted by the Thomas fire in
the a subsequent debris flows
I understand how important
it is to rebuild and to get
our community -- functioning
and moving in as normal
as a way possible in the most
a normal circumstances and
it is very difficult -- one
of the elements that I I've
been kind of you and I had
a conversation about it that
we've been trying to figure out
is AB you know the removing of
the sea quest -- piece of it
and I the conversations
in my district still --
happening and -- I have
not felt the positive impact
of public input and through
the review process as much
-- for any other issue I've
had to deal with than with
rebuilding our community -- and
so seen that it would be removed
-- because it's you know seek
was a much thorough is something
that you know I just throw
out there -- our community
has been very involved in what
rebuilding looks like -- there
have been really tough not just
individual owner conversations
but community conversations
about area that can no longer be
rebuilt because the topography
itself change and you know
watching a community go through
a process to have to decide
that ex number of homes won't
be rebuilt and now we're
going to service the debris
basin -- was very difficult
-- individuals had to make a
decision but also community
had to come around and support
some of these decisions a throw
that out there because I know
sometimes we feel that seek when
the public input process can
THE DISTRICT HAVE
ALSO SEEN IT UNDER THIS
CIRCUMSTANCE ALSO BE PART OF THE
CEILING.
IN TERMS OF THIS IS HOW WE
REBUILD -- INDIVIDUAL DECISIONS
HAVE HAD TO BE MADE AS WELL AS
COLLECTIVE DECISIONS FOR THE
COMMUNITY AND I JUST.
AS THIS DISCUSSION CONTINUES I
UNDERSTAND WE'RE NOT VOTING ON
THIS TODAY BUT YOU KNOW THERE.
THERE HAS BEEN GREAT VALUE TO
THE PUBLIC.
IN DEATH PROCESS -- IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT'S BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT AND I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND -- WHERE YOU AND THE
COMMUNITY ARE COMING FROM LIKE
EIGHT IS IMPORTANT? TO HELP OUR
COMMUNITY REBUILT AND IT WILL BE
YEARS -- BUT BUT I WANTED TO US
TO ALSO THINK ABOUT THAT AND
THERE'S JUST.
A FEW INSTANCES OF IN OUR
COMMUNITY WHERE IT REALLY HAS
HELPED.
THANK YOU A SUMMER MATHIS.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE I'M
HEARING EVERYTHING A RIGHT SO.
WE'RE NOT TAKING AWAY LOCAL
CONTROL FROM SAY THE CITY OF
CHICO FOR ISSUE IN A BUILDING
PERMIT WE'RE DECIDING NOT. TO
ISSUE A BUILDING PERMIT IS THAT
CORRECT.
NO I MEAN WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IS
SIMILAR TO SB -- THIRTY FIVE
WHICH WAS PASSED A COUPLE YEARS
AGO.
IS IT THESE ARE VERY LIMITED
TYPES OF PROJECTS NUMBER ONE
THEY HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE GENERAL PLAN AND ZONING SO
THAT ALREADY HAVE TO BE.
A PLACE IT'S ZONED RESIDENTIAL
THAT'S ALREADY BEEN AYE ZONE AND
GONE THROUGH AND NOT EASILY CORE
PROCESS AND EVERYTHING LOOKING
AT THE ZONING CURRENT EXACTLY
AND THEN IT HAD CAN'T.
INVOLVE -- YOU KNOW ON A FLOOD
PLAIN AGRICULTURALLY PROTECTED
AREA OR OTHER BUYER MENTALLY
SENSITIVE AREA -- SO IT'S IT'S
THERE'S GONNA BE A LIMITED
AMOUNT OF PROJECTS HERE BUT IT'S
IMPORTANT TOOL AND WHAT IT WOULD
DO FOR THE SO IN THOSE LIMITED
CIRCUMSTANCES IT WOULD BE A
MINISTERIAL PROCESS.
THE SO AS LONG AS YOU MET THAT
CRITERIA YOU GET APPROVED BUT
YOU WOULD STILL HAVE TO GO
THROUGH.
THE THE PLANNING COMMISSION
YOU'D STILL HAVE TO GO TO THE
THE BOARD.
IT WOULD BE PUBLIC INPUT
THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS.
AND AS LONG AS IT MET THE
CRITERIA AND MEETS THE OBJECT
YOU COULD ALSO HAVE DESIGN
CRITERIA.
IN PLACES MANY COMMUNITIES DO.
AND AS LONG AS A MET THAT
CRITERIA IT WOULD IT WOULD BE
MINISTERIAL E. APPROVED BY THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
NOW SOME MIGHT TAKE THAT IS
TAKING AWAY THEIR THEIR
CONTROLLER DISCRETION BECAUSE OF
THAT FACT THERE.
BUT AGAIN THERE'S A LOT.
THAT GOES INTO THAT THIS IS A
VERY LIMITED AMOUNT OF PROJECTS
AND IT'S AN IMPORTANT TOOL.
BECAUSE ULTIMATELY WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT IS WE HAVE A LOT OF
PEOPLE THAT ARE OUT OF THEIR
HOMES AND SO I NEED TO TRY AND
BRING ONLINE HOUSING AS FAST AS
POSSIBLE.
AND WE'RE SAYING HEY WE'RE WE'RE
COMMUNITIES OF ALREADY DECIDED.
IT MAKES SENSE TO HAVE GROWTH
AND BUILDING LET'S GET IT DONE.
IS ESSENTIALLY WHAT WE'RE DOING
FOR EXAMPLE THE THE MAYOR OF
CHICO AS THESE CONCERNS THROUGH
THE PLANNING PROCESS COULD.
HOLD PUBLIC EVENT TO GET PUBLIC
COMMENT ON ANY PUBLIC CONCERNS
REGARDING.
THE THE PLANNING OF A SAY THE
HOMES THAT THE IS ALREADY ZONED
FOR CORRECT.
I'VE JUST HEARD ABOUT THIS
LETTER TODAY MYSELF I HAVEN'T
HAD A CHANCE EVEN READ THERE'S A
LIMIT IS MAYOR I COULD
DEFINITELY HAVE PUBLIC COMMENT
TIME IT.
THROUGH THE PLANNING PROCESS
IRONY I IS I AM A OR IF YOU
WANTED.
TO I FEEL VERY CONFIDENT THAT
THERE WILL BE A LOT OF PUBLIC
INPUT INTO THESE PROJECTS IF
THIS BILL WERE TO PASS YES.
BUT SOME PEOPLE WOULD ARGUE BUT
SEQUEL WOULD BE BYPASSED YEAH SO
YOU'RE NOT TYING HIS HANDS ON
THE PUBLIC PROCESS OR OR AS OUR
COLLEAGUE HAS SAID YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THE COMMUNITY.
CAN COME TOGETHER AND HILL IN
THE DIFFERENT AREAS THEY THEY
COULD ALL.
MEET IN AND TALK ABOUT IT
PUBLICLY THERE IN CHICO JUST
LIKE IS THE THE PEOPLE AND
PARADISE TO BE ABLE TO GET
TOGETHER AND TALK.
CORRECT.
THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING YES OKAY
SIDE.
HE STILL HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
BE MAYOR SO I THINK YOU'RE BILLS
GREAT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY.
THANK YOU A MANAGER AT THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER -- FOR FOR FOR
THEY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO ONE
TALK ABOUT TODAY AND YOUR
CONSTITUENTS DROVE ALL THE WAY
HERE BUT FOR ALSO.
SAYING TO WORK WITH THE AT
COMMITTEE STAFF.
AND THE CHAIR TO TRY TO COME TO
A CONCLUSION HERE BECAUSE I
THINK WE'RE ALL.
VERY SYMPATHETIC -- TO TO THE
CONCERNS OF DEALING WITH THE
COMMUNITY THAT SUFFERED A GREAT
TRAGEDY IN TRYING TO REBUILD
UNFATHOMABLE.
WITH THAT THE MAGNITUDE OF OF
ALL THAT IS NOT MY DISTRICT I
DON'T SO I DON'T SEE IT -- BUT
ALSO TRYING TO IT HERE TO OUR
CALIFORNIA POLICIES AND OUR
VALUES SO I DO WANNA TO HAVE TO
ASK A QUESTION FOLLOW UP WITH
MISTER MATHIS ITSELF I WAS A
FORMER.
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL JUST
LIKE YOU.
AND I UNDERSTANDING IS THAT.
THAT ONCE THE PROPERTY IS IS --
PROPERLY ZONE.
IN RESIDENTIAL AND SINGLE FAMILY.
YOU GO IN AND GET YOUR APPROVAL
FROM THE CITY AND IT IS A
MINISTERIAL DECISION SO.
RIGHT BUT YOU SAY THERE'S SOME
TYPE OF DEVELOPMENTS THAT WOULD
BE DIFFERENT CAN YOU EXPAND.
WHAT WHAT THE SITUATION CIRCUS
HARD FOR ME TO KIND UNDERSTAND?
I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MY WITNESS
BUT JUST JUST IN ADVANCE OF THAT --
YES IT WOULD BE A MINISTERIAL
PROCESS BUT NONE THE LESS.
AGAIN THIS IS ONLY FOR PROJECTS
THAT ARE ALREADY ZONED
RESIDENTIAL THEY CAN INVOLVE ANY
AGRICULTURALLY PROTECTED LAND
ECCENTRIC RIGHT.
THEY WOULD STILL NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE PUB THEY GO TO THE
PLANNING COMMISSION EVEN THOUGH
THE MINISTERIAL THEY GO TO THE
PLANNING COMMISSION PROCESS THEY
GO TO THE BOARD.
WHERE THERE WILL BE PUBLIC INPUT
BUT ALL TURNED OVER TO THE CITY
MANAGER FOR A BILL WHO KNOWS
THIS ALL TOO WELL?
I JUST WANT TO EMPHASIZE THAT SO.
CONSISTENT WITH THE GENERAL PLAN
CONSISTS WHO WAS OWNING IT STILL
TAKES SUBDIVISION APPROVAL THERE
STILL IS A PUBLIC HEARING THERE
STILL PROCESS.
PLANNING STAFF TO ADDRESS IS THE
SAME ISSUES WHETHER IN DANGER
SPECIES OR TRAFFIC AND I
GUARANTEE ' COMMUNITIES
INVOLVED ALLOWED DISCUSSION
ABOUT BOTH OF THOSE.
YEAH SO THOSE ITEMS ARE STILL
DRESSED IN A PUBLIC HEARING
PROCESS IN IN A COMMON PROCESS.
SO GIVE US AN EXAMPLE OF OF A
PROJECT THAT WOULD BE ABLE TO BE
APPROVED AND YOUR CURRENT
PROCESS ONE THAT WOULD BE
TRIPPED UP WHICH SHE WOULD SHE
WOULD NEED THIS BILL TO ADDRESS
[inaudible]
OUR COMMUNITY.
IS A VERY DIVIDED COMMUNITY AND
IN THIS CASE AND TALK ABOUT THE
CITY OF CHICO.
AND THE COMMUNITY.
THERE'S A PORTION THE COMMUNITY
THAT GREATLY OPPOSES ANY
DEVELOPMENT.
AND WITH SEEK WERE IT'S
PRIMARILY PROCEDURAL TOOL AND
THEREFORE THE PROJECTS ARE
DRAGGED OUT.
NOT BECAUSE HAVING GONE THROUGH
A LENGTHY LENGTHY PUBLIC HEARING
PROCESS BUT BECAUSE THERE'S A
WAITED TO DETERMINE.
THE TO SLOW THE PROJECT DOWN
BASICALLY MAYBE MAYBE STOP IT.
OKAY AND THEN -- CAN YOU REMIND
US AGAIN WHAT WHAT THE SIERRA
CLUB IS IS ASKING OF YOU.
AND WHAT YOU'RE WILLING TO TO
PUT ON THE TABLE TO ADDRESS
THOSE CONCERNS [inaudible]
SO [inaudible]
I DON'T.
I THINK I CAN SPEAK FOR THEM BUT
ESSENTIALLY. ONE THEY WOULD LIKE
SOME LANGUAGE THAT DEALS WITH
WETLANDS -- AND ENSURING THAT
THOSE ARE PROTECTED -- THEY ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO CHANGE THE
REQUIREMENT ON WHETHER NOT YOU
CAN REQUIRE PARKING -- RIGHT NOW
THE LANGUAGE READS IT AS LONG AS
IT'S WITHIN A MILE OF PUBLIC
TRANSIT -- THAT THERE CAN'T BE A
PARKING REQUIREMENT ON IT --
THEY'VE ACID BE HALF A MILE.
SO HAVE AGREED TO DO THAT -- THE
LET'S SEE HERE THERE'S THERE'S
SOME LANGUAGE ABOUT WHAT IF
THERE'S A DISCREPANCY BETWEEN.
GENERAL PLAN AND AND SONY AND
HOW THAT WOULD BE HAMMERED OUT.
THAT COMES FROM SB THIRTY FIVE
THEY'VE ASKED THAT THAT BE TAKEN
OUT.
I'M AGREEABLE TO TAKING THAT OUT --
AND THEN RIGHT NOW WE HAVE THIS
AS A FIVE YEAR OR SORRY A TEN
YEAR.
IT HAS A TEN YEAR SUNSET ON IT --
BECAUSE I WAS THINKING WILL
REALLY WERE THINKING IT.
ABOUT TEN YEARS TO RELEASE.
AB GET BACK UP ON THE RIDGE IN
REBUILDING -- ALSO MANY GENERAL
PLANS ARE TEN YEARS USUALLY --
SO.
THAT THAT WAS THE THINKING
BEHIND THAT THEY'VE ASKED FOR IT
TO BE FIVE IN THE INTEREST OF
TRYING TO COMPROMISE A MOVE
SOMETHING ALONG HERE I'M WILLING
TO DO THAT AS WELL DOES THAT
COVER EVERYTHING HERE.
YES PRINT AWESOME B. OFFICE HERE
THE CALIFORNIA -- FIRST OFF
THANK YOU ALL FOR HEARING THIS
BILL -- HE BASICALLY HAD ALL THE
NET IN THE NOTES ON THE HEAD AND
THAT OF OUR REQUESTS -- WE'VE
TALKED ALSO ABOUT HOW BECAUSE OF
THE LIMITATIONS THAT I PROVIDED
AND ALSO SOME OF IMITATION THAT
THE COMMITTEE HAS BEEN TALKING
TO A LOT OF THIS WOULD BE
SUBJUGATED -- TO INFILL
DEVELOPMENT WHICH WE OBVIOUSLY
WOULD LIKE AS WELL -- AND SO
THAT'S NOT A NEED THAT IN OUR
LETTER PER SE BUT WE WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO TALK TO MORE ABOUT HOW
WE CAN DO IT LIKE LIMIT THIS TO
INFILL DEVELOPMENT.
WHICH WE OBVIOUSLY ADVOCATE MORE --
FOR LONG TERM WHAT NOT SURE OF
THANK YOU IN IN THE MAYBE THAT
THANK YOU THOUGHT YOUR WELL YOUR
WORKING WITH THE SIERRA CLUB AND
HOPEFULLY BUT TIME IS A BILL.
YOU'LL HAVE WORKED WORKED IT OUT
WITH THEM TO REMOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION BUT ONE THING THAT
THEY DID NOTE THERE WHICH I WANT
TO ASK YOU IS THAT IS AYE AYE.
I KNOW YOU'RE TRYING TO BE
CREATIVE AND MODEL THIS AFTER.
SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH WAS IS THE
LIE SUPPORT DEVOTED -- BUT IT'S
YOU KNOW APPLES AND ORANGES I
THINK THAT THE GOAL THAT MISTER
WINNER PUT FORTH WAS.
IN THESE URBAN LOCATIONS WERE
THERE YOU KNOW MANY TIMES CLOSE
OUR CLUSTER RAIL AND TRANSIT AND
OBVIOUSLY PARADISE IS NOT.
NECESSARILY -- THAT CITY MAYBE
CHICO'S A LITTLE BIT SINCE SOME
OF THE DENSE AREAS AND SO AND
THEN ALSO TALK ABOUT HOW.
WELL YOU FOCUS ON THIS IS SB
THIRTY FIVE LIKE IT'S IT'S GOOD
AS A LIGHT IN MANY AREAS
INCLUDING.
THIS INFILL -- YOU KNOW --
PRINCIPLE THAT OBVIOUSLY IS NOT
THERE IN YOUR COMMUNITY SO. ONE
IF YOU CAN ADDRESS THAT IN SOME
OF THE OTHER ISSUES THAT WERE IN.
THIRTY FIVE SB THIRTY FIVE WHICH
ARE NOT IN YOUR PROPOSAL.
I MEAN I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY IT
LIKE I I MEAN I I I KIND OF JOKE
TO AN SB THIRTY FIVE WAS UP THAT
IT WAS IT WAS.
NO SECRET STREAMLINING FOR SAN
FRANCISCO RIGHT BECAUSE IT WAS
ALMOST LIKE THAT WAS KIND OF THE
ONLY AREAS IT WOULD REALLY WORK
IN -- SO I'VE I'VE MODELED. FOUR
THIRTY OFF OF THIRTY FIVE THAT I
WOULD CALL IT.
SICK WITH STREAMLINING FOR BUTTE
COUNTY HERE AND SO I'VE I'VE
DEFINITELY IN TRYING TO TAKE
INTO ACCOUNT.
THAT THERE YOU KNOW IT IS IT IS
DIFFERENT AS I THINK MANY OF YOU
KNOW -- AND MANY AB THE VISITED.
YOU KNOW WE DON'T NECESSARILY
HAVE [inaudible]
YOU KNOW.
VERY URBAN ENVIRONMENTS WE DO
HAVE URBAN AREAS -- WE DO HAVE A
LOT OF SINGLE FAMILY RESIDENCES.
BUT THIS WOULD ENABLE INFILL
PROJECTS IT WOULD ENABLE A MULTI
FAMILY PROJECTS APARTMENTS
THERE'S A LACKS THE A LOT OF
APARTMENT HOUSING IN CHICO
PROBABLY NEEDS TO BE MORE -- IN
IN OTHER IN OTHER JURISDICTIONS
AS WELL.
BUT ALSO SINGLE FAMILY HOMES
BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S KIND OF
PART OF HOW PEOPLE LIVE UP IN
THIS IN THIS AREA THAT'S WHAT
PEOPLE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
ON THE RICH ARE USED -- TO BUT
WE NEED IT ALL RIGHT WE NEED WE
DON'T JUST NEED ONE TYPE OF
HOUSING THAT'S WHY THIS ALLOWS.
FOR THE WHOLE GAMUT -- AND BUT
ONLY IN THOSE LIMITED AREAS
WHERE IT MEETS THE CRITERIA
BASICALLY.
YES MA'AM I HAVE TO INTERRUPT
BECAUSE I HAVE TO GO ON PRESENT
A BILL I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO
MY CODE MY VICE CHAIR TO
CONTINUE TAKING YOUR QUESTIONS
BEFORE I GO I I DO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD IN.
AN ATTEMPT TO DEAL WITH WHAT'S
CLEARLY A CRISIS AND I DO --
ALSO APPRECIATE YOUR BEING
WILLING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
US BEFORE WE BRING ABOUT GO BACK
FOR A VOTE I THINK YOU ARE
HEARING.
CONCERNS AND THERE'S SOME WORK
TO BE DONE WITH THIS BILL --
FRIEND SINCE SB THIRTY FIVE WAS
REALLY A BILL THAT WAS MEANT --
TO FORCE ARE RETICENT -- CITY
COUNCILS IN URBAN AREAS I'VE TO
FORCE THEM TO ALLOW PROJECTS
WHEN THEY DIDN'T WANT TO SO IT'S
STILL UNCLEAR TO ME WITH THIS
BILL.
IF A PROJECT COMES IN IT MEETS
THE CRITERIA OF BEINGS UP KIND
OF THE RIGHT KIND OF PROJECT FOR
THE ZONING AND OTHERS WHETHER
CITY COUNCIL COULD STILL DENY IT
THAT STILL UNCLEAR TO ME.
IT SEEMS LIKE IT'S YOUR
INDICATION TO ALLOW THAT LEVEL
OF REVIEW BUT THAT'S NOT ALL
WITH SB -- THIRTY FIVE DID AND I
I THINK BECAUSE YOUR BILL MAHER
MIRRORS THAT BILL SO CLOSELY
THAT WE REALLY DO NEED.
TO YOU KNOW YOU'RE IT IS THAT
ROUND PEG SQUARE HOLE OR
WHATEVER THE EXPRESSION IS
BASICALLY TO GIVE COME BACK WITH
THE CLOTHES.
ON RIGHT [inaudible]
SENS [inaudible]
YEAH -- BUT YOU KNOW TO BETTER
DEFINE WHAT IT WHAT YOU KNOW
WHAT SORT OF URBAN MEANS TO
NARROW THIS SO THAT IT'S NOT.
USED FOR FOR SPRAWL THAT THE THE
COMMUNITY HAS A CHANCE TO REALLY
HAVE A VOICE AND INPUT.
AND I ALSO WILL SAY THAT AS
WE'VE DISCUSSED THERE'S A LOT OF
OTHER MEASURES THAT COMMUNITIES
CAN BE TAKING RIGHT NOW IF THEY
WANT TO HELP DEVELOPERS AND HELP
DEVELOPMENTS SUCH AS
PROGRAMMATIC YARIS -- WITH THEIR
DOWNTOWN SPECIFIC YOU KNOW WITH
THEIR PLAN SO THAT THAT WORK IS
DONE IN ADVANCE -- FOR THE
DEVELOPERS THAT'S USE VERY
SUCCESSFUL IN A LOT OF
COMMUNITIES AND THERE'S MONEY IN
SB TWO FROM LAST YEAR TO HELP
SMALLER COMMUNITIES -- HAVE THE
ABILITY TO DO THAT SO RATHER
THAN WAIT UNTIL THIS BILL MAHER
MAY NOT GO THROUGH AN UNTIL
JANUARY COMMUNITIES SHOULD BE
WORKING RIGHT NOW I THINK
TOWARDS THAT END.
SO I LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH
YOU OVER THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS AND YOU KNOW WE'LL WE'LL
SEE WHAT WE GET WITH THIS.
WITHOUT IT OVER MISTER I DO JUST
WANT TO SAY IT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR OF APPRECIATE THE INPUT
AND DIALOGUE THAT WE'VE HAD AND
I AND I DO BELIEVE THAT WILL BE
ABLE.
TO YOU KNOW GET TO THAT PLACE --
BUT IT'S IT'S DEFINITELY A GREAT
TO HAVE AND COMMITTEE STAFF
WHO'S BEEN VERY ATTENTIVE TO
THIS ISSUE.
YOU KNOW I THINK AS WE AS WE AS
WE SAID THERE'S NO I THINK ALL
THE ISSUES THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
OR THINGS THAT WE CAN ADDRESS --
AND I'M HOPEFUL THAT WE'LL GET
TO A PRODUCT HERE AT THE END.
HOW RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER SOME
WOMAN?
WAS EGGMAN THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GALLAGHER IN.
THANK YOU FOR THIS.
YOUR WORK ON THIS -- I I I WOULD.
AND THEN TOUR THE AREA AND AS
YOU WELL KNOW I HAVE FAMILY THAT
LIVE IN THE AREAS IMPACTED -- SO
I APPRECIATE YOU BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AND AYE AYE.
AYE AYE DIFFER FROM MY
COLLEAGUES A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE
I SEE SB THIRTY FIVE WAS
ADDRESSING A CRISIS -- AND I AND
I THINK YOUR ROUND HOLE IS A
CRISIS AS WELL -- IT MAY NOT FIT
IN THE EXACT SAME WAYS BUT I
THINK IT IS VERY CLEAR -- THAT
WE NEED TO GET PEOPLE BACK IN
HOUSING.
I GUESS ONE OF MY QUESTIONS I
WOULD ASK FOR THE CITY MANAGER
IS IT EVERYBODY HAS A GENERAL
PLAN ALREADY IN PLACE AND
THERE'S THERE'S NOTHING UP --
FOR LAND USE EXTENSION AT THIS
POINT.
IN.
THE CITY OF CHICO AND SO YOUR
BILL YES PARADISE APPOINT
THROUGH AN EXTENSIVE LAND USE
PROCESS RIGHT NOW.
AS YOU MIGHT EXPECT IN TERMS OF
HOW WHAT WE WANT TO LOOK LIKE
SINCE.
THEY BASICALLY WIPED OUT BUT THE
ANSWER TO YOUR QUESTION IS YES.
RECENTLY ADOPTED A LONG TERM
GENERAL PLANS IN THE COMMUNITIES.
OKAY SO THAT SO THIS WOULDN'T BE
CHANGING ANYTHING BUT ALTHOUGH
CHICO IS IS LOOKING AT THEIR
LAND USE RIGHT NOW.
I'M PREPARED AYE SOMETHING
PARADISE IS.
NOT YOUR ENTRY POINT.
OKAY ALRIGHT BUT YOU GO IN
ORVILLE HAVE DENTAL PLANS IN
PLACE THAT IS CORRECT OKAY --
BECAUSE IT CERTAINLY LIKE LIKE
SAN FRANCISCO I THINK ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I'M HEARING EVEN
MORE CLEARLY TODAY IS SIMPLY BE
ISM.
RIGHT ABOUT THEN PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS -- AND I THINK YOU
KNOW BUT IT THE FIRE HAS ALREADY
ESTABLISHED A BUNCH OF SORRY
PICK SOME WINNERS AND LOSERS.
AND I THINK IT'S UP TO US AS A
AS A STATE AS A COMMUNITY TO BE
ABLE TO HELP PEOPLE GET BACK ON
THEIR FEET SO -- I'D BUY I AM
ENCOURAGED.
YOU KNOW AND THE THE HOPEFULLY
THE COMMITTEE WILL DO GOOD WORK
AND WILL BE ABLE TO THREAD THE
NEEDLE IN A WAY THAT PROVIDES.
YOU TOOLS -- AND CONTINUES TO A
PULLED CALIFORNIA VALUES.
BUT THERE THERE IS A CRISIS IN
IN THE AREA THAT MUST BE
ADDRESSED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
SEE A NINE TO GALLAGHER ALICE'S
TESTIMONY ONLY SO.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE.
AND I APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE I
MEET AS YOU KNOW THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ISSUE FOR ME I WANTED
TO JUST CLARIFY A COUPLE THINGS
IN IN IN CLOSING -- AND I DO
LOOK FORWARD IN TWO WEEKS TO
BRING IT BACK SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN ALL GET BEHIND AND PASS OUT --
NUMBER ONE LOCAL CONTROL IS
PRESERVED -- THEY AGAIN IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CLEAR TERMS OF THE
LEGISLATION.
I WOULD HAVE TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH THE PLANNING THE CITY
COUNCILS AND COUNTY GOVERNMENTS
HAVE ALREADY DONE.
AND SAID THIS IS WHERE WE WANT
TO GROW THIS IS WHERE I WANT TO
HAVE RESIDENTIAL THERE WOULD
STILL BE A PUBLIC.
REVIEW PROCESS FOR THESE
PROJECTS.
SO LOCAL CONTROL IS PRESERVED IF
YOU MEAN THAT AND THEN BE ISM.
WILL BE LESS LIKELY YEAH THAT'S
TRUE.
YOU KNOW THAT SOMEBODY COMES IN
A PROJECT WHERE EVERYBODY'S
ALREADY DECIDED THIS MAKES A LOT
OF SENSE AS WAS HAPPENING IN SAN
FRANCISCO -- AND THE PROJECTS
WERE GETTING BUILT YEAH OF THIS
WOULD PROVIDE A MINISTRY --
PROCESS THAT HELPS ENSURE.
THAT HAPPENS -- BUT IT WOULD
PROVIDE FULL PUBLIC VETTING OF
THOSE PROJECTS AND IT WOULD HAVE
TO MEET CRITERIA VERY LIMITED
CRITERIA AS WE'VE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT.
AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON
ON THAT CRITERIA SO THAT PEOPLE
FEEL FEEL COMFORTABLE WITH THAT.
SECOND POINT IS LOCALS HAVE BEEN
INVOLVED THIS WHOLE PROCESS I
STARTED THIS RIDE IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THE FIRE.
WE MET WITH ALL THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WE MET WITH LOCAL
ELECTED IF OFFICIALS.
WE'VE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
LOCAL ELECTED OFFICIALS
INCLUDING THE MAYOR OF CHICO.
WHO IS WHO IS WELL AWARE OF WHAT
WE'VE BEEN PROPOSING?
AND HE HAS A LETTER APPARENTLY
THERE'S BEEN SUBMITTED -- THAT
HASN'T BEEN SHARED WITH ME AT
THIS POINT -- BUT WE HAVE BEEN
AND AS YOU'VE HEARD ME IN.
IF ANYBODY SAYS THAT LOCALS
DON'T SUPPORT THIS I HAVE A
LETTER CITY OF OROVILLE.
VALLEY CONTRACTORS EXCHANGE
SIERRA NORTH VALLEY REALTORS.
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES A CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
BUTTE COUNTY.
AND THE P. O. A THE NORTH VALLEY
PROPERTY OWNERS ASSOCIATION THAT
YOU HEARD FROM THE CHICO CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE -- THE CHICO
BUILDERS ASSOCIATION.
THE VALLEY CONTRACTORS EXCHANGE
ALL THE BUILDERS IN THAT REGION.
AND PEOPLE AND VENDORS INVOLVED
IN BUILDING I MEAN ALL THE
STAKEHOLDERS AND LOCAL.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN INVOLVED
IN TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
BUILD HOUSING AND THAT WE TREAT
THIS AS THE EMERGENCY THAT IT IS.
ARE BEHIND THIS AND SO THOSE
THAT MAYBE -- OPPOSE THIS ARE A
VERY SMALL MINORITY.
AND I CAN SAY VERY EMPHATICALLY
THAT THERE HAS BEEN NO NO ONE
WHO REPRESENTS AN OFFICIAL
ENTITY.
THERE'S BEEN ANY OFFICIAL VOTE
INCLUDING THE CITY OF CHICO FOR
THAT MATTER.
THAT IS SAID THEY OPPOSE THIS
BILL -- BUT IF THIS YEAR THE
CITY OF CHICO RIGHT NOW.
LET'S TALK ABOUT ANOTHER
EMERGENCY TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE.
AN ESTIMATED THAT ARE IN THE
CITY OF CHICO RIGHT NOW
PRECARIOUSLY HOUSE STE.
EITHER LIVING WITH WITH A FAMILY
MEMBER LIVING WITH FRIENDS
LIVING IN TRAILERS ON THE STREET.
LIVING IN TENTS.
HOMELESS THE IMPACTS ARE GOING
ON IN THAT CITY WE'RE TRYING TO
DO SOMETHING TO HELP ADDRESS
THOSE IMPACTS BY FINDING PEOPLE
STABLE HOUSING.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL WOULD
DO.
BUT AT THE CITY OF CHICO REALLY
DOESN'T WANT THIS HELP OF THIS
BILL.
FROM THIS BILL WILL BE HAPPY TO
TAKE THEM OUT.
IF THAT'S THE KIND OF STATEMENT
THAT THEY WANT TO MAKE.
THEY WILL BE HAPPY TO TAKE THEM
OUT AND OTHER COMMUNITIES THAT
WANT TO STEP UP AND HELP.
AND WHO HAVE ALREADY PUT OUT
PUBLIC DO -- BUT I JUST WANT TO
FIND SOLUTIONS FOR MY COMMUNITY
FOR THE PEOPLE.
THEY GOT UP HERE TODAY PEOPLE
THAT HAVE LOST LOVED ONES PEOPLE
THAT HAVE BEEN LIVING IN RV'S
THAT YOU HEARD FROM.
TODAY RIGHT THAT'S WHAT I DO
THIS FOR AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION FOR
THEM AND I'M.
AND I WANT TO THANK.
I JUST WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR
ABOUT I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE AND I WANT TO THANK
THE MEMBERS.
THE SERVER Là M<c.cyan> ONLY BEEN</c>
WORKING A LOT OF THE EMERGENCY
RESPONSE ISSUES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
EGGMAN.
CAME UP TO PARADISE.
THE VERY ATTENTIVE TO THIS ISSUE
INTO THE ISSUES THAT ARE
AFFECTING THE PEOPLE UP THERE.
AND MANY OTHERS THE SERVER
MATHIS -- THAT HAVE COME UP AND
SIT AND AND SEEN THE DEVASTATION
UP THERE IN THAT WANT TO HELP --
I AM VERY APPRECIATED ALL OF THE
APPRECIATED THE CHAIR WHO'S
TRYING TO FIND.
A SOLUTION HERE WE WANT TO
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE WE'RE
TRYING TO FIND A SOLUTION. FOR
PEOPLE WHO DESPERATELY NEED IT
RIGHT NOW -- I THINK WE CAN FIND
A WAY AND HOPEFULLY IN TWO WEEKS
WE'LL COME BACK HERE WITH THE
LANGUAGE WILL GET THE SAME WITH
THE FORD SO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TODAY.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE -- WHEN WE HAVE THIS
AMENDED MEASURE BEFORE YOU?
IN A COUPLE WEEKS AND HELP YOU
COUNTY RECOVER FROM ONE OF THE
MOST DEVASTATING DISASTERS IN
CALIFORNIA HISTORY.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE US TO GALLAGHER.
ALL RIGHT NEXT UP SOMEONE NUMBER.
THIRTEEN AB
.
SEVEN NINETY TWO SO EVER
WHATEVER YOU'RE READY PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
FIRSTLY JUST THANK THE CHAIR AND
THE CONSULTANT FOR THE
AMENDMENTS WILL BE HAPPY --
ACCEPTING THE MEMBERS THAT APPLY
THESE STANDARDS TO ONLY I
CALIFORNIA REDEMPTION VALUE
BOTTLES AND BASES THAT ON THE
MANUFACTURER'S AVERAGE -- A. B.
SEVEN ID TO ESTABLISH IS A TIME
LINE FOR PLASTIC BOTTLED
BEVERAGE MANY FACTORS TO USE
MINIMUM RECYCLED CONTENT IN
THEIR PLASTIC BOTTLES.
WITH THE GOAL OF GETTING 21100%
RECYCLED CONTENT BY.
TWENTY THIRTY FIVE AS YOU KNOW A
SIGNIFICANT PORTION OF
CALIFORNIA'S RECYCLE PLASTICS.
WERE SHIPPED OVERSEAS TO CHINA
INTEL LAST YEAR WITH CHINA
STOPPED TAKING AND PURCHASING
MOST OF OUR RECYCLED CONTENT.
NOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S FACING
THIS CRISIS I THINK WE HAVE TO
LOOK INTERNALLY TO FIGURE OUT
HOW BEST TO CAN REALLY HAVE
RECYCLED CONTENT IN OUR VARIOUS
PLASTIC BOTTLES.
IT JUST.
TO SET THE SET THE RECORD SO YOU
UNDERSTAND WHAT'S AT STAKE.
IS IF NOTHING ELSE IS DONE. TO
DEAL WITH THE RECYCLED PLASTICS
BY.
TWENTY FIFTY THERE WILL BE MORE
PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN THAT FISH.
SO IF YOU COULD THINK ABOUT THE
FACT THAT IF WE DON'T DO
ANYTHING BY TWENTY FIFTY WALK TO
HAVE MORE PLASTIC IN THE OCEAN
THAN FISH.
A NUMBER OF LEADING COMPANIES
HAVE ALREADY.
STARTED AND LEAD BY EXAMPLE WE
HAVE THE NAKED JUICE COMPANY
THEY HAVE BEEN USING BOTTLES
WITH 1100% POST RECYCLED
CONSUMER.
CONTENT IN EUROPE COCA COLA HAS
COMMITTED. TO HAS ALREADY BEEN
USING 25% RECYCLED PLASTIC AND
THEY'VE COMMITTED TO THE 50% BY --
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE RECYCLED
PLASTIC THE PROPOSAL IN EUROPE.
SO AGAIN IF WE CAN SET UP
MINIMUM CONTENT TO PLASTIC
BOTTLES IN CALIFORNIA TO HAVE
HUGE ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS WE
HAVE A COUPLE WITNESSES THROUGH
WILLING.
TO JUST BE VERY QUICKLY ON THE
ISSUE THANK.
MY APOLOGIES ON BEHALF OF THE
RECLAIMER IS IN THE RECYCLERS
THE PROCESSORS AND ON I HAVE ONE
WITH ME HERE FROM CARBON LIGHT
BUT VERY QUICKLY I JUST PASSED
OUT A A HAND OUT.
IT TALKS ABOUT WHAT MY CLIENTS
HAVE BEEN DOING AS FAR AS THEIR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO TO TRYING TO
HELP WITH BOTH THE BOTTLES OUT
OF LANDFILL AND GREENHOUSE GASES --
BUT IF YOU LOOK THROUGH YOU CAN
SEE SOME OF THE BOTTLES
EXPLAINING A 100%.
A 100% -- NAKED CHOOSE A 100% --
WE WERE TOLD YEARS AGO THAT IT
COULDN'T BE DONE NAKED USED AS A
100% ERRO HEAD DOES 50%.
EVERY ON DOES A 100% NESTLE PURE
LIFE DOES A 100% KIRKLIN WATER
DOES BOTH A HUNDRED AND FIFTY I
MEAN A HUNDRED AND 50% RECYCLED
CONTENT.
SO I THINK WE'VE COME TO THE
POINT WHERE I'LL JUST SAY THAT
IT'S IT'S REALLY NOT OK ANYMORE
TO JUST BE ABLE TO HAVE
SOMETHING RECYCLED.
BUT IT NEEDS TO ACTUALLY BE
RECYCLED IN THE STATE TO HELP
KEEP THIS OUT OF YOUR LANDFILL
AND AND OF WATER WAYS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS FOR TAKE UNDER
CONSIDERATION APOLOGIZE SIR.
REYES RICH COST ON THE DIRECTOR
PROCUREMENT SUSTAINABILITY IT
CORRELATE INDUSTRIES LONGER
COALITION A CALIFORNIA GROUP
REQUIREMENTS THAT CONSIST OF ALL
REQUIRES THE STATE EXCEPT.
FOR ONE WE PURCHASED THE BOTTLES
PIPE TRUCKLOAD FROM STATE
PROCESSORS AND RECYCLERS IN
EXCESS OF A HUNDRED MILLION
POUNDS OR TWO BILLION BOTTLES
ANNUALLY AND PROCESS MATERIAL.
THROUGH OUR PLANT RIVERSIDE BACK
IN A NEW PT PELLETS WHICH IS FDA
CERTIFIED FOR FOOD GRADE CONTACT
UP TO A 100%.
WE HAVE BEEN SUCCESSFULLY
PERFORMING THE SERVICES.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE WE'VE BEEN
DOWN THIS MINIMUM PATH GOING ON
FOR FOUR YEARS NOW AND GETTING
NEW GROUND EACH TIME.
WE EDUCATE.
THE WILLING OF THE FACTS ABOUT
INDUSTRIES CAPABILITY AND NOT
THE SECTIONAL HAVE TREES PUT OUT
BY SOME WHO SAY IT'S NOT SAFE
FOR FOR CONTACT BUT THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH GOOD MATERIAL.
OR RECYCLING IS FINDING
CALIFORNIA.
NGUYEN RECYCLE P. TWO BOTTLES
ARE DOWN CYCLE THAT TO OTHER
PRODUCTS AND SET UP SHORE THE
CHAIN IS BROKEN AND WE LOSE
ABILITY TO CLOSE THE LOOP.
AND LIMIT NEW FOSSIL FUELS LIVE
IT.
X. WITH THE LIMITED.
THAT'S WE LIMIT THAN DO.
OF SIDE THE NEW FOSSIL FUELS A
VIRGIN PT BADAK COULD BE PROCESS
BACK INTO A BOTTLE OVER AND OVER
AGAIN AND TELL US BANKS DOWN
CYCLE INTO ANOTHER PRODUCT OR
OFF SHORT.
IT'S A CHICKEN OR EGG ARGUMENT
THAT COMES TO MIND WE DISCUSS TO
DEBATE THIS TOPIC.
IT'S TRUE WE DO HAVE THE MOST
FOR BUS RECYCLING INFRASTRUCTURE
IN THE NATION WITH THE RECYCLING
RATE THAT HOVERS AROUND 70% YEAR
AFTER YEAR.
BUT WE MUST SET NEW STANDARDS TO
PUSH INDUSTRY TO REALIZE MORE
THE RECYCLE MATERIALS THAT THEY
SELL TO THE PUBLIC.
THE REALIZATION RATE FOR OUR PET
BACKING ABOLISHED EVER 007%.
YOU HAVE A GREAT RECYCLING STORY
WE NOW NEED WE'RE GREAT
RECYCLING THAT WE NEED
REALIZATION AND PRACTICE TO
CLOSE THE LOOP AT CIRCA CONNERY
WE MUST DO BETTER.
I UNDERSTAND OUR FRIENDS ON THE
OTHER SIDE WHO OPPOSE A MANDATE
MANY OF WHOM ARE OUR CUSTOMERS
BY THE WAY.
NO ONE WANTS GOVERNMENT TELLING
THEM HOW TO RUN THEIR BUSINESS.
BUT THEY HAVE THE OPTION BE A
VIRGIN WE DO NOT.
IT'S IF IT'S AT A COST SAVINGS
TO THEM THE MATTEL YES WE USE IT
BUT ONLY IF IT'S CHEAPER.
UNFORTUNATELY COSTS ASSOCIATED
WITH RECYCLING FOR STRUCTURE THE
STATE HAS NO BEARING ON DOMESTIC
OR INTERNATIONAL VERGE OF
PRICING AT ALL THAT PUTS OUR
INDUSTRY IN A NO WIN SITUATION.
TAKE ORDERS A LOSS OF HOPE
VIRGIN RESIN GOES UP AT SOME
POINT OR SHUT DOWN A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLAR PLAN THAT'S JUST
ONE COMPANY.
WE NEED ONGOING GUARANTEE FOR
THE BALLING THE STREET TO SECURE
CAPITAL INVESTMENTS FOR FUTURE
GROWTH EXPANSIONS WITHIN THE
STATE AND WITHOUT IT WE COULD
LOSE A GREAT SUCCESS STORY WE
HAVE A CALIFORNIA RECYCLING.
A CLOSE WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO
TAKE ANY QUESTIONS THE MAP.
THANK YOU.
WITH US.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MARK VERY WITH
THE ENVIRONMENT OF CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER TINGS MEASURE
WILL ENHANCE AND EXPAND THE
MARKETS FOR THE NINE BILLION
PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THAT
CONSUMERS ARE ALREADY RECOVERED.
AND IT ALSO CREATE NEW
INCENTIVES FOR THE THREE AND A
HALF BILLION PLASTIC BOTTLES
THAT WE AREN'T RECYCLING THAT
ARE GETTING LITERATURE LANDFILLS.
THE EXPERIENCE THIS WHOLE CHINA
NATIONAL SOARED.
EPISODE HAS TOLD US THAT WE'RE
NOT REALLY RECYCLING UNLESS
SOMEBODY IS BUYING THAT MATERIAL
IF THEY'RE NOT BUYING THE
PLASTIC AND PUTTING IT INTO A
NEW PRODUCT THAT WE'RE NOT
REALLY RECYCLING.
OUGHT THE RECYCLE CONTENT THE
IDEA OF MANDATING RECYCLE
CONTENT IS SOMETHING THAT THIS
STATE PIONEERED TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO.
YOUR PREDECESSORS SET MINIMUM
RECYCLE CONTENT REQUIREMENTS FOR
NEWSPRINT FOR NON FOOD PLASTIC
CONTAINERS ALL AND FOR GLASS
CONTAINERS.
TODAY WE HAVE A 35% RECYCLED
CONTENT MANDATE FOR GLASS
CONTAINERS BUT THE MARKET.
THAT WE HELP BUILD IS ACHIEVING
MORE THAN 50% RECYCLED CONTENT
AND THE RECOVERY RATE FOR THE PT
BOTTLE IS HIGHER THAN THE
RECOVERY RATE FOR GLASS BOTTLES.
AND WE ONLY HAVE ONE PROCESSOR
FOR GLASS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND YET WE'RE USING
50% RECYCLED CONTENT.
WE HAVE MORE THAN A HALF A DOZEN
PROCESSORS OF RECYCLED PLASTIC
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND THE REASON THAT WE HAVE A
HALF A DOZEN PROCESSORS FOR THAT
MATERIAL IS BECAUSE PRIVATE
INVESTORS IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAVE INVESTED IN THAT.
WE'VE USED TAX CREDITS WE'VE
USED MORE THAN A HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS.
IN TAX CREDITS IN ON RUDY MONEY
FROM THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
RECYCLING PROGRAM TO DEVELOP
THESE FACILITIES.
AND WE NOW HAVE CAPACITY IN
CALIFORNIA FOR PROCESSING AND
TURNING INTO FOOD GRADE
PACKAGING.
ANOTHER PLASTIC.
BUT ENOUGH PLASTIC TO RECYCLE
EVERYTHING THAT'S COLLECTED IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT THAT
SYSTEM IS BEING UNDER UTILIZED
BECAUSE THE BEVERAGE CONTAINER
MANUFACTURERS ARE NOT BUYING
THAT MATERIAL BACK.
THIS MEASURE WILL REQUIRE THAT
THEY BY THE MATERIAL BACK WE ARE
CHEN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
NATALIE KNOCKS ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT.
OR FRONT TEND TO HAVE THE
CALIFORNIA REFUSE RECYCLING
COUNCIL NORTHERN DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE MORE ON BEHALF OF
APOLOGY AND SUPPORT.
HELLO VICTORIA ROOM WITH NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT.
AND ONLY ZERO DEFENDERS OF
WILDLIFE IN SUPPORT.
PERSONAL GET US ON BEHALF OF
SOLOWAY CESSATION NORTH AMERICA
AND STOP WASTE IN SUPPORT.
A GOOD EVENING TONY GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF TOM AND WITH AMERICA
IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BASE SEVENTH GENERATION
ADVISORS AND THE OTHER MEMBERS
OF THE CLEAN SEIZE LOVING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER SAVAGE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
THEN I CAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF
SAN FRANCISCO BAY KEEPER AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
SEE AN NINE ANY OPPOSITION.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CHAIR.
I'M SORRY ABOUT THAT AB THERE.
FEDERICA MCGEE ON BEHALF OF THE
AMERICAN BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION --
UNFORTUNATELY OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED COUPLE OF CONCERNS WE
HAVE MOSTLY WE WANT TO SEE
RECYCLE CONTENT NOT OPPOSED TO
THAT THE NUMBERS THAT ARE
OUTLINED IN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY
TWO OR SIMPLY NOT REACHABLE --
WHEN WE TALK ABOUT OUR
COLLECTION RATE IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE A SEVENTY FIVE OR 80%
COLLECTION RIGHT SO IF YOU GET
275% OR A 100% WHICH ARE
OUTLINED IN AB?
SEVEN NINETY TWO IT DOESN'T
RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT WE'RE
NOT GETTING A 100% EVENING
COLLECTED BACK -- LET ALONE THE
CONTAMINATION THAT WE TALKED
ABOUT EVEN IN -- AGUILAR CARRIES
BILL EARLIER TODAY SO WE ARE
ALREADY DOWN FROM 1100% ACTUALLY
DOWN THE 75% IF THAT'S THE
COLLECTION RATE AT THAT
PARTICULAR TIME.
THE SECOND THING THERE'S YIELD
LOSS OUR P. R. C. C. DID A STUDY
IN THE FALL WITH OUR RECLAIMER
IS AND AND AND LOOKED AT ABOUT.
THIRTY THREE AT THREE THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED AND FIFTY EIGHT
POUNDS OF SORTED BAIL SO WHEN
YOU GET THE BALES A COME BACK.
EVEN THE RECLAIMER IS HAD A TEN
AND A HALF PERCENT YIELD LOSS
FROM THE BAIL THAT CAME BACK SO
NOW YOU'RE ALREADY DOWN FROM
WHATEVER THE 75%.
OF OUR COLLECTION RADIUS FROM
WHAT YOU GET BACK FROM WHAT THEY
GET BACK TO THAT TO THE BAIL SO
YOU'RE NEVER GOING TO GET TO A
75% OR A 100% RATE.
TURNING AROUND INTO ANOTHER
BOTTLE -- WE TALK ABOUT THE FDA
STANDARDS THAT IS IMPORTANT AND
OUR OTHER OUR OTHER PRODUCTS
SUCH AS THAT THEY TALKED ABOUT
WHAT A 100%.
RECYCLED CONTENT RATE THAT'S
RIGHT THERE ARE SOME BEVERAGES
THAT THAT BOTTLE CAN HAVE 1100%
RECYCLED CONTENT BUT THERE ARE
CARBONATED DRINKS WHERE THE THAT --
CONSISTENCY OF THAT BOTTLE MUST
BE DIFFERENT BASED ON THE FDA
STANDARDS AND SO ALL BEVERAGES
ARE NOT COULD CREATED THE COOL
THE EXAMPLES WERE YOU KNOW SOME
OF OUR OUR OUR DRINKS THAT KIND
OF OUR WATER OR OTHER PRODUCTS
AND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE TYPE
OF PRODUCT.
IT IS VERY IMPORTANT TIME LINES
ARE CONCERNING HERE SOME OF THE
CONTRACTS ARE. TWO IN THREE
YEARS OUT WE DON'T HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO GET THERE AND SO
EVEN IF WE CAN LAND ON A NUMBER
OR A TIME MIND WE ALSO THINK
THAT.
PRICE GOUGING CONCERN SHOULD BE
CONSENT LAID OUT IN THE BILL AND
THOSE PROTECTION SHOULD BE IN
THERE THERE SHOULD BE --
CONSPIRE AS CONCESSIONS FOR
COMPANIES LIKE COCA COLA WHO
HAVE PLANT BASED PRODUCTS THAT
ARE NOT PUTTING AS MUCH VIRGIN
INTO THE TO THE SYSTEM AND THAT
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED AN ART LAID
OUT.
IN HERE AS WELL AND SO AND
LASTLY -- THERE SHOULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO AVERAGE IT ACROSS
THE PORTFOLIO BECAUSE ALL
BEVERAGES ARE NOT THE SAME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
DENNIS I'LL BE ON A ON A BEHALF
THE GROCERY MANUFACTURERS BUT
THE ABA REPRESENT OF LAID OUT A
VERY GOOD -- SET THAT THIS IS
JUST COMPLETELY IN FEASIBLE THE
TIME LINES ARE NOT -- COULD NOT
BE MAD AND IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT
THE BIG LARGE MANUFACTURERS
THERE'S ALSO -- YOU THINK ABOUT
ALL THE STORE BRANDS THE BELL
THE PRIVATE MANUFACTURES BE ABLE
TO GET TO THAT FIRST STEP --
WHICH IN THIS BILL IS NEXT YEAR
REQUIRE ONE YEAR FOR COMPLIANCE
SO THOSE ARE AREAS THAT THAT
THAT NEED TO BE ADDRESSED.
I THINK ALSO THERE'S ALSO
REGRETTABLE SUBSTITUTION THESE
BOTTLES THE PT THAT.
THAT THE PROPONENTS BROUGHT
FORWARD IS A 1100% RECYCLABLE
BOTTLE.
AND BY THE WAY THAT THE NATIONAL
SORT.
WITH A VERY SIGNIFICANT ISSUE
BUT FOR OUR PET.
OUR PET ACTUALLY THE PRICEY
RETAINED VERY STRONG VALUE
THROUGHOUT THAT TIME WOULD DUMP
A FEW MONTHS AND BOUNCE BACK UP
TO EQUILIBRIUM.
SO OUR PET IS A DIFFERENT
MATERIAL BASED ON DIFFERENT.
AND NATIONAL INTERNATIONAL
MARKETS.
AND SO.
WELL WE DON'T WANT TO DO IS TO
DRIVE TO A REGRETTABLE
SUBSTITUTION SITUATION WE HAVE
THINGS LIKE THIS THIS CAME OUT
OF THE SIX OF FLOOR CAFETERIA.
THIS IS NOT A WILD IS PAPER IT
IS LINED WITH A WITH A LINER
THAT IS NOT RECYCLABLE IT HAS A
SECOND MATERIAL IN HERE WHICH IS
A PLASTIC PRODUCT.
AND SO THIS IS A VERY ON
RECYCLABLE UP.
OF A PACKAGE IT'S A WE DON'T
WANT TO DRY THINGS OUT OF OUR
PETS ARE PET IS A IS A ISA GOOD
MATERIAL AND WE CAN GET BEHIND.
RECYCLED CONTENT AS THE MOST OF
THE THE THE MANUFACTURERS HAVE
ALREADY.
IT'S JUST A MATTER OF
FEASIBILITY TIMING LIKE SAY ONE
MORE THING SO MARCH TWENTY
SEVENTH THE THE E. U..
LAID OUT THEIR STANDARDS AND
THEY STUDY THIS FOR SEVERAL
YEARS THEY LOOKED AT IT VERY
INTENTLY AND THEIR STANDARDS ARE
25% BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO THEY GIVE%
A FIVE SIX YEAR A GLIDE PATH ON
THAT.
AND THEN THEY ARE 30% BY.
TWENTY THIRTY THEY ALSO HAVE A
GOAL -- REQUIREMENT OF OF 90% OF
RECYCLING.
AND SO THEY HAVE A MUCH BETTER
RECLAIMING SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE
AND THEY'RE STILL AT THOSE
NUMBERS SO THAT THAT'S CLEARLY A
DEMONSTRATION THAT THAT'S NOT
FEASIBLE TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THIS BILL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SO MUCH ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION NAME AN ORGANIZATION
PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE IN SOME THE NUMBER
TING MY NAME'S THEIR THOMAS ON
BEHALF OF NIAGARA BOTTLING WITH
THE LARGEST PRIVATE LABEL.
BOTTLED WATER COMPANY IN THE
COUNTRY AND THE LARGEST USER OUR
PET IN CALIFORNIA WERE IN
OPPOSITION MEMBER PROPOSAL WE
WILL.
LOOK FOR THE WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND WE'RE VERY
OPTIMISTIC WE CAN CHANGE
SOMETHING THANK YOU SO MUCH.
MY CORPORATE BEHALF OF NESTLE
WATERS NORTH AMERICA ALSO IN
OPPOSITION BUT I DO JUST WANT TO
SAY WE'RE WALKING THE WALK AS
MYSTERY JUST.
POINTED OUT AT 50% ON ARROWHEAD.
AND WE DO INTEND TO COLLECTIVE
WERE COMMITTED TO COLLECTIVELY --
TO CONSTRUCTIVELY ENGAGING WITH
MR MURRAY OUR BUSINESS PARTNERS
THE RECLAIMER IS TO GET A
SOLUTION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
ALL RIGHT.
ANYONE ELSE OPPOSITION SEE AN
NINE ANY QUESTION COMMITTEE.
THE SEGMENT.
I THINK YOU AB.
THANK YOU MISTER KING FOR
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE -- AND I
GUESS MY QUESTION WAS ABOUT.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THAT'S THAT'S
A PRETTY FAST TURN AROUND TIME
AND ALSO ABOUT THE U. RIGHT TO
THE YOU HAVE STUDIED THIS.
AND SO I GUESS.
HAVE YOU CONSIDERED THAT AND
THEN TO THE OPPOSITION WITH THE
E. U. MODEL B. DO YOU THINK
THAT'S MORE FEASIBLE.
SO SO HOT HAPPY -- TO WE DON'T
HAVE HAD THAT INITIAL MEETINGS
WITH THE OPPOSITION IN TERMS OF
IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD WHAT WERE
HAPPY AND OPEN -- TO BOTH
DIFFERENT PERCENTAGES AS WELL
DIFFERENT TIMELINE.
WE LOOKED AT THE KEY YOU MODEL --
WE THINK IT'S IT'S WORTH TAKING
A LOOK AT BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT
WE YOU KNOW WE ALWAYS LOOK AT
OURSELVES A SORT OF LEADING NOT
NECESSARILY FOLLOWING.
SO THE FACT THAT THE E. U. --
HAS SET A BENCHMARK I THINK IS
GOOD BUT I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE TO JUST
ACCEPT.
THE 30% BY TWENTY THIRD I MEAN
TO THE 25% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
AS WELL ROUTE.
THAT WE THOUGHT WE COULD BE MORE
AGGRESSIVE IN THE HOPE IS THAT
ONCE YOU GET INTO THIS.
PRACTICE OF RECYCLING BIN I
THINK IT COULD REALLY PICKS UP A
LOT OF STEAM.
I THINK THE OTHER PIECE -- JUST
JUST TO GO FOR A COUPLE COUPLE
DIFFERENT PIECES.
IN TERMS OF NESTLE NESTE IS
ALREADY COMMITTED TO I BELIEVE
50% BUT BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE WE ALSO MR
BIONDI I'LL BE ON A HAD THE HERE
WILL LOOKS LIKE A SMALL MILK
CARTON -- IN IN CERTAIN PLACES
THAT IS COMPOSTABLE AT FAULT YOU
CUT OUT THE PLASTIC PIECE OF IT
SO AGAIN.
THAT ACTUALLY IS COMPOSTABLE IS
NOT NOT JUST NOT IT'S NOT JUST --
RECYCLABLE IS COMPOSTABLE SO --
IT ALSO WITH THE THE OGIC OF
THE BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION IS SORT
OF LIKE -- A VERY ODD TYPE OF
MATH THAT WAS SORT OF BEING USED
IN TERMS OF WELL BECAUSE YOU
CAN'T.
GET BACK EVERY SINGLE BOTTLE
THEN YOU CAN ACTUALLY.
RECEIVE GET A 100% WELL WHAT'S
ACTUALLY HAPPENING IS IN DOUBT
NOT ONLY ARE WE NOT GETTING BACK
IN THE BOTTLE FOR ACTUALLY USING
MORE AND MORE AND MORE PLASTIC
BOTTLES OUT THERE.
THAT THAT'S A BIGGER ISSUE THE
BIGGER ISSUE IS IS.
THE USE OF PLASTIC BOTTLES IS
FRANKLY NOT SUSTAINABLE NOTHING
BEFORE LANDFILLS NOT SUSTAINABLE
FOR OUR OCEANS NOT SUSTAINABLE
FOR OUR STATE I THINK.
IT'S REALLY TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW DO WE GET THOSE -- GET THAT
QATAR RECYCLED AND RE USE IN IT
TO TRY TO BE PRETTY AGGRESSIVE
ABOUT.
IF I COULD JUST CLARIFY THE
YIELD.
PERSPECTIVES I'M SORRY.
YEAH RIGHT WHEN WE MIND THAT WAS
A PROJECT.
WELL I I WAS JUST ASKING IF THE
OPPONENTS.
ARE OKAY WITH THE WHAT.
IF THEY THINK THAT IS A MORE
REASONABLE.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THEY'VE LEFT.
SO WE HAVE A GROCERY
MANUFACTURERS WITH THE BRANDED
FOOD COMPANIES -- WE THINK THE
25% BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE IS IS
A LIVE IS A YEAH A GOOD WRAP UP
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE CONTRACT
WOULD LOOK AT THE PHASE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE AMOUNT OF MATERIAL.
AND I IN THAT 30% BY TWENTY BY
TWENTY THIRTY IS IS ABSOLUTELY
MAYBE WE COULD EVEN DO BETTER.
THANK YOU MAY HAVE PERMISSION
JUST TO GO INTO THAT TOO WE WILL
BE A BUSINESS BY THEN.
LITERALLY WE'VE ALREADY LOST.
ONE I'M SORRY I'M SORRY I JUST
WALKED IN I WHAT WHAT DOES YOUR
INTO YOU AND THREE TO TWO OF THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN.
ON THE QUESTION OF WAITING I WAS
ALSO ANYBODY YOU AND THE AND THE
OPPONENTS -- TO TO TO THAT
QUESTION ASSEMBLY MEMBER EGGMAN --
YOU KNOW NIAGARA LIKE AS I WAS
SAYING IS THE LARGEST PRODUCED --
BUYER OF OUR PAY IN THE STATE IT
WAS REFLECTED IN LAST WEEK'S CAR
CYCLE REPORT -- WE YOU KNOW
WE'RE CLOSE 240% WE USE THE
STUFF WE LIKE IT WE ENCOURAGE IT.
WE DON'T EMBRACE THE U. MODEL
WITH THE GUYS WERE STUDYING.
I MEAN THERE'S THERE'S THERE'S A
LOT OF ELEMENTS TO THAT PROPOSAL
THAT'S WORTHY OF FURTHER REVIEW --
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
RECLAIMER IS WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL COMMUNITY WITH
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE.
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS AMOUNTS
IN THE BEVERAGE COMMUNITY TO
WORK ON SOMETHING THAT'S
ACHIEVABLE AND REALISTIC THIS
BILL.
REGRETTABLY I I YOU KNOW ARTS
ARE OPINION IT'S IT'S NOT THAT
BUT IT CAN BE AND WE HOPE TO GET
THERE SO WITH YOUR SUPPORT AND
GUIDANCE.
WE THINK WE CAN WE CAN GET THERE
SO SOUNDS LIKE EVERYBODY'S
WORKING LOOKING IS EVERYONE IS
EAGER TO TERRY HARD I'M KIND OF
AGREEMENT -- AND I WOULD.
AND I WOULD JUST SAY TO TO MR
TANG.
WITH THE THE THE LITTLE CARTON
I'M UP I AM A SERIOUS RECYCLE
SEC RECYCLER CYCLER -- PERSON
WHO RECYCLES.
BUT I WILL SAY THAT THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO AND OUR AVERAGE
PERSON WHO RECYCLES IS NOT GOING
TO TAKE A PART THAT THAT CARTON
I MEAN I I DO IT SOMETIMES AND I
HAVE TO ADMIT SOMETIMES I DON'T
ALWAYS PULL IT ALL APART AND
THEN.
AND THEN WE HAVE THE PROBLEM
THAT LED TO THE NATIONAL SORT.
TO BRING THIS FORWARD AND IT'S A
COMPLICATED ISSUE THAT WE'RE ARE
GRAPPLING WITH.
MS EGGMAN I'M SORRY MISS GARCIA
[inaudible]
OKAY -- WE SAW -- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GONZALEZ HERE RECENTLY
PRESENTING HER BILL DEALING WITH
WITH PLASTICS AND I I TOLD HER
AND HER SPONSORS THAT IF THIS IS
THE APPROACH WE'RE GOING TO BE
DEALING WITH PLASTIC THAT WE
NEEDED TO HAVE -- A BILL SIMILAR
TO WHAT YOU'RE DOING I WILL SAY
THOUGH I HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
WHETHER OR NOT THE TARGET OF A
100% IS FEASIBLE.
IN IN THIS BILL.
AND SO I WOULD URGE YOU TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
STAKEHOLDERS.
BEFORE THIS COMES TO THE FLOOR
TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT'S
THAT'S FEASIBLE.
IN GENERAL PRACTICALITY SPEAKING
ONCE WE START TO GET PAST THE
THIRD NUMBER FINISHINGS BECOME
EITHER TOO EXPENSIVE -- AND AND
I THINK YOU CAN GET A PRETTY
HIGH NUMBER.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT THE E.
U. MODEL AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
30% IS HIGH ENOUGH IN ALL
HONESTY.
ON AND SO YOU KNOW BUT I DO
QUESTION WHETHER 1100% IS USABLE
FOR ALL THESE PRODUCTS AND WE
HAVE PRODUCTS OUT THERE THAT ARE
AN EXAMPLE ARE READY 290%.
BUT I DO THINK WE NEED TO BE
THINKING ABOUT.
ABOUT IT -- AND I DON'T KNOW IF
IT'S TIED TO OUR RECYCLE
CONTINENT WHERE WAS TO PRODUCE
OR SOMETHING ELSE AND HOW YOU
GET TO THAT NUMBER I I APOLOGIZE
THAT I'M NOT GIVING YOU A
SOLUTION.
THAT THE CONCERN THAT I HAVE
MOVING FORWARD BUT FOR TODAY I
AM.
READY TO SUPPORT THE BILL TO
KEEP THE DISCUSSION GOING AND
NEVER GOING TO BE HAVING AB TEN
EIGHTY AND ITS COMPANION BILL IN
THE SENATE.
WE NEED TO HAVE -- SOME SORT OF
CONTENT BILL SPELL THANK YOU.
SO HAPPY TO WE'VE WE'VE HAD SOME
INITIAL DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
BEVERAGE ASSOCIATION AND THEY
DID -- POINT OUT CERTAIN TYPES
OF BOTTLES THAT PERHAPS COULD
COULD EVENTUALLY GET THERE IS
SOMEONE THAT WOULD ACTUALLY
NEVER GET THERE SO I THINK.
THE OPEN TO DIFFERENT IN THAT
DISCUSSION -- THE THE THE GERMAN
FROM NIAGARA HAS NOT COME INTO
THE OFFICE OF WHERE THE HAPPY TO
BE INTERESTED IN HEARING WHAT
HAS PROPOSAL WOULD BE. TO TO SEE
HOW IT MATCHES WITH OURS BUT
WHAT WE'RE MORE THAN HAPPY TO
CONTINUE THESE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS IS TECH.
THE BIGGEST SERVICE I THINK I
COULD HAVE DONE YOU THIS YEAR'S
RUN THE LEAST THE LID BOTTLE
[inaudible]
AGAIN BECAUSE AS WE TRIED TO DO
THAT AND HAD LOTS AND LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE MAJOR
FILERS THEY SAID DON'T DO THIS
TO US DON'T DO THIS TO US.
WE'LL SHOW YOU HOW GREAT WE ARE
DOING -- AND RECYCLE CONTENT IN
OUR BOTTLES AND SO THEY LAID OUT
THESE GREAT NUMBERS AND I THINK
YOUR YOUR PATH IS REALLY WHAT
THEY WERE TRYING.
TO USE TO CONVINCE US TO NOT DO
THE LEAST THE LEAD SO IT'S IT'S
INTERESTING THIS YEAR NOW ALL
SAID THIS IS THE BIG BUGABOO AND
WE CAN'T GET THERE.
THAT'S THE REFRAIN WE CONSTANTLY
HEAR OH CAN'T DO THIS INVISIBLE
INVISIBLE VISIBLE AND THEN TURNS
OUT THINGS ARE VISIBLE.
SO I I WISH YOU LUCK DO YOU HAVE
A MOTION ON THIS YET.
HAVE YOU SOCIAL QUORUM.
WE DO HAVE A QUORUM THAT ARTICLE
MOTION ON THIS BILL.
OKAY WITH EMOTION THE SECOND ANY
OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL
TODAY AND I DO A REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BRING IT FOR THIS
IS ONE OF THE BIGGEST CRISIS IS
WE HAVE IN THE STATE RIGHT NOW
IN FRONT OF THIS COMMITTEE SO
THANK YOU.
I DO YOU HAVE ANY YOU WANT TO
CLOSE TO DO JUST VERY QUICKLY
CLOSING WITH THE YOU KNOW YOU'RE
YOU'RE YOU'RE GONE MADAM CHAIR
BUT REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR WORK
THE CONSULTANTS WORKING WORKING
WITH AS I HEAR AT THE FEEDBACK
FROM MY COLLEAGUES I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT WE KNOW.
THIS ISSUE IS A CHALLENGING
ISSUE WE WERE WERE UP TO I KNOW
THAT THE STATE DOES BODIES UP TO
THE CHALLENGE.
AND WE'RE GOING TO KEEP WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE GOING
TO GET -- A MINIMUM CONTENT
BUILT ON THE SHORES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WITHOUT WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL A SECOND WE HAVE A VOTE A
ROLL CALL VOTE PLEASE.
ITEM TEN A. B. SEVEN NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TEAM THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING.
RIGHT TO TREAT STONE
[inaudible]
SO [inaudible] NINE FOR ONE THE
VOTERS FORTY ONE BELIEVE THE
REAL OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH [inaudible]
MISTER KALRA [inaudible]
YOUR NEXT.
WITH ELEVEN SIXTY TWO YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY
.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
THE SENATE BILL ELEVEN SIXTY TWO
WILL TAKE ME FOR ACTION TO CURB
SINGLE HOUSE ON THE BILL'S
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND
COUNTY AMOUNTS.
PROVISIONAL PLASTIC WASTE AS WE
WERE JUST DISCUSSING AND AND
THIS COMMITTEE IS AS COST REALLY
OVER MANY YEARS -- IS HAVING
DEVASTATING IMPACT OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND AS IN DALLAS IS
RIGHTLY POINTS OUT ITS POLICING
OUR OCEANS.
SINGLE USE PLASTIC IS ALSO
ADDING TO OUR LANDFILLS.
THOSE TINY PLASTIC SHAMPOO
SHAMPOO BOTTLES OTHER PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS REPRESENT A
SIZEABLE AMOUNT OF WASTE I CAN
EASILY BE ELIMINATED. TWO MORE
COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
ALTERNATIVES.
THINK ABOUT IT WHEN YOU STAY IN
A HOTEL EVERY DAY WORKERS MUST
RESTOCK POSSIBLE THE NEW ONES
OFTENTIMES REGARDLESS OF FULL
USED BY THE GAS OR JUST USING A
SMALL FRACTION OF IT.
WITH OVER NINETY FIVE HUNDRED
TRAVEL ACCOMMODATION EMPLOYERS
IN THE STATE AND HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF HOTEL ROOMS A
PLASTIC WASTE STREAM QUICKLY
ADDS UP.
BACK ORDER THE AMERICAN HOTEL
LODGING ASSOCIATION AS PACOLLI A
APPROXIMATELY HALF A MILLION
HOTEL ROOMS IN CALIFORNIA AND
THOSE ARE JUST THOSE THEIR
ACCOUNT ABOUT THAT PARTICULAR
ASSOCIATION.
SO LIKELY MANY MORE.
BOB IF YOU OF COUNT FOR A
THOUSAND BOTTLES PER ROOM PER
YEAR SUGGEST BY THE WALL STREET
JOURNAL.
THAT AMOUNTS TO APPROXIMATELY
HALF A BILLION PLASTIC BOTTLES
IN CALIFORNIA ALONE EVERY YEAR
AND AGAIN THAT'S A CONSERVATIVE
ESTIMATE.
BASED UPON THE NUMBER OF ROOMS --
THAT WE HAVE.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO PROHIBITS A
LODGING ESTABLISHMENT PROVIDING
SMALL PLASTIC BOTTLES CONTAINING
A PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS. TO A
GAS AND THE SLEEPING
ACCOMMODATION.
FORTUNATELY MANY BUSINESSES AND
BRANDS IN THE HOTEL INDUSTRY ARE
ALREADY FACING OUT THE SMALL
PLASTIC BOTTLES AND PAPER PAPER --
FOR REFILLABLE DISPENSERS OR IN
THE CASE OF SOAPS USING A PAPER.
OF A BY NOT OFFERING SMALL
PLASTIC BOTTLES OF PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS HOTELS MOTELS AND OTHER
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS.
WE SB CAN REDUCE SINGLE USE
PLASTIC CONSUMPTION AND
INCREASED CONSUMER AWARENESS OF
OUR USE OF PLASTIC IN FACT A LOT
OF WHAT THE HOTEL INDUSTRY IS
DOING IS BEING DRIVEN BY
CONSUMER CHOICE AND PREFERENCE
AS WELL.
I'VE BEEN A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL AND LODGING
ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
ASSOCIATION AMERICAN ASIAN
AMERICAN HOTEL OWNERS
ASSOCIATION -- AND YOU KNOW WE
ACTUALLY HAD MET WITH THEM
BEFORE THIS BILL WAS EVEN
INTRODUCED AS A SIGN OF GOOD
FAITH THAT WE REALLY WANT TO
WORK WITH THE WITH THE INDUSTRY.
AND MAKING SURE THIS IS DONE
AWAY DONE IN A WAY THAT'S
RESPECTFUL OF ALL STAKEHOLDERS --
AND JUST RECENTLY -- THE IT
INDUSTRY TOOK A SUPPORT OF A MAN
A POSITION ON A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO AND I'M VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT.
MY HOPE.
AND INTENTION IS TO KEEP WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY AND COME TO AN
AGREEMENT ON THE BILL'S TIME
FRAME AND SCOPE OF ALREADY
RECOGNIZE THE NEED. TO DELAY --
THE BILL BUT BEFORE A THREE YEAR
TIME LINE TO GET BUSINESSES TIME.
TO DEPLETE THE CURRENT STOCK IS
DAHLE DISPENSERS AND ENSURE THEY
HAVE DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLY.
SO MANY VIABLE ALTERNATIVES TO
PROVIDING SMALL PLASTIC BOTTLES
OF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS LIKE
SHAMPOO THE LOGIC IN IT
INDUSTRIES IN A PRIME POSITION
TO PHASE OUT THE PRACTICE.
AND CONTINUE THEIR COMMITMENT AS
AN INDUSTRY THAT'S VERY FOUR
FOUR THINK ON THESE ISSUES -- TO
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP OF
REDUCING PLASTIC WASTE WASTE.
WOULD BE TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS KATHERINE -- DAY
EXACTED DIRECTORS SAVE UP FOR
SAVE OUR SHORES.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
AS JUST SAID MY NAME IS
KATHERINE -- DAY AND AS THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR.
OF THE SAVE OUR SHORES AND ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIAN
CONSTITUENTS -- WE ARE HERE TO
SUPPORT AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO SAVE
OUR SHORES AS A NONPROFIT BASED
IN SANTA CRUZ CALIFORNIA WHOSE
MISSION IS TO STEWART CLEAN
SHORES HEALTHY HABITATS AND
LIVING WATERS.
WHICH FOSTER THRIVING MARINE
SYSTEMS ALONG THE CENTRAL COAST.
PLASTIC POLLUTION AS EVIDENCED
BY THE EXPLOSION OF MAINSTREAM
NEWS COVERAGE HAS REACHED A
CRISIS STAGE.
SERIOUS ACTION IS REQUIRED TO
STEM THE TALKS A VACATION NUMBER
OCEAN THE DEATH OF SEA LIFE AND
SEE BIRDS IN THE VERY HEALTH AND
WELL BEING OF HUMANS.
TRACES THE PLASTICS ARE NOW
FOUND IN FOODS AND BEVERAGES WE
CONSUME INCLUDING FISH SEA SALT
HONEY TAP WATER AND WATER.
PLASTICS AND THEIR TOXIC AND
CARCINOGENIC ADDITIVES HAVE ALSO
BEEN FOUND IN HUMAN BLOOD IN
STOOL.
MANY HOTEL CHAINS INCLUDING MARY
ON HILTON HAVE ALREADY BEGUN
SWITCHING TO WALL MOUNTED
DISPENSER STIRRED REDUCE WASTE.
PER STUDY RELEASED BY MARRIOTT
AN AVERAGE SIZE HOTEL WHICH THEY
DEFINE AS ONE HUNDRED AND FORTY
ROOM PROPERTY.
CAN ELIMINATE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND BOTTLES PER YEAR
YIELDING TWO THOUSAND IN ANNUAL
SAVINGS WHILE ALSO YOU ALSO.
KEEPING ROUGHLY TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE POUNDS OF PLASTIC
CONSUMING EACH BOTTLE WEIGHS
ONLY ONE POINT FIVE OUNCES OUT
OF THE LANDFILL EVERY YEAR.
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL A WIN WIN
SCENARIO.
LIMITING SINGLE USE PLASTIC
TOILETRY BOTTLES ALSO RESULTS IN
GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTION.
GHGS ARE RELEASED DURING EVERY
PHASE OF EVERY YEAH EACH PLASTIC
BOTTLES LIFECYCLE FROM FOSSIL
FUEL EXTRACTION THROUGH PLASTIC
RESIN PRODUCTION TO PACKAGING
MANUFACTURING LANDFILL DISPOSAL.
USING THESE ARGUMENTS WE WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN URGING THE SANTA
CRUZ COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
TO TAKE ACTION.
IN NOVEMBER TWO IN NOVEMBER OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IF YOU CAN
FINISH UP PLEASE YOUR TIME IS
YET.
SANTA CRUZ BECAME THE FIRST
COUNTY AND MAYBE A IN THE
CALIFORNIA AND POSSIBLY IN THE
U. S. TO PASS SUCH IN A MEASURE.
WE'RE ALSO WORKING IN HAVE
ACTIVE -- AN INDICATION OF
ACTION FROM SIT CITY OF SANTA
CRUZ SCOTTS VALLEY CAPITAL LACKS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIRMAN.
JOHN CALDWELL ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR REACHING OUT TO US -- WE
ARE NOT OPPOSED TO THE BILL AS
HE SAID WE WE I HAVE ASKED --
FIRST AMENDMENTS AND WE WOULD
SUPPORT IT IF THOSE AMENDMENTS
ARE TAKEN OUR INDUSTRIES A
LEADER IT'S BEEN POINTED OUT AND
SUSTAINABILITY AND DEMONSTRATED
TANGIBLE COMMITMENT. TO
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP.
INTER CONTINENTAL HOTEL GROUP
HAS RECEIVED THE HIGHEST SCORE
FOR THE INDUSTRY ON THE
CORPORATE SUSTAINABILITY
ASSESSMENT HEALTH IN AS REDUCE
LANDFILL WASTE BY 41%.
HI IT IS COMMITTED TO DIVERTING
40% OF ITS WASTE FROM LANDFILLS
BY THE END OF TWENTY TWENTY
MARRIOTT HAS -- RECYCLED OVER A
HUNDRED THOUSAND POUNDS.
OF PLASTIC JUST IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ALONE.
OUR INDUSTRY IS ALREADY TAKING
RECOGNIZED INNOVATIVE STEPS TO
CREATE A MORE SUSTAINABLE FUTURE
SO WHAT WE'RE ASKING.
IS THAT THE COMMITTEE TO
CONSIDER AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD
HELP SB ELEVEN SIXTY TO MELD
WITH THESE EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL INITIATIVES AND SO
WE WERE WE TALK TO THE THE
AUTHOR ABOUT THIS -- WE WE WOULD
LIKE TO MAKE SO SURE THAT
CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF THE BILL BE
LIMITED THE SHOWER BATH
ACCESSORIES.
WHICH THE INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY
BEGUN IN EARNEST OVER THE PAST
DECADE WITH SEVERAL HOTEL BRANDS
ALREADY MOVING AWAY FROM SINGLE
USE SHAMPOO CONDITIONER LIKE
WHICH SHALL.
WE BELIEVE THIS FOCUSED APPROACH --
MEETS THE INTENT OF THE AUTHOR
AND WILL PREVENT LATER DISPUTES.
SECONDLY WE REQUEST A RIGHT TO
CURE PROVISIONS SIMILAR TO WHAT
IS REQUIRED OF ON HUMAN
TRAFFICKING SIGNAGE THAT HOTELS
AND OTHER BUSINESSES ARE SUBJECT.
TO LASTLY REQUEST AN
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FOR ALL
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS WITH
FIFTY ROOMS ARE MORE.
THAN A YEAR LATER FOR THOSE.
WITH FIFTY ROOMS ARE LAST.
ON THAT THIS OUR PRIDE THIS WILL
PROVIDE HOTELS WITH ENOUGH TIME
TO EXHAUST OUR CURRENT SUPPLY OF
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER LIQUID SOAP
SO AS NOT TO ENCOURAGE
UNNECESSARY WASTE.
ADDITIONALLY THE REALITY IS A
MANDATE LIKE THIS ON A STATE
WITH MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
HOTEL LODGING ROOMS MAY CAUSE
BACKLOGS AND SHORTAGES.
ON THE REPLACEMENT TECHNOLOGY
AGAIN OUR APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR FOR REACHING OUT TO US IN
HIS WILLINGNESS TO MAKE THIS WAS
LOWER.
YOU ARE THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
BOTTOM ANYONE FROM CALIFORNIANS
AGAINST WASTE IN SUPPORT.
THERESA RIGOROUS ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
HEY GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS SORRY
LITTLE OUT THERE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS KAREN ROSS
AND WITH THE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS COUNCIL WHERE THE
INDUSTRY TRADE ASSOCIATION.
REPRESENTING THE FRAGRANCE
PERSONAL CARE -- AND BECAUSE
MEDICS ASSOCIATION WITH OVER
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
IN STATE AND WE ARE HERE TO
OPPOSE THE BILL AS CURRENTLY
DRAFTED HAVEN'T HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SEE THE RECENT
AMENDMENTS BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
SEEING THEM -- WE THINK THIS
BILL IS WELL INTENDED WE SHARE
THE SAME GOAL AS FAR AS REDUCING
PLASTIC PACKAGING.
OUR MEMBER COMPANIES HAVE SET
AGGRESSIVE COMMITMENTS ON THAT
FRONT -- WE DO THINK THERE ARE
SOME ISSUES -- WITH THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL -- WITH THE SIZE OF THE
TWELVE OUNCES OR LESS WE THINK
THAT COULD ON IN A FOR ONLY BàN
A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF PRODUCT.
AND WE ALSO HAVE -- YOU KNOW
THERE ARE A LOT OF MY MEDIUM AND
SMALL COMPANIES THAT ARE IN
STATE THAT COULD BE READ READ --
PACKAGING THE PRODUCT OF
DISTRIBUTING THE PRODUCT UNDER
BRAND NAMES TO HOTELS AND WE DO
THINK THAT WE HAVE TO BRING THEM
INTO THE CONVERSATION TO MAKE
SURE THAT COMPANIES OF ALL SIZES.
CAN COMPLY WITH US BUT WE LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- BUT REGRETFULLY OPPOSE
AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OPPOSE.
GOOD AFTERNOON ADAM REQUIEM
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE HAVE A OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR -- TO GO TO NEUTRAL THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NUMBER GET BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR -- SO
MISTER KALRA -- MANY OF THESE
BOTTLES ARE RECYCLABLE.
YES THEY ARE [inaudible]
SURE THERE.
MISTER KALRA MANY OF THESE
BOTTLES ARE RECYCLABLE IF
THEY'VE IF THEY'VE GOT THE
SYMBOL UNDER NEED THAT SHOWS
THAT THERE IS LIKE WHAT THEY CAN
BE REACHED THAT CAN BE PUT IN
THE RECYCLE.
BIN IN THE ROOM ON THAT DOT THE
HOTELS CAN THEN YOU KNOW SEND
THEM OUT FOR READ FOR RECYCLING
SO I'M JUST CURIOUS.
RATHER THAN A BAN WHY NOT MORE
OF A FOCUS ON AN EDUCATION.
CAMPAIGN.
WELL.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION A
COUPLE OF THE THINGS THAT POINT.
ONE IS THAT WE KNOW ESPECIALLY
THE SMALLER A PIECE OF PLASTIC
GETS THE LESS LIKELY THAT IT
DOES ACTUALLY GET RECYCLED AND
BACKED.
UP AND AND A SUMMER STYLE HE'S
OVER THERE THAT.
THIS BILL IDEA CAME BECAUSE IT
WAS A SELECT COMMITTEE HEARING
THAT A SIMILAR STONE WAS --
HOLDER THE HELD IN SANTA CRUZ
NEVER DIFFERENT -- IDEAS AS TO
WHAT KINDS OF THINGS COULD
REDUCE SINGLE USE PLASTIC USAGE
THAT ENDS UP IN THE WASTE STREAM
AND IN THE OCEANS.
AND THIS WAS IDENTIFIED AS ONE
MOST MORSE BUT MOST POSSIBLY
BECAUSE NOT JUST THE SIZE BUT
THE VOLUME OF THE AMOUNT OF THEM.
IS SO LARGE THE DAD A NOTE IN AN
INORDINATE INORDINATE A NUMBER
OF THEM ARE ENDING UP IN THE WAY
STE NOT IN THE WAIST PROPER
WASTE AND RECYCLING STREAM.
BUT ENDING UP IN OUR RIVER WAYS
AND OUR WATERWAYS AND INTO THE
OCEAN.
SECONDLY OF THE WE HAVE THIS
LARGER CONVERSATION -- SUMMER
GONZALEZ AND OTHERS HAVE BILLS
REGARDING SINGLE USE PLASTICS IF
WE'RE REALLY GOING TO TACKLE THE
ISSUES IN THESE PLASTICS WE HAVE
TO FIND.
AREAS WHERE WE CAN REDUCE THEIR
USE AND I BELIEVE THAT HOTELS UP
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE FACT THE
INDUSTRY ON ITS OWN WITHOUT ANY
LEGISLATION.
IS MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION IS
ABSOLUTELY LOW HANGING FRUIT TO
REDUCE SINGLE USE PLASTICS IN
OUR IN -- IN OUR STATE -- AGAIN
YOU KNOW MERRY OUT BY ITSELF BY
THE END OF THIS YEAR AND IN
NORTH AMERICA WILL HAVE WELL
OVER FIFTEEN HUNDRED PROPERTIES --
BUT ENDED THIS YEAR -- WELL
BEFORE ANYTHING OF THIS NATURE
WOULD BE PUT INTO PLACE OF OF OF
OF REMOVING SO THEY USE PLASTICS
AND THEIR TOILETRIES.
AND SO IT'S NOT JUST SIMPLY A
MATTER OF WHETHER SOMETHING CAN
BE RECYCLED OR NOT.
IT'S A MATTER OF HOW DO WE
ULTIMATELY BECAUSE THERE'S A
THERE'S A PRODUCTION COSTS AS
WELL TO CREATING PLASTIC THAT AB
HAD TO CONTRIBUTE TO GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND CRUDE JOBS TO
WASTE.
AND SO IF WE CAN REDUCE THE
OVERALL AMOUNT OF PLASTIC IS
PARTICULARLY SINGLE USE.
I THINK THAT IT IT HITS A LOT OF
DIFFERENT GOALS WE HAVE OKAY BUT
YOU SAID SOMETHING THAT KIND OF
STAND ABOUT WHICH IS THAT THE
INDUSTRY IS REALLY ALREADY
TAKING THIS UPON THEMSELVES. TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH THIS SO WHY
THEN DO WE NEED GOVERNMENT
INTERVENTION.
IF IT'S WORKING.
WELL IT'S A COUPLE REASONS ONE
IS GAS INDUSTRY IS MOVING IN
THAT DIRECTION IN TERMS OF SOME
OF THE BRANDS.
I THINK THAT WITH LEGISLATION
NOT ONLY CAN WE PAYS IT OUT ALL
TOGETHER WHICH I THINK IS A A
NOBLE COLIN OF OF APPROPRIATE
GOAL IN TERMS OF PUBLIC POLICY.
BUT BY HAVING LEGISLATION WE CAN
ALSO.
HELP IN WORKING WITH THE LODGING
ASSOCIATE HOW AND ACTIVELY WITH
THOSE INDEPENDENT HOTELS THAT
AREN'T PART OF THE MARRIOTT
BRAND WHAT HAVE YOU MOVE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION MANY OF THEM
WANT TO I'VE MET WITH I MET WITH
SO MANY OF THEM.
THEY WANT TO THEY DON'T HAVE THE
SUPPORT SYSTEM TO DO IT WITH THE
BILL NOT ONLY CAN WE IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT MANDATING IT'S ALSO
ABOUT.
CREATING A TIE MINOR SUPPORT
SYSTEM TO HELP ALL OF THE HOTEL
YEARS A MOTEL YEARS -- PAYS US
IN THESE PLASTIC BECAUSE THAT
GOAL IN ITSELF IS A GOOD GOAL SO
WHAT IN THE WHICH PART IN THE
BILL OFFER SUPPORT TO THEIR
SMALLER HOTEL.
WELL FOR ONE OF THE AREAS THAT.
WERE ONE OF THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WILL BE.
OF THAT WE DISCUSSED AND I I
KNOW WELL A REPRESENTATIVE HERE
FROM THE HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION A REFERENCE -- TO
AND IT'S SOMETHING I'VE
DISCUSSED.
EVEN WITH OF THE ORGANIZATION IS
THAT ADDITIONAL TIME LINE OF ONE
YEAR FOR SMALLER HOTELS.
I THINK THAT ADDITIONAL YEAR
ALLOWS THE ASSOCIATION -- AND
ALLOWS.
US AS A STATE TO EDUCATE AND GET
THE WORD OUT THERE ABOUT IT AND
TO HELP OFFER ASSISTANCE AND
CONNECT WITH SAYS ABSOLUTELY --
SOMETHING THAT -- I'M I'M
ABSOLUTELY INTERESTED IN DOING
IS ENSURING THAT -- AND THAT'S
PART OF THESE I MET WITH THE
BILL DISSOCIATION WAS A HOA --
BEFORE I EVEN REDUCE THE BILL
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO BE A
HEAVY HANDED ABLE COMING AT YOU --
COMING AT YOUR INDUSTRY IT WAS
QUITE THE OPPOSITE IT WAS A
LET'S MEET NOW BEFORE I EVEN
KNEW DISABILITY AND THAT'S WHY
THEY'RE AMENDMENTS ARE BEING
OFFERED THE CONVERSATIONS GOING
TO CONTINUE. TO MAKE IT AS EASY
AS POSSIBLE BUT ABSOLUTELY
THERE'S AN INTEREST TO HELP WITH
THE INDEPENDENT SMALLER HOTELS
HELP FACILITATE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WITH COMMENTS.
SOME MEMBER MATHIS JUST.
YOU KNOW AND I KNOW THERE'S
OTHER BILLS FLOATING AROUND THE
LEGISLATURE THAT MORE TOWARDS --
YOU KNOW KINDA INFORMING THE
PUBLIC ON RECYCLING -- HAVING
DIFFERENT GROUPS ACTUALLY SET UP
RECYCLING BINS I MEAN I'VE NEVER
WALKED INTO A HOTEL ROOM.
IT'S IN A BLUE.
RECYCLING BAND -- MALIK I'VE
SEEN A FEW BUT IT'S YOU KNOW YOU
YOU GOT A LITTLE TRASH CANS
THERE ARE THEY OFFERING
RECYCLING BINS I MEAN WHAT WOULD
IT BE A MUCH EASIER PUSH -- FOR
HOTELS JUST.
TO HAVE THEM OFFER RECYCLING
BINS THAT WE WE KNOW WE'RE
GETTING THIS.
AND IT GOES INTO TO THE PLASTIC --
RECYCLING IN A GOES AND MISTER
TEAMS BILL I'M A GOES IN AND ALL
THESE OTHER THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO -- NO IT WE A LOT
OF US GREW UP WITH THIS -- YOU
KNOW RECYCLE REDUCE REUSE.
BIND SCHOOLS AND NOW IT JUST
SEEMS LIKE WE JUST WANT TO GET
RID OF ANYTHING THAT COULD BE A
RECYCLED PRODUCT ON JUST BECAUSE
IT'S BAD -- OR OR SOMEBODY DEEMS
THAT BAD -- YOU KNOW I THOUGHT
THE THE WHOLE PURPOSE -- THE
EARLIEST -- FOR FOR THE
MILLENNIALS ON MY GENERATION
THAT WE GOT -- INSTITUTIONALIZED
IN IN -- SCHOOL WAS TO RECYCLE
ON NOT TO GET RID OF SO WHY
AREN'T WE FOCUSING ON RECYCLING
THESE PRODUCTS AND SAY HAVE THE
HOTELS -- HAVE RECYCLE BINS
THERE IN THE ROOMS TO CAPTURE
THAT OR THE YOU KNOW ON SPENT
SHAMPOOS CAN GO TO HOMELESS
SHELTERS WERE HAVING AN ISSUE
GETTING PRODUCTS THERE I MEAN
THERE'S A HUNDRED ONE THINGS WE
CAN DO.
BUT I I FEEL LIKE WE'RE JUST
TRYING TO SAY OKAY THIS IS BAD.
LET'S GET RID OF IT YOU KNOW IN
THE I THINK THERE'S TOO MUCH OF
THAT FLOW AROUND UP HERE I I
APPRECIATE YOUR PERSPECTIVE LOOK
YOU KNOW I GREW UP JUST LIKE YOU
DID LEARNING ABOUT RECYCLING WE
TAUGHT OUR PARENTS HOW TO DO IT
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T GROW UP.
WITH THAT AND THE PART OF THE
REASON IS THAT POSSIBLE
LIBERATED DURING OUR UPBRINGING
IN A WAY THAT WE HAD NEVER SEEN
BEFORE NOW WE KNOW WHAT THOSE
IMPACTS ARE.
THIS IS AN EVOLUTION IT'S AN
EVOLUTION RECOGNIZING IS NOT
JUST ABOUT ABOUT RECYCLING
PLASTICS BUT WE HAVE TO START
ARE WE AT THE START TO PHASE AS
MUCH THE MOTHER THAT'S PACKED
THAT'S PRACTICAL.
THAT MAKES SENSE -- SECONDLY AND
THIS IS SOMETHING I LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT WHEN I WAS IN THIS
HOUSE A CITY COUNCIL IN A MANY
OF YOUR FROM LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
AND WHEN I VISIT RECYCLING
PLANTS IF THERE ARE CONTAMINANTS --
THAT THEIR OF THEIR CONTAMINANTS
WHICH A LOT OF THESE PRODUCTS
WOULD HAVE AS FAR AS RECYCLING
IS CONSIDERED.
THE END OF THE PRODUCT IS NOT
RECYCLE THEY ACTUALLY JUST PUT
INTO LANDFILL AND SO THAT'S
ANOTHER ISSUE NOT AND I'LL GIVE
YOU AN EXAMPLE ABOUT IS
EDUCATION ENOUGH.
PLASTIC.
BAGS AT THE GROCERY STORES I
KNOW I'M SURE WE HAVE A
DIFFERENT OPINION ON ON WHETHER
THAT WAS A GOOD PUBLIC POLICY
BUT I'LL TELL YOU THAT PRO. TWO
TO THREE DECADES THERE WAS A
EDUCATION PROGRAM THAT YOU WERE
ABLE TO TAKE YOUR PLASTIC BAGS
BACK THE GROCERY STORE THEY
WOULD TAKE IT BACK.
THE REALITY IS THAT PEOPLE JUST
DIDN'T DO IT AND SO THE THOUGH
OF THE REAL THE REAL.
OF THE THE REAL MOVE THAT HAD TO
BE MADE WAS JUST ABANDONED
BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT GETTING IN
THE RECYCLING STREAM THERE ARE
GETTING IN THE WAY STREAM.
NOW AGAIN I KNOW YOU MAY NOT
AGREE WITH THAT.
THAT CONCLUSION BUT THAT'S AN
EXAMPLE OF HOW IT'S NOT JUST
ENOUGH TO HAVE A RECYCLING BIN
OR HAVE A PROGRAM THAT ACCEPTS
BACK TO THE RECYCLING SO THAT IS.
SO YEAH SO.
WANT ONE MORE QUESTION MANAGERS
IF.
WE'RE WE'RE SO FOCUSED ON SINGLE
USE SMALL PLASTICS AND WHAT
ABOUT LIKE THE INK PEN THAT
YOU'RE HOLDING IN YOUR HAND.
NO I MEAN IS THAT IS THAT NEXT
ON THE CHOPPING THIS WAS CARE AT
ALL SINGLE USING PENS AND WELL%
OF AT THE LOOK THE REALITY IS
THIS AND I I UNDERSTAND I MEAN I
AM I MEAN A LITTLE FACETIOUS.
I GET IT I I'VE IT BUT I MEAN WE
WE KEEP GOING AFTER.
YOU KNOW ONE SMALL PLASTIC AFTER
ANOTHER AFTER ANOTHER AFTER
ANOTHER. ONE IS IN STOCK WELL
ABOVE WHAT WE DO THIS AND GET
RID OF HALF A BILLION A YEAR.
THAT'S NOT HOW MUCH OF THAT IS
ACTUALLY COMING FROM CALIFORNIA
VERSUS OTHER PLAYER THAT'S
CALIFORNIA ALONE THAT THAT'S CAL.
IT'S A VERY ROUGH LIKE NAPKIN
CALCULATION BUT BASED UPON THE
DATA OF THE HOW MANY ROOMS AND
HOW MANY PLASTIC BOTTLES OF THE
ROOMS.
AND SO -- BUT IT DOES MATTER IT
DOES ADD UP I MEAN WE DON'T.
WE'RE IN THE WERE IN THE PROBLEM
THAT WERE IT WE WERE HAVING A
PROBLEM IN THE CRISIS RIGHT NOW
WITH THE PLASTICS.
BECAUSE IT'S CONSERVATIVE AND SO
YES YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT WE
DO ONE THING OVER JUST TO THAT
ONE THING WHICH IS IN THE OTHER
THING AHLERS SANTA SOUNDS LIKE A
LOT OF OF ABILITY TO RECYCLE AND
AND REVIEWS.
ARE WE WE ARE YOUR YOUR I HATE
YOU YEAH WELL RIGHT NOW WE'RE
HAVING A BILL WE'RE HAVING A
PROBLEM WITH RECYCLING PLASTIC
BECAUSE CHINA'S DECIDED TO STOP
TAKING OUR RECYCLABLES.
AND SO PART OF IT IS YES HAVING
OUR OWN HOME GROWN ABILITY TO
RECYCLE AND PART OF IT IS
REDUCING THE CONSUMPTION OF
SIMPLY IS PLASTICS.
AND SO WE HAVE TO DO IT ALL IS
THAT THERE'S NOT ONE ANSWER TO
IT.
A SIGNAL MORE COMMON SIDE ARE
VERY SUPPORTIVE OF YOUR BILL --
THE IDEA THAT BECAUSE SOMETHING
IS RECYCLABLE THAT IT'S OFF THE
HOOK WHEN WE KNOW BECAUSE WE SIT
ON THIS COMMITTEE AND WE HEAR IT
OVER AND OVER AGAIN THAT THESE
PRODUCTS ARE NOT BEING RECYCLED.
THEY'RE EITHER BEING LAND FILLED
OR IF THEY GO OVERSEAS SOMETIMES
ARE BEING BURNED.
AND A LOT OF TIMES THEY END UP
IN THE OCEAN AND WHEN DOES IT
END ENDS WHEN WE STOP PULLING
WELLS OUT OF THE OCEAN.
WHO ARE DEAD BECAUSE OUR
STOMACHS ARE FILLED WITH PLASTIC
THAT THEY CAN'T DIGEST SO?
REDUCING THE SOURCE OF ALL OF
THIS POLLUTION IS GOING TO BE A
HUGE PART OF THE EQUATION AND
THIS SEEMS TO ME LIKE LOW
HANGING FRUIT.
I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD I DO HAVE ONE QUESTION
IS YOU HAVE TO ANSWER BUT I
DON'T KNOW.
HOW TO THE PACE CONTAINERS
FIGURE INTO THIS GIVEN THAT
THERE MIGHT BE SOME SANITARY
ISSUES SO JUST THINK ABOUT ALL
THE RANGE OF PRODUCTS AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD?
BUT I'M VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT
YOUR BILL TODAY.
AND WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
THE SUPPORT -- AND I'LL JUST DO
A QUICK ON WE'RE NOT CUTTING TO
PLEASE BECAUSE NOT IT'S NOT AS
STANDARD YOU WALK IN EVERY HOTEL
ROOM YOU DON'T SEC TWO BASE
THERE.
AND IT IS A DIFFERENT KIND OF
POSITIVE A KIND OF ISSUE WITH
CONTAMINANTS RAPID.
PROCESS I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT INTEND TO COVER TO PAY
JUST JUST TO MAKE IT CLEAR TO
EVERYONE BUT I DO APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION BECAUSE THOSE ARE THE
KINDS OF QUESTIONS THAT COME UP
THAT WE TALK ABOUT WITH THE
INDUSTRY.
ARE THOSE DETAILS BECAUSE THE
THE DEVIL'S IN THE DETAILS WHEN
IT COMES TO A BILL LIKE THIS IS
GOOD IMPACT SO MANY.
HOTEL ROOMS AND HOTELS THAT WANT
TO DO THE RIGHT THING THE
INDUSTRY HAS PROVEN THAT YOU'VE
SEEN IT WITH THE BUT THE TOWEL
ON THE BED SHE CLEANING WHEN
THEY HAVE SIGNS ALL BUT IT SEEMS
THE MONEY IT'S ALSO WRITING TO
DO.
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE OF SOMETHING
THAT WILL SAVE INDUSTRY MONEY
AND IT'S ALSO THE RIGHT THING TO
DO AND SO I REALLY BELIEVE THAT
WE'RE GONNA BECAUSE OF THE
WILLINGNESS OF THE INDUSTRY TO
WORK WITH US.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO FIND UP OF
PUT COMPROMISED POSITIONS OF
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING REALLY WELL
TOGETHER ALREADY AND I'M VERY
GRATEFUL TO THE CHAIR VERY
GRATEFUL AS WELL A TO SUMMER
STONE -- FOR HAVING A SELECT
COMMITTEE THAT REALLY SPREAD
THIS IDEA HAS WITHOUT A
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR MY BOAT.
AND IF YOU REALLY WANT TO BORROW
THE SHAMPOO YOU CAN BRING YOUR
OWN BOTTLE.
OKAY WITH THAT WE HAVE A WE NEED
A MOTION A SECOND.
OKAY.
OUR CAN I MAKE.
A MOVE IT WE HAVE A SECOND.
OKAY ABOVE IT AND ALSO I THINK
THAT.
WITH ACT MAY HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ITEM EIGHTEEN A. B. ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU.
EGGMAN GARCIA LIMON.
MATHIS.
NO MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NUMBER THREE TREE STONE.
STONE. NINE TWO THREE TWO THREE
WILL BE THE ROLE OF AN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT WE HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE WITH A. B..
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT THIS BURKE
YOU MAY BE SEATED WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
THANK YOU ALTHOUGH NOT REFLECTED
IN THE ANALYSIS I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WOULD REQUIRE RE
CLEAN OR IS TO REPORT TO CAL
RECYCLE ON THE TOTAL NET AMOUNT
OF RECYCLED MATERIAL THEY
PRODUCE AND THE AMOUNT OF FOOD
GRADE MATERIAL THEY PRODUCE --
THE PROPOSED DEFINITION APOLLO
GREAT WILL BE REMOVED I WANNA
MAKE SURE EVERYONE HERE IS THAT
THE PROPOSED DEFINITION OF OUR
GREAT WILL ALSO BE REMOVED.
AB FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT
REQUIRES CALORIE CYCLE TO
STANDARDIZE AN EXISTING FORM
USED TO COLLECT DATA ON THE
AMOUNT OF VIRGIN PLASTIC IN POST
CONSUMER RECYCLED PLASTIC USED
BY MANUFACTURERS THE CURRENT
CARRIED CYCLE REPORT DOES NOT
SPECIFY.
WHAT TYPE OF METRIC THEY WANTED
MANUFACTURES USE WHEN REPORTING
AND AS A RESULT THE DATA
REPORTED?
CAME IN PERCENTAGES POUNDS
KILOGRAMS AND A NUMBER OF
BOTTLES USED AS A RESULT THE
INFORMATION DOES NOT ACCOMPLISH
THE GOAL OF EFFECTIVELY
IDENTIFYING THE AMOUNT OF VIRGIN
PLASTIC AND RECYCLE PLASTIC USED.
IN PLASTIC BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
FROM THE PREVIOUS YEAR AS
OPPOSED TO BE AMENDED THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE CLIMBERS TO
REPORT DATA I'M RECYCLE MATERIAL
INCLUDING.
GRADE MATERIAL THEY PRODUCE IN
THE PREVIOUS CALENDAR YEAR THE
GOAL IS TO SET UP AN ANNUAL
SNAPSHOT OF THE FOOD GRADE PELA
TIES MATERIAL THAT IS BEING
PRODUCED IN.
THE STATE TO SEE IF THEY CAN
SUPPLY THE NECESSARY FEEDSTOCK
FOR THE VARIOUS PROPOSED MINIMUM
CONTENT LEVELS FOR BEVERAGE
BOTTLES UNDER THE C. R. V.
PROGRAM.
AT NEW POLICIES PROMOTING
RECYCLE CONTENT ARE CONSIDERED
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND CAL RECYCLE TO
NOT ONLY KNOW HOW MUCH RECYCLED
MATERIAL IS IN THE STATE BUT
ALSO HAVE USEFUL STANDARDIZED
INFORMATION TO BETTER INFORM THE
DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS A
FEDERICA MCGREEVEY MIKEY WITH
THE AMERICAN BEVERAGE
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN ITEM.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS -- PATRICK MAGEE ON
BEHALF ABA AND JUST CONSIDERING
YOUR TIME IN THE LIFT THE THINGS
YOU HAVE.
DO YOU KNOW WHAT.
IT IS SUPPORT [inaudible]
YEAH.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
IS THERE ANYBODY WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
SIGNAL BRING IT TO THE COMMITTEE
DOES ANYBODY HAVE ANY COMMENTS
[inaudible]
OKAY.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU AND I I REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR WORKING WITH OUR
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENTS AND
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE BILL
TODAY THANK YOU VERY THOUGHT TO
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED AND SECONDED WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND CLEAVER ALL
CALL PLEASE THANKS I DON'T
TWENTY FIVE A. B. FOURTEEN
EIGHTY AYE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE THE MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
LARA AYE CHAU.
EGGMAN GARCIA LIMóN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI STONE.
STONE I FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- NEXT WE
HAVE MISTER O'DONNELL WITH.
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WEBER SECOND
FULL PLEASE PLEASE CONTINUE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE CHAIR AND THE STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK ON THE BILL.
I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT AT
ELEVEN NINETY FIVE WHICH CARS
CARP TO ALLOW OIL AND GAS
COMPANIES TO GENERATE AN
INNOVATIVE PRODUCTION METHOD
CREDIT.
UNDER THE LOW CARBON FUEL
STANDARD FOR USING RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS TO DISPLACE THEIR
EXISTING USE OF TRADITIONAL.
NATURAL GAS.
THE LOW CARBON FUEL STANDARD OR
ELSE CFS IS PRIMARILY DESIGNED
TO ENCOURAGE THE USE OF CLEAN.
LOW CARBON TRANSPORTATION FUELS
IN CALIFORNIA.
THIS PROGRAM IS ALSO INTENDED TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS DURING THE
ACTUAL PROCESS OF PRODUCING
TRANSPORTATION FUELS.
AS SUCH THE PROGRAM ALLOWS OIL
REFINING OPERATIONS TO GENERATE%
LC OF AS CREDITS WHEN SWITCHING
FROM FOR TRADITIONAL NATURAL GAS
TO RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE SEEKS TO
EXPAND THIS OPTION TO OIL AND
GAS PRODUCERS GIVEN THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF NATURAL GAS REQUIRED
BY ENHANCED OIL RECOVERY METHODS.
THIS MAKES THE PROCESS LESS
CARBON INTENSIVE WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE GOALS OF THE
LC OF US.
THIS BILL ALSO ASSIST IN
CREATING ADDITIONAL BENEFICIAL
USES FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS.
THE ABSENCE OF A HAVE A HEALTHY
RENEWABLE GAS MARKET HAS MADE IT
DIFFICULT TO FIND INVESTMENT. TO
CAPTURE THE LARGE AMOUNT OF
METHANE DERIVED FROM ORGANIC
WASTE AS REMINDER METHANE IS A
POTENT GLOBAL WARMING GAS THAT
IS THIRTY FOUR TIMES THIRTY FOUR
TIMES.
MORE POWERFUL THAN CARBON
DIOXIDE AT TRAPPING THE EARNERS
HEAT OVER A ONE HUNDRED YEAR
PERIOD.
WELL THIS BILL REPRESENTS A
MODEST USE OF RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS IT IS IMPERATIVE THAT THE
STATE FINDS ADDITIONAL END USERS
FOR WHAT FOR FOR WHATEVER IS
POSSIBLE.
AB ELEVEN NINETY FIVE ASSISTS IN
CREATING A MARKET FOR MATH THING
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE DISSIPATE
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE WHILE ALSO
REDUCING THE GHQ FOOT PRINT OF
ALL OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS
INTERSTATE.
IN HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
THE CALIFORNIA.
STATE PIPE TRADES COUNCIL.
MADAM CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
SCOTT WHICH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE PATRIOTS
COUNCIL ALSO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES.
IN THE STATUS OF SEASON
ELECTRICAL WORKERS -- WE'RE HERE
TO URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL -- IT TODAY YOU KNOW MY
MEMBERS -- BOTH WORK AT MANY OF
THESE.
OIL REFINERIES AND IN THE IN THE
OIL PATCH.
AS WELL AS IN THIS NEW EMERGING
INDUSTRY OF BIO GAS AND WE
BELIEVE THIS IS -- COMMONSENSE
MEASURE.
CURRENTLY -- INDUSTRIAL USERS --
YOU KNOW -- OIL AND GAS
PRODUCERS.
IF THEY PURCHASE SOLAR POWER.
THEY CAN GET OFFSETS FOR THE
PURCHASE OF THAT SOLAR POWER
REGARDLESS OF OF WHERE THAT
POWER IS GENERATED AND PUT ON TO
THE GRID.
BUT IN IN ORDER TO GET CREDIT
FOR THE BIO GAS.
IT HAVE TO BE PIPED DIRECTLY TO
THE FACILITY.
WE WE SIMPLY BELIEVE THE
MOLECULES AND ELECTRONS IN THIS
INSTANCE SHOULD BOTH.
BE TREATED EQUALLY.
WE THINK THAT THIS WAS A HUGE
BENEFIT TO THE ENVIRONMENT TO
THEIR BURGEONING BIO GAS
INDUSTRY AND TO THE FOLKS.
MY MEMBERS WHO WORK IN LABOR
EVERY DAY IN THE OIL PATCH SO
FOR ALL THOSE REASONS WE WOULD --
DRIVE OUT THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS THE PAY US
OVER THE CALIFORNIA BEEN
PATROLMEN'S ASSOCIATION.
SOME MODEST BILL IT JUST GIVES
US ANOTHER INCENTIVE TO BUILD TO
PRODUCE OIL AND GAS.
IN A WAY THAT REDUCES RGH TWO
FOOT PRINT -- AGAIN WE THINK
IT'S VERY MODEST THERE'S NOTHING
IN THE BILL.
THAT IS GOOD NO -- BECAUSE US TO
TRY TO PRODUCE MORE GASOLINE OR
CRUDE OIL FROM CALIFORNIA THAT'S
SIMPLY A DEMAND QUESTION THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THIS THIS
JUST SAYS AS LONG AS WE'RE
PRODUCING.
OIL IN CALIFORNIA WE CAN AVAIL
OURSELVES TO THIS INCENTIVE TO
DO SO IN A MORE ENVIRONMENTALLY
RESPONSIBLE MANNER.
I JUST WANT ONCE AGAIN REALLY
QUICKLY THE BENEFITS OF METHANE
ARE HUGE.
IF WE CAN USE MECHANIC METHANE
STREAM INSTEAD OF USING A FOSSIL
FUEL BASED NATURAL GAS TO TO
HEAT OUR WATER TO MAKE THIS TEAM
TO DO THE IN FINANCE OR RECOVERY.
I THINK THAT'S A BIG BENEFIT
RECENTLY -- WE'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS SUCH AS BY THE
COMMITTEE TO ENSURE THAT THAT
AVENUE WILL NATURAL GAS COME
FROM CALIFORNIA SOURCES.
THUS THE METHANE REDUCTION IS IN
CALIFORNIA FOR THOSE OF YOU WITH
A METHANE SOURCES BE A DAIRY
ORGANIC -- LANDFILL WASTE IN
YOUR DISTRICT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S GOOD FOR YOUR DISTRICTS
SO WE APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR FRIEDMAN
MEMBERS NEED TO COOK FOR THE
COALITION FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL
GAS WE REPRESENT OVER A HUNDRED
AND EIGHTY MEMBERS -- FROM EVERY
SECTOR OF THE R. G. INDUSTRY
INCLUDING ORGANIZED LABOR
UTILITIES AND PRODUCERS OF OVER
90% OF THE ARE IN G. PRODUCED IN
NORTH AMERICA.
WE SUPPORT ALL SUSTAINABLE AND
USES OF OUR ENERGY AND THAT
INCLUDES WHEN IT IS USED AS A
PROCESS YOU'LL TO LOWER THE
CARBON INTENSITY OF OTHER FUELS
OF IN PROGRAMS LIKE THE LOW
CARBON FUEL STANDARD.
AND WE THINK THIS IS A REALLY --
MODEST AND APPROPRIATE BILL AND
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND FOR AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE AS AMENDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS P. ANTHONY THOMAS RIP IN
THE CALIFORNIAN GAS PRODUCERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
NATALIE MAX ON BEHALF OF SEE OUR
IN OUR ENVIRONMENTAL
ENVIRONMENTAL SERVICES AND
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
HI LAUREN COLEMAN BE ALPHA
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA.
CIRCLE CALIFORNIA POSES AB ONE
ONE NINE FIVE THIS BILL WOULD
OPEN UP THE NATURAL GAS PIPELINE
INFRASTRUCTURE TO RENEWABLE
NATURAL GAS ND BY DOING SO
WOULD UNDERMINE CALIFORNIA'S
PROGRESS ON CLEAN ENERGY POLICY.
AND DELAY OUR SHIFT TO CLEAN
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOLUTIONS.
IN ADDITION TO THE INFORMATION
THAT WE PUT FORWARD IN OUR
OPPOSITION LETTER THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO UNDER CUT THE NON
COMBUSTION CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES
THAT SOME FIELDS ARE DEVELOPING.
SUCH AS USING SOLAR STEAM TO
EXTRACT AND NOT ONLY THAT BUT IT
WOULD END UP PRESERVING
COMBUSTION TECHNOLOGY AND
DISCOURAGE THE TRANSITION TO NON
COMBUSTION TACK.
IN AREAS THAT NEED THAT
TRANSITION. FOR EXAMPLE MANY
FIELDS IN CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY
IN THE CENTRAL VALLEY RELY ON
USING THERMAL ENHANCEMENT
RECOVERY HE'S AREAS COULD
GREATLY BENEFIT FROM NON
COMBUSTION TECHNOLOGY TO HELP
MINIMIZE THE ENVIRONMENTAL
IMPACTS THEIR SUFFERING FROM
SUCH AS AIR POLLUTION.
INSTEAD THIS BILL WOULD LOCK
THOSE AREAS AND RELYING ON DIRTY
COMBUSTION TECHNOLOGIES.
THE STATE NEEDS TO WEAN ITSELF
OFF OF ITS DEPENDENCE ON GAS AND
THIS BILL WOULD WORK IN
OPPOSITION TO THAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE I BRING TO THE
COMMITTEE.
MISTER MATHIS.
YOU KNOW I I ALWAYS FIND IT
INTERESTING SO TALK ABOUT
WINNING PEOPLE OF A GAS EVEN
THOUGH WE HAVE ALL THIS NATURAL
NATURAL GAS OCCURRING IN THE
ABILITY TO CAPTURE IT AND USE IT
AND GET IN THE PIPELINE -- YEAH
I'VE GOT A VERY DISADVANTAGED
DISTRICT IN WE WE HAVE A AREA
AND I I WON'T CALL THE THE TOWN
OUT BY NAME -- BUT THE RESIDENTS
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPTION. TO GET
FREE SOLAR.
AND SWITCH ALL OF THEIR
APPLIANCES OVER TO ELECTRIC.
THEY REFUSED THE FREE OFFER OF
SOLAR ELECTRIC APPLIANCES.
BECAUSE THEY PREFER THE ABILITY
TO USE GAS STOVES.
AND INSTEAD HAVE BEEN
ENCOURAGING THE LOCAL AREA -- TO
TEAM UP WITH OUR GAS COMPANIES
AND OUR RENEWABLE ENERGY PLANT
THAT'S ACTUALLY CAPTURING
METHANE FROM DERRY DIGEST
STATION -- TO USE THAT NATURAL
NATURAL GAS -- AS A MATTER.
ID AND I BELIEVE THIS WOULD
ACTUALLY LOWER THE COST -- QUITE
SIGNIFICANTLY.
OF THAT NATURAL NATURAL GAS AND
HELP AND MOVE FORWARD TO CREATE
A MARKET -- FOR THAT MAKE IT
MORE AFFORDABLE FOR THE MOST
DISADVANTAGED IN OUR STATE.
I REALLY APPRECIATE WHAT YOU'RE
DOING THIS ROAD ON ALL -- TO TO
DO THIS AND REALLY HELP DRIVE
DOWN THOSE COST AND MAKE NATURAL
NATURAL GAS MORE AFFORDABLE ON
TO THE CALIFORNIA NEEDED THE
MOST THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MS EGGMAN.
THE GAME IS PARTY PRESENTATION
BUT MY MY ESTIMATE WHAT A LOT OF
TEARS IN MY DISTRICT IT IT IS.
ONLY CALIFORNIA NATURAL GAS ONLY
TO BE RECEIVE THE CREDITS IN
CALIFORNIA ALL CALIFORNIA.
ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE. FOR THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS THAT THE
THE METHANE HAS TO COME THAT
DISPLACEMENT HAS TO BE FROM
CALIFORNIA SO AS TO BE ACCEPTED
YEAH EXCEPT YEAH THE COUPLE.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE -- I DO THINK WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING
WITH US AND ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS I AM GOING TO SUPPORT
THE BILL TODAY I WILL SAY THAT I
DO -- WANT TO JUST PUT OUT THERE
THAT THE LC ABOUT L. L. C. F. F.
IS VERY.
IS A VERY COMPLICATED SET OF
REGULATIONS AND I DO THINK THAT.
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO MAKE SURE
THAT THAT THE AIR RESOURCE BOARD --
CAN REALLY MAKE SURE THAT THIS
BILL IS WORKABLE AND SUPPORTS
OUR COMMON OBJECTIVE OF NEW
NOTHING CAPTURE PROJECTS MY ONE
CONCERN IS THAT.
THIS ISN'T WORK SOMEHOW SO THAT
YOU CAN PURCHASE EXISTING
PROJECTS SO THAT YOU MOVE THOSE
CREDITS OVER IT HAS TO IT FOR
THIS TO WORK AS AS ADVERTISED.
THESE HAVE TO BE NEW PROJECTS SO
THAT WE'RE GETTING -- NEW
REDUCTIONS SO I JUST WANTED TO
PUT THAT OUT THERE FOR THE
RECORD THAT THAT'S OUR INTENTION
AS WE MOVE FORWARD AND I HOPE
THAT THERE RESOURCE BOARD IS.
UP TO THE TASK OF BEING ABLE TO
IMPLEMENT THAT.
WITH THAT WE DO HAVE A MOTION I
BELIEVE.
WE HAVE A SECOND.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND CAN WE
HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE -- AND I
DO HAVE A QUESTION SO.
MY MY ONE QUESTION IS WILL THE
BILL SUPPORT NEW METHANE CAPTURE
PROJECTS.
IS THAT YOUR YOUR COMMITMENT
RATHER THAN TRYING TO PERCH ON
TEXTING PRICE SO I MEAN I I
CAN'T SPEAK TO EVERY PARTICULAR
TRANSACTION BUT I CAN I CAN'T
SAY A COUPLE THINGS.
ONE WE DON'T HAVE AS MUCH
METHANE CAPTURE IN THE STATE IS
AS WE THINK WE DO RIGHT AND SO
AS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS ELECTRIC
SO CAL GAS IS COMMITMENT TO
START.
OFTEN INVOLUNTARY WINNABLE
NATURAL GAS IN THEIR PIPELINE
AND FOR ALL THE OTHER VARIOUS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE --
ACROSS THE STATE WE THERE'S NOT
ENOUGH RIGHT NOW TO FILL THE
DEMAND THAT'S RIGHT THERE IN
FACT WE HAVE ASKED.
FOR RENEWABLE NATURAL GAS
CONTRACTS AND WE HAVEN'T REALLY
GOTTEN A RETURN PHONE CALL IT IS
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS
GONNA TAKE THERE'S GONNA BE
COMPETITION FOR NEW PROJECTS.
RIGHT NOW WE ACTUALLY COULDN'T
DO WHAT'S IN THE BILL BECAUSE
IT'S JUST NOT THE SUPPLY SO IT
IS GOING TO HAVE TO BE.
NEW PRODUCTS NEW PROJECTS BUILT
OUT IN ORDER TO GET THE GET THE
SUPPLY IN THE PIPELINE AND DRIVE
THE PRICE DOWN SO WE CAN DO
THAT'S WEIRD MY UNDERSTAND IS
WE'RE NOT THERE YET.
SO MY ASSUMPTION IS BANNED FROM
THE BEGINNING ONCE THAT
AMENDMENT WAS PROFFERED THAT
WOULD BE TALKING ABOUT NEW
PROJECTS OKAY THANK YOU WITHOUT
MISTER DONNA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
THAT'S WHEN I VOTE.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND WAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I AM NINETEEN AB ELEVEN NINETY
FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
O'DONNELL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN.
MATHIS -- MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ [inaudible]
WROTE SURGERY [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE NO FOUR ONE THANK YOU FOR
ONE LEAVE THE ROLL OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU NEXT WE
HAVE MISTER GLORIA WITH.
FOR TWENTY THREE A GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE --
EIGHTY FOUR TWENTY THREE WE'RE
STRUCTURE SAID THE EAGLES AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT AND
DIRECT THEM TO INCREASE THEIR
PROGRAM TRANSPARENCY.
THE BOARD INCLUDES
REPRESENTATION FROM ADDITIONAL
SAN DIEGO AREA CITIES AND OTHER
KEY STAKEHOLDERS IF PASSED A
BEFORE TWENTY THREE WILL TAKE
EFFECT ON MARCH FIRST.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE QUICKLY --
MADAM CHAIR I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A
LONG DAY OF THE BILL.
THIS BILL CORRECT ANOMALY -- IS
CREATED BY THIS LEGISLATURE MANY
MANY YEARS AGO -- BASICALLY
INCREASING TRANSPARENCY AND
REPRESENTATION THIS BOARD I
BELIEVE WILL HELP US TO REACH A
CLIMATE GOALS I AM REDUCE AIR
POLLUTION OUR COMMUNITY I HAVE
TWO WITNESSES I'D LIKE TO HAVE.
THE OPPORTUNITY TESTIFIED TRAVEL
FROM SAN DIEGO DâN TALK VOID
WITH THE ENVIRONMENT HEALTH
COALITION AND THERE ARE HUNDREDS
TO TELL US OF THESE FROM THE
CITY OF NATIONAL CITY.
WE CAN MAKE IT REALLY WORTHWHILE
AND ASK A LOT OF REALLY
DIFFICULT QUESTIONS IF YOU
PREFER AS WELL.
YOU CAN ASK THEM TO BE PUT ON
THE WITNESS OKAY.
GOOD AFTERNOON -- DIANE TECH FOR
IN DIRECTOR OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH COALITION WE'RE A FORTY
YEAR OLD ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION THAT WORKS IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR --
TO CONFRONT THE UNJUST
CONSEQUENCES OF POOR AIR QUALITY
AND OUR COMMUNITIES HAVE A VERY
LONG HISTORY OF WORKING FOR AIR
QUALITY IN OUR COMMUNITIES AND
WE HAVE BEEN MET WITH AN
UNRESPONSIVE BOARD.
THE HEALTH IMPACTS IN THE
CONTINUED HIGH RATES OF CANCER
AND ASTHMA HOSPITALIZATIONS
AMONG CHILDREN ARE UNACCEPTABLE
AND DEMONSTRATE THE NEED FOR
ACTION.
THE NEED FOR A DIVERSE
REPRESENTATION ON THIS BOARD IS
CLEAR.
THE SAN DIEGO AIR POLLUTION
CONTROL DISTRICT BOARD IS AN
ANOMALY AMONG THE LARGE
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE THE
PRODUCT OF A TWENTY FIVE YEAR
OLD PROVISIONS SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO EXAM SAN DIEGO
COUNTY FROM HAVING A DIVERSE AND
REPRESENTATIVE FORD.
AND WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT THE
NEED FOR DIRECTED ACTION THROUGH
CLEAR REQUIREMENTS IS EVIDENT
FOR EXAMPLE BASIC TRANSPARENCY
IN LACKEY IS LACKING IN AREAS
WHICH WOULD ENABLE THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE IN THEIR ACTIVITIES
FOR EXAMPLE.
VERY SIMPLY THE SAN DIEGO AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
MINUTES AND AGENDAS ARE NOT
POSTED ON THEIR WEBSITE --
THEY'RE BURIED IN THE COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS --
INFORMATION THERE IS LITTLE
INFORMATION AVAILABLE ABOUT --
BASIC PERMITTING WHEN WE FOLLOW
THEIR INSTRUCTIONS AND SIGNED UP
TO RECEIVE DATA -- WE RECEIVED
ZERO DATE AND NONE OF THE DATA
REQUEST MATCH THEIR CRITERIA--
WHEN WE DID THAT ON THE -- BAY
AREA'S WEBSITE WE GOT TWENTY
FIVE HUNDRED HITS SO THERE'S A
BIG DIFFERENCE.
AIR POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT
FOUR DOES NOT PROVIDE BUDGET
INFORMATION THERE'S NO DETAILED
INFORMATION AND NOT AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE PUBLIC TO
PARTICIPATE.
AND LASTLY MONITORING DATA FROM
EXISTING MONITORS TAKES YEARS TO
BE PROCESS JUST LAST WEEK WE
RECEIVE DATA FROM.
TWENTY SIXTEEN SO IN CLOSING
OTHER LARGE DISTRICTS HAVE
ROBUST PUBLIC INFORMATION
AUTHENTIC COMMUNITY
PARTICIPATION OPPORTUNITIES AN
AMBITIOUS EMISSION REDUCTION
PROGRAMS SAN DIEGO DESERVES AIR
POLLUTION CONTROL DISTRICT.
THAT ENCOURAGES AND SUPPORTS ITS
KATE CAPABLE AND COMMITTED STAFF
TO TAKE BOLD AND EFFECTIVE
ACTION TO PROTECT PUBLIC HEALTH
AND OUR MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH THIS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH -- MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS -- I KNOW THAT HOW
THAT'S WHAT THE LAW SO LEASE AND
I AM THE MAYOR OF THE CITY OF
NATIONAL CITY AND IT'S A CITY OF
SIXTY THOUSAND PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN **** ANY ACCOUNTING.
NATIONAL CITY SUFFERS FROM SOME
OF THE WORST AIR POLLUTION IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AND AS A RESULT OF THESE
CHALLENGES NATIONAL CITY HAS
RECENTLY BEEN SELECTED TO BE
PART OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
AIR PROTECTION PROGRAM.
UNDER AB SIX ONE SEVEN OR SIX
SEVENTEEN THE CITY OF NATIONAL
CITY HAS RECOGNIZED THE SERIOUS
PROBLEM OF AIR POLLUTION IN OUR
COMMUNITY FOR NEARLY TWO DECADES.
AND WE'RE DOING WHAT WE CAN AND
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL TO IMPROVE
OUR AIR QUALITY.
AND WHAT DOES THAT MEAN THAT
INCLUDE THE NEW WEST SIDE
COMMUNITY PLAN THAT RESOUNDS THE
COMMUNITY TO CORRECT
INCOMPATIBLE LAND USES.
NATIONAL CITY ADOPTED THE FIRST
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE ELEMENT IN
A GENERAL PLAN AND IN THE STATE
AND WHICH WAS THE INSPIRATION
FOR SB ONE THOUSAND ADOPTED IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN WE JUST
COMPLETED THE CONSTRUCTION OF
TWO HUNDRED ONE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS RIGHT NEXT TO OUR
A TRANSIT CENTER WITH THE HELP
OF NINE MILLION DOLLARS.
IN CAPITAL FUND TRADES.
CAPITA RATE BUTTONS.
WE NEED YOUR HELP TO ENABLE
NATIONAL CITY IN ALL OF THE
EIGHTEEN CITIES IN SAN DIEGO
COUNTY TO PARTICIPATE IN
IMPROVING AIR QUALITY WE WANT
OUR SEAT AT THE TABLE.
OUR PERSPECTIVES AN INSIGHT INTO
LOCAL AIR POLLUTION SOURCES OUR
UNIQUE INVALUABLE INSIGHTS THAT
ARE REPRESENT.
OF REPRESENTATION WILL PROVIDE
WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB.
FOR TWENTY THREE THANK YOU ARE
THERE ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
FAVOR OF THE BILL.
YEAH GOOD EVENING IN A BASKET ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA ROOM TO
SCIENCE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
ROCKY RUSSIAN COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR HAPPY TO SUPPORT.
I WILL BEAR AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION ALSO IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL THAT LIKE
TO SPEAK.
COUPLE OF TWEETERS.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JONATHAN CLAY
HERE ABOUT FOR THE COUNTY SAN
DIEGO TO VOICE CONCERNS WITH THE
MOST RECENT AMENDED VERSION OF
AB -- FOR TWENTY THREE IN ITS
PREVIOUS ITERATION WHEN THE BILL
JUST DEALT WITH GOVERNANCE THE
COUNTY AND CHOSEN TO REMAIN
SILENT ON THAT.
BUT WITH THE RECENT SET OF
AMENDMENTS -- WE FELT WE NEEDED
TO RAISE SOME CONCERNS.
THIS CONCERNS REVOLVE AROUND A
COUPLE DIFFERENT -- ISSUE AREAS
FIRST OFF WE BELIEVE THAT
IMPLEMENTATION FOR THOSE NEW SET
OF AMENDMENTS REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE DISTRICT -- THE MANDATES TO
DO WOULD BE SOMEWHERE IN THE
RANGE OF ABOUT THREE TO FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS.
WE ALSO THINK THERE'S A NUMBER
REQUIREMENTS THAT HAVE
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES --
WEATHER RELATED TO PENDING
INVESTIGATIONS AND HAVING TO
MAKE THOSE PUBLIC WITHOUT HAVING
THE FULL FACTS OF THE MATTER
BEING DETERMINED -- WE ALSO FEEL
THAT THERE'S WAYS INTERPRET THE
LANGUAGE OF REQUIRE TIPSTERS AND
OTHER TYPES OF COMMENTS HAVE TO
BE MADE PUBLIC.
THERE'S JUST SOME MECHANICAL
PROBLEMS WITH THE LANGUAGE WE
ALSO FEEL THAT -- THERE'S SOME
OTHER THINGS THAT THE BILL
REQUIRES THAT WOULD BE NICE TO
HAVE BETTER -- HUGE WORKLOAD FOR
THE DISTRICT IN VERY EXPENSIVE.
FINALLY WE ALSO THINK -- THERE'S
SOME -- MISSING CROSS REFERENCES
FOR FEAR FORTY AND THAT OF THEIR
OTHER ITEMS IN THE BILL RIGHT
NOW THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING
DONE OR IN PROCESS OF BEING DONE
AND DON'T NEED TO ACTUALLY BE
MANDATE AND STATUTES.
WITHOUT THOSE ARE CONCERNS.
THANK YOU.
CHAIR FREEDMAN RANDALL FRIEDMAN
REPRESENTING THE NAVY AND MARINE
CORPS ALSO VOICING CONCERNS.
WITH SIX MAJOR INSTALLATIONS IN
SAN DIEGO COUNTY DEPENDENT ON A
WIDE RANGE OF EQUIPMENT SUBJECT
TO REGULATION BY THE A. P. C. D..
THIS BILL IS.
A HIGH PRIORITY FOR US.
WE ARE WORKING IN GOOD FAITH
WITH THE AUTHOR ON REQUESTED
AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THE
MILITARY'S UNIQUE MISSION NEEDS
ARE FULLY CONSIDERED BY THIS NEW
BOARD.
WE ARE STILL ANALYZING POTENTIAL
IMPACTS FROM THE LATEST
AMENDMENT.
AND WILL CONTINUE OUR
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYBODY WHO WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
OKAY WITH THAT TO WILL GO TO THE
COMMITTEE IS ANY COMMITTEE
MEMBER OF ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
MR GLORIA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I JUST WANNA STATE FOR THE
RECORD MEN SHARE THAT WITH MY MY
OFFICE AND I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE OPPONENTS ON THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED --
TODAY IN IN IN DAYS UP PRIOR TO
THIS -- INITIAL SPECS WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU -- I AM HAPPY TO
SUPPORT YOUR BILL TODAY -- DID
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
YES WE DO HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
I DON'T FIVE AB FOR TWENTY THREE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GLORIA THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA [inaudible]
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN.
MATHIS NO MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ.
WROTE SURGERY.
STONE.
BUT SOON I FOR ONE FORTY ONE
BELIEVE THE REAL OPEN CRAFTED
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
AND NOW -- MISTER REAVIS WITH
NINE THIRTY SIX AND SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR.
IS PREPARED TO SAY I'M HAPPY
WITH WHO I AM HAPPY TO BE HERE
WITH YOU THIS AFTERNOON BUT IT'S
SEEMS TO BE EVENING TIME.
BUT IT'S A IT'S IT'S ALWAYS
GREAT TO BE HERE -- MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I ALSO WANT TO
THANK -- STAFF FOR NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE FOR A WORK
ON THE ANALYSIS AND I ALSO
GLADLY ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS BUT I AM HAPPY HERE
TO PRESENT A. B. -- NINE THREE
SIX A BILL RELATED TO OIL SPILL
RESPONSE A CONTINGENCY PLANNING.
AND SO LET ME BE ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR THAT THIS BILL.
THAT IS BILLS INTENT.
YOU KNOW IT'S A BILL ABOUT
SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS -- AND
SO CERTAINLY SEE THE THE
KALAMAZOO RIVER OIL SPILL IN
SOUTH CENTRAL MICHIGAN HAS BEEN
CALLED THE BIGGEST OIL SPILL
THAT YOU'VE NEVER HEARD ABOUT.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN ACCORDING TO
FEDERAL AGENCIES A RUPTURED
THIRTY INCH PIPELINE RESULTED IN
A SPILL OF MORE THAN ONE MILLION
GALLONS OF TAR SANDS OIL FROM
ALBERTA CANADA.
INTO THE KALAMAZOO.
THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL WAS
SEVERE.
NEARLY FORTY MILES OF RIVER AND
SHORELINES ARE POLLUTED MORE
THAN ONE HUNDRED FAMILIES
VOLUNTARILY LEFT THEIR HOMES.
MOSTLY -- MOSTLY BECAUSE OF THE
HIGH LEVELS OF OF OF BENZENE
THAT HAD EVAPORATED FROM THE OIL
INTO THE AIR.
IT WAS -- BENZENE THAT HAD BEEN
USED TO DILUTE THE HEAVY CRUDE.
AND THIS EVENT TO THIS OIL SPILL.
WITH SIGNIFICANT IT WAS
SIGNIFICANT BECAUSE IT WAS THE
FIRST SPILL OF TAR SANDS OIL.
A TYPE OF NON FLOATING OIL THAT
US AGENCIES WERE FORCED TO DEAL
WITH.
AND TO DATE THIS BILL REMAINS
ONE OF THE BIGGEST AND COSTLIEST
INLAND OIL SPILLS EVER
REGISTERED IN THE UNITED STATES.
THE BIGGEST AND COSTLIEST
BECAUSE THE TYPICAL OIL SPILL
CLEANUP METHODS DID NOT WORK
[inaudible]
THIS.
THIS PARTICULAR HEAVY OIL IT DID
NOT FLOAT ON WATER LIKE MOST
OILS.
TO EVERY ACTED VERY DIFFERENTLY.
ONCE THIS BILL OCCURRED OVER
TIME AS IT SAT IN THE WATER IT
BECAME SUSPENDED IN THE WATER
COLUMN EVENTUALLY THINKING.
THE CALVET THE THE RIVER CLEANUP
TOOK FIVE YEARS TO COMPLETE.
AND COST OVER ONE POINT -- TWO
BILLION DOLLARS NOT INCLUDING
THE MULTI BILLION DOLLAR SPENT
IN COMPANY FIGHT TO
INFRASTRUCTURE IMPROVEMENTS.
CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF ONLY THREE
MAJOR REGIONS IN THE UNITED
STATES THAT CAN REFINE THIS TYPE
OF HEAVY CRUDE.
TAR SANDS OIL HAS BEEN IN
PRODUCTION SINCE THE LATE
NINETEEN SIXTIES.
AND CURRENTLY ACCOUNTS FOR ABOUT
5% OF ALL US GAS.
HOWEVER PRODUCTION HAS BEEN
SCALING UP.
IN FACT ACCORDING TO THE US
ENERGY INFORMATION
ADMINISTRATION LAST YEAR CANADA
EXPORTED A RECORD AMOUNT OF TAR
SANDS OIL TO THE UNITED STATES.
EXPORTS ARE TRANSPORTED
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE USING
VARIOUS METHODS INCLUDING BY C.
ALONG OUR PACIFIC OCEAN
COASTLINE.
AND IN LIGHT OF THIS THIS
LEGISLATION.
AB NINE THIRTY SIX AGAIN IS
ABOUT SAFETY AND PREPAREDNESS.
IT'S SIX THIS IS A BILL THAT
SEEKS TO ENHANCE OIL
TRANSPORTATION SAFETY IN
CALIFORNIA BY PROVIDING
INFORMATION ON NON FLOATING OIL
MOVEMENTS WITHIN THE STATE TO
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS.
AND IT RESPONSIBLY SEEKS TO
UPDATE AND STRAIGHTENING
CALIFORNIA'S TOOLS FOR PLANNING
AND PREPARING FOR UNANTICIPATED
FUTURE OIL SPILLS.
OF NON FOR AN OIL.
THE CALIFORNIA COAST ALL TWELVE
HUNDRED MILES ALONG THE PACIFIC
OCEAN IS ONE OF OUR STATE
NATURAL TREASURES.
AND IT'S CLEARLY A MAJOR
ECONOMIC RESOURCE FOR OUR STATE.
NON FOR THE OIL PRESENTS A
UNIQUE AND SERVICE RISK TO OUR
COAST.
HERE CALIFORNIA IF YOU TAKE THE
TIME AND REVIEW CALIFORNIA'S OIL
SPILL -- THE CONTINGENCY PLAN IT
IS ABSOLUTELY CLEAR.
THAT OUR STATE OIL RESPONSE
CAPABILITIES ASSUME.
THE OIL FLOATS.
WHEN IT COMES TO NON FORTY OILS
HEAVIER OILS LIKE TAR SANDS THE
TRUTH IS WE KNOW VERY LITTLE
ABOUT IT?
WE KNOW VERY LITTLE ABOUT THIS
WILL IMPACT IN BEHAVIOR.
ESPECIALLY WHEN THIS BILL OCCURS.
WE CAN HAVE A POINT TO THE
KALAMAZOO RIVER INCIDENT THE
EFFECTS THAT NON UT -- HAD ON
THE RIVER AND ON THE OVERALL
ENVIRONMENT.
THAT INCIDENT MADE IT QUITE
CLEAR THAT ONCE ALL THE OIL
STARTED TO SINK IT MADE THINGS A
LOT MORE DIFFICULT AND VERY VERY
CHALLENGING TO CLEAN UP.
RESPOND AS WERE CLEARLY NOT AS
PREPARED TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION AND CLEAN IT UP AS
THEY SHOULD HAVE BEEN -- IT'S
AGAIN THIS BILL IS ABOUT SAFETY
AND PREPAREDNESS -- FOR OUR
STATE AND ALONG OUR COAST I HAVE
HERE SOME WITNESSES AND I WILL
ALLOW THEM TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES THANK MANAGER.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I AM -- JOSHUA AXELROD
FOR WITH THE INTERNATIONAL
FOSSIL FUELS PROGRAM AT THE
NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL HERE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
WE APPRECIATE MISTER REVERSES
LEADERSHIP IN INTRODUCING AB
NINE THIRTY SIX TO ADDRESS THE
THREATS THAT NON PUTTING AYEOPPOSED TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES.
AND NATURAL RESOURCES ACROSS THE
STATE.
THE BILL PROVIDES FOR PRUDENT
AND NECESSARY REQUIREMENTS TO
CONFRONT THESE THREATS
SPECIFICALLY -- I'LL HAVE IT
THREE THINGS -- PROPOSED NEW
INFRASTRUCTURE OUTSIDE OF THE
STATE IS POISED TO OPEN
CALIFORNIA'S REFINING MARKETS TO
AN INFLUX OF NON FLOATING AROUND.
CARRIED MOSTLY BY OCEAN TANKERS
TO THE SAN FRANCISCO SAN
FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES AREAS.
IN LIGHT OF THIS POTENTIALITY
AND TO COPE WITH NON VOTING ARE
BEING TRANSPORTED INTO OUR STATE
NOW AB NINE THIRTY SIX PROVIDE
STATE AGENCIES AND SPELL RESPOND
AS WITH INCREASED INFORMATION.
REGARDING CHARACTERISTICS OF
OILS ENTERING THE STATE AND
CLARITY AS TO THE TIMING AND
TYPES OF RESPONSE THAT MIGHT BE
NECESSARY IN THE EVENT OF A
LARGE WATER BORNE SPELL OF NON
FLOATING AROUND.
AB NINE THIRTY SIX EXPANDS THE
FINANCIAL RESPONSIBILITY OF
OPERATORS MOVING NON PUTTING OIL
INTO THE STATE TO ENSURE THAT
THE POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
COSTS OF CLEAN UP.
SHOULD THEY ARISE ARE NOT BORN
BY THE CITIZENS OF CALIFORNIA.
AB NINE THIRTY SIX OF THE
COMMONSENSE BELT THAT WILL
BENEFIT FIRST RESPONDERS
COMMUNITIES AND CALIFORNIA'S
PRECIOUS NATURAL RESOURCES.
BY IMPROVING OUR PREPAREDNESS
FOR A POTENTIALLY DEVASTATING
ACCIDENT INVOLVING NON PUTTING
OILS WE ARE QUITE BE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT THEIR MEDICARE.
MEMBERS TIME I'M THEN I CAN
BURKE STAFF ATTORNEY PERCENT
DISCO BAY KEEPER I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS IMPORTANT BILL --
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REAVIS FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP ON THIS IMPORTANT
ISSUE AS WELL AS MANY STAFF.
ALSO LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE
MINORITY SEE FOR TAKING TIME OUT
FROM HIS PATERNITY LEAVE AND HIS
HIS NEW BABY.
AS IT'S BEEN MADE CLEAR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER REAVIS CALIFORNIA
NEEDS THIS ADDITIONAL PROTECTION
IN THE EVENT OF A NON POLLUTING
SPELL. TO SUMMARIZE -- THERE'S
AN IMMINENT THREAT OF MORE OF
THIS TYPE WELCOME TO CALIFORNIA
THE RISK OF THIS BILL IS
CATASTROPHIC.
OUR SOLUTION IS THREE PARTS
FIRST.
FIRST OF ALL FIRST RESPONDERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHAT
THEY'RE DEALING WITH SECOND OF
ALL WE MUST PREPARE FOR THIS
THREAT USING THE BEST TECHNOLOGY
WE CAN GET.
AND THIRD THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULDN'T BE SADDLED
WITH THIS THE COST OF A SPELL.
THE NATIONAL ACADEMY OF SCIENCES
IS THE STUDY THIS ISSUE TWICE
FIRST IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
AND THEN WHAT MORE RECENTLY.
FOUND THIS THREAD TO BE SEVERE
AND FOUND THAT WE ARE UNDER
PREPARED.
SAN FRANCISCO BAY IS
SPECIFICALLY UNDER THREAT --
THERE'S GONNA BE MORE THERE
COULD BE MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED
IT'S NOT BARGES AND TANKERS
CARRYING ON PUTTING OIL ON THE
WEST COAST IF CURRENTLY PLANNED
PROJECTS ARE COMPLETED.
FIRST RESPONDERS MUST KNOW WHAT
IS COMING.
EACH TANKER CARRIES AN ADDED
RISK OF SPELL AND SPILLS IMPORT
MEAN ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES COULD BE HIT
PARTICULARLY HARD.
CALIFORNIA'S FORTY SIX BILLION
DOLLAR COASTAL ECONOMY HAS A LOT
TO LOSE FROM A SPELL.
EVER GONNA SHIP THIS THAT STUFF
THROUGH SEPARATIST KOBE AND ALL
OVER CALIFORNIA WE NEED TO
IMAGINE THE SCENARIO TO FIGURE
OUT A PLAN TO REDUCE
CATASTROPHIC DAMAGE.
ALSO RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WANTING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO CALIFORNIA LEAGUE
OF CONSERVATION VOTERS IN
SUPPORT.
I FURTHER THAN ON BEHALF OF
BOTTLING CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
VICTORIA AROUND YOU KNOW ME AS
IN OUR DC BUT I'M SPEAKING TODAY
FOR THREE FIFTY BAY AREA ACTION
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER SAVAGE SURFRIDER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
LAUREN COM SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
TREES A BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
HILL THE BAY IN THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYBODY WISHING TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
IF ONE OF THE WITNESSES COULD
PLEASE GIVE THEIR SEAT TO THE
OPPOSING WITNESS THANK YOU.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR P.
ANTHONY THOMAS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION -- WE'RE WE'RE IN
WE'RE IN OPPOSITION -- TO AB
NINE THIRTY SIX FIRST OF ALL LET
ME SAY THIS -- MADAM CHAIR THAT
I WANT TO THANK MISTER REAVIS WE
WORKED WE'VE WORKED ON TO OTHER
BUILT ASIDE FROM THIS WOMAN.
AND I HE IS A MAN OF HIS WORD
AND A PERSON WHO I AM GLAD TO
HAVE KNOWN HOW TO NOTE.
AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING
IN THE FUTURE.
BUT IN SO FAR AS A. B. -- NINE
THIRTY SIX IS CONCERNED.
THERE'S NO ARGUMENT ON HOW
DAMAGING ANY OIL SPILL IS.
BUT IF YOU LISTEN TO THE
TESTIMONY VERY CLEARLY WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IMPORT.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE ISSUE
WITH THE IMPORT SOLD WHEN
PRODUCTION IN A STATE GOALS DOWN
THE DEMAND IS STILL THERE SO WE
HAVE TO DEPEND ON IMPORTS.
ENTERS TALKING ABOUT THE DAMAGE
OF IMPORTS WE'VE SAID THAT ALL
THE TIME THAT MORE IN STATE
PRODUCTION IS ACTUALLY BETTER
CONSIDERING THE ROUTE THE
REGULATION THAT WE FUNCTION
UNDER.
THE TO PROPONENTS MENTION THE
ISSUES WITH IMPORTS OF OIL SO WE
SHOULD TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
MAYBE WE NEED TO IN FACT
INCREASE PRODUCTION STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
BECAUSE OF THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS THAT ARE THAT ARE
GOVERNED AND BECAUSE OF OUR ORAL
BEING THE BEST IN THE CLEANEST
IN THE NATION.
AS THE BILL READS MADAM CHAIR
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE THE OFFICE
OF SPILL RESPONSE ADMINISTRATOR
TO ESTABLISH A CRITERION FOR
SEPARATE RATING.
OUR RATING LEVEL FOR THE
ORGANIZATION TO ADDRESS NON
FLOATING.
OIL INDUSTRY HAS ADDRESSED THIS
ISSUE OF WORLD BILL DATING BACK
TO AB -- ELEVEN NINETY SEVEN
MEMBER LAMONT CHAPTER IN TWENTY
FOURTEEN AS WELL AS SB EIGHT
SIXTY ONE WHICH IS ALSO CHAPTER
IN.
TWENTY FOURTEEN THE LEGISLATURE
HAS INVESTED SIGNIFICANT
RESOURCES AND TIMING CRAFTING
THESE TO COMPREHENSIVE LOSS. TO
SUPPLEMENT SB FOUR CHAPTER IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN WHICH
INCIDENTALLY IS NOW UNDERGOING
STATUTORY REVIEW FOR A TWENTY
TWENTY REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE
WHICH WILL INCLUDE.
OIL SPILLS YOUR TIME IS UP YOU
CAN JUST FINISH UP IN LATE
WITNESSES MAY HAVE MADAM CHAIR I
I I UNDERSTAND WE'RE ALWAYS ON
TIME LINES BUT BUT I WERE.
OKAY LET ME JUST SAY THIS.
THERE ARE CHAPTER BILL THAT
ADDRESSED THIS ISSUE THERE WAS A
REPORT COMING OUT THAT WILL
ADDRESS OR THIS BILL DOUBLE
INCLUDE NON FLOATING.
IF IN FACT NON FLOATING IS NOT
INCLUDED I AM SURE THAT THIS
BODY WILL GO BACK AND READ AND
READ AND READ KINDLE AND RE
SURFACED AND DEAL WITH THAT
ISSUE THANK YOU.
EARLY EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS RESENTED WITH THE
WESTERN PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION BE
VERY BRIEF.
ENCOURAGED THAT THE
CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD WITH THE
AUTHOR STAFF AND PROVIDING
INFORMATION AS TO YOU KNOW HOW
WE CURRENTLY OPERATE AND TAKE
THIS ISSUE VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT THE THE
THE BIG MAJOR CONCERN THAT WE
HAVE WITH WITH THE BILL IS THE
FINANCIAL ASSURANCE IS PEACE WE
BASICALLY SEE IT AS IMPOSSIBLE
OR VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE TO ME
GENERALLY.
AS WE ARE CURRENTLY -- IMPORT
OVER 70% OF OUR ENERGY NEEDS --
IN ORDER TO PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION FIELD AND TO
DRIVE CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY --
THIS COULD HAVE VERY VERY HUGE
IMPLICATIONS AS TO YOU KNOW THE
THE ABILITY FOR THESE VESSELS TO
COME INTO OUR MARINE TERMINALS
AND PROVIDE THAT FEES TALK FOR
REFINERY SO.
YOU KNOW TOP OF THE MARKET IS
THE FINANCIAL ASSURANCE IS PEACE
AFTER SOME OF THE THE PROVISIONS
UNDER SECTION FIVE IN SECTION
SIX THERE'S A WHOLE HOST OF
ISSUES OR CURRENTLY WORKING --
IT WHETHER IT'S A P. I. OR THE
U. S. COAST GUARD TO PROVIDE
SOME OF THIS INFORMATION THIS
DATA THE STUDY SO -- WILL LOOK
FOR TO CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION
WITH THE AUTHOR AND HIS STAFF TO
SEE WE CAN COME -- WHAT WAS SOME
SORT OF SOLUTION TO BASICALLY
YOU KNOW GET OUT TO WHAT HE'S
TRYING TO DO WHICH IS?
YOU KNOW A LOT OF LOCAL SO WE
OPPOSE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS
JOHN BURKE I REPRESENT THE
PACIFIC MERCHANT SHIPPING
ASSOCIATION OUR MEMBERS ARE NON
TANKER SHIPPING LINE SERVING
CALIFORNIA -- WE HAVE BEEN
OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
ON THIS BILL -- SPECIFICALLY WE
HAVE ONE ISSUE AND THAT IS WOULD
BE WE VIEW IS THE OVERLY BROAD
DEFINITION OF NONVOTING OILS TO
INCLUDE -- MARINE FUEL OILS USED
FOR PROPULSION WHICH ESSENTIALLY
CAPTURES EVERY SHIP THAT COMES
IN THE CALIFORNIA AND THIS IS
DESPITE THE FACT THAT THESE
FUELS ARE PROPERLY RESPONDED TO
AS FLOATING OILS.
IN THE EVENT OF A SPILL -- WE
ACTUALLY FEEL CONFIDENT THAT WE
CAN WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS TO MORE NARROWLY
ADDRESS THIS DEFINITION A WE
NOTE THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
DID BRING UP THIS ISSUE AS WELL
SO -- HOPEFULLY WE CAN RESOLVE
THIS ISSUE.
IN THE NEAR FUTURE.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL.
OKAY.
I ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
FACING THE MISTER RIVERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE NO -- YOU KNOW
AGAIN -- YOU KNOW MYSELF AND
STAFF -- WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE OPPONENTS YOU KNOW TO
ADDRESS THEIR CONCERNS ABOUT THE
FINANCE ASSURANCES AND CERTAINLY
THE DEFINITION OF NON FLOOD OIL
BUT CERTAINLY THIS IS A BILL YOU
KNOW IT'S A GOOD BILL WAS ABOUT
SAFETY IT'S ABOUT PREPAREDNESS
FOR OUR STATE FAR COAST. FOR OUR
PRECIOUS RESOURCES ARE NATURAL
RESOURCES YOU KNOW IT'S THAT WAS
SEEN -- YOU KNOW A DEFINITION OF
NOT FOR OIL MAKE USE THAT WE
OFFER THE NOTIFICATION FOR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS BIGGEST AT
WERE PLANNING YOU KNOW IN THE
WAY OF OF WHAT TO EXPECT TO IF
IF IF IF WE DO HAVE THIS BILL OF
NOT FOR OIL.
AND THEN FINALLY MAKING SURE
THAT THOSE THAT ARE TRANSPORT IT
DO HAVE THE FIND AT THE
APPROPRIATE FINANCIAL ASSURANCES
TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY SPILL THE
FUTURE -- THAT -- IT'S COVERED
SO HOW YOU KNOW WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR EITHER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND AND WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I'D IN FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY SIX FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT REVERSED MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN YES FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA ISLA MON.
Là MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ MURATSUCHI STONE
[inaudible]
STONE I FIVE ONE YOU HAVE FIVE
VOTES WILL LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
YOU HAVE SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
YES SO -- THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
LAST YEAR OUR ATTORNEY GENERAL
HOBBY OF THE SERRA ESTABLISHED
THE BUREAU OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE. TO PROTECT PEOPLE AND
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT INDOOR A
DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE OF
ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION.
THROUGH OVERSIGHT INVESTIGATION
AND ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW.
AB SIXTY TWENTY EIGHT WOULD
RECOGNIZE THE BUREAU IN STATUTE
AS A PERMANENT ENTITY.
AND WHAT STATE THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL IN SECURING THE
RESOURCES NECESSARY TO SUPPORT
THE BUREAU.
RESEARCH RESEARCH SHOWS THAT
POOR PEOPLE AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
INDOOR A DISPROPORTIONATE SHARE
OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION AND
PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARDS WHERE THEY
LIVE WHERE THEY WORK.
AND WHERE THEY GO TO SCHOOL.
THESE FRONTLINE -- THESE
COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK RESOURCES
AND OPPORTUNITIES TO COMBAT
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS AND ARE
DENIED A VOICE IN KEY DECISIONS
THAT IMPACT THEIR HEALTH.
THIS BILL ALSO AS THE TERM
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT TO THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO SURE THAT FAIR
TREATMENT AND MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT OF PEOPLE.
OF ALL RACES CULTURES AND
INCOMES WITH RESPECT TO THE
DEVELOPMENT ADOPTION
IMPLEMENTATION AND ENFORCEMENT
OF ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS
REGULATIONS AND POLICIES -- MY
WITNESS HERE TODAY I CAN
INTRODUCE THEMSELVES BUT AGAIN.
THIS IS AB SIXTY TWENTY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS -- MY NAME IS TIFFANY
ING AND WITH THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE LANCER SO
HOT.
I'M HERE TODAY TO SHARE OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI.
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS A KAMALA
ALLIANCE A BILL TO POWER OF
VARIOUS ORGANIZATIONS TO CHEER
VINYL JUSTICE SOLUTIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA.
WE DEEPLY UNDERSTAND HOW
IMPORTANT THE EASIER IT IS TO
THE PEOPLE AND NEIGHBORHOODS
THAT WE WORK WITH.
FROM ENSURING THAT LAND USE
DECISIONS CONSIDER VINYL JUSTICE.
TO HOLDING BIG PUSH ACCOUNTABLE
FOR THE HARM THEY FLIPPED ON
MANY LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND
COMMITTEES A COLOR.
WE HAVE SEEN FIRST HAND HOW THE
EGYPTAIR HAS MADE A DIFFERENCE
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO CONSULT
WITH OTHER STATE AGENCIES AND
OFFICES SUCH AS OPR. TO
COORDINATE PROGRAMS AND EFFORTS.
SECOND MABEL COMMUNICATION IS
OBVIOUSLY CRITICAL TO THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THAT
ATTY MEANINGFUL GAUGE WENT TO
THE STATE'S DEFINITION VIRAL
JUSTICE.
WOULD SEND A CLEAR MESSAGE TO
THIS TO OTHERS THAT FRONTLINE OR
FENCE LIKE COMMUNITIES SHOULD
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE NOTIFIED AND
HAVE A VOICE THESE APPOINT
SURGEONS -- FOR THESE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND LOOK FOR TO WORK WITH
SOME REMEMBER REAVIS AS THE BILL
MOVES FORWARD TO THE PROCESS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO WISHES TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
LARA GONNA BE ALPHA SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANY MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO THE
BILL.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER RIVERS WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
OR FAR IS ANY COMMITTEE MEMBER
HAVE ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
SURE AND YOU KNOW AGAIN.
THIS BILL SUPPORTED TO JONES
MISSION TO PROTECT VULNERABLE --
SOME COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE
AND TO FURTHER MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT EFFORTS TO COMBAT BY
MIDDLE HAZARDS I RESPECT THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A MOTION
AND SECOND CAN WE HAVE A ROLL
CALL PLEASE.
ITEM TWENTY SEVEN A. B. SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AND REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA CHAU EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MELENDEZ WHERE THIRTY STONE
[inaudible]
STONE I I WANT TO GIVE I FOR ONE
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN.
SOMEONE ARE CALDERON.
GOOD.
EVENING MADAM CHAIR [inaudible]
AND MEMBERS.
YOUR TIME THIS EVENING -- I'M
HERE TODAY TO PRESENT AB NINE
SEVEN FIVE CAL ADAPTATION
LEADERSHIP AND COORDINATION ACT
TWENTY NINETEEN AND IT WILL
REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF NATURAL
RESOURCES AGENCY TO COLLABORATE
WITH OUTSIDE NATIONS. TO SUPPORT
AND PROMOTE THE GOALS POLICIES
INVEST MANAGER PROCESS PRACTICES
RELATING TO OUR GLOBALLY SHARED
OCEAN ESSENTIALLY WE JUST WANT
MORE COMMUNICATION BETWEEN NOT
JUST OURSELVES WE'RE NOT ONLY
TALKING WITH OURSELVES BUT THAT
WE HAVE A MORE GLOBAL APPROACH
WHEN IT COMES.
TO OUR ENVIRONMENT AND WHAT
WE'RE DOING WHEN IT COMES TO
POLICIES ARE THERE TO PROTECT
OUR OCEAN BECAUSE IT'S MAJORITY
OF THE WORLD.
GET THE FOOD FROM THE OCEAN AND
SO WE ALL NEED TO BE TALKING TO
EACH OTHER SO THAT A PARENT
POLICIES RUN CONGRUENT WITH ONE
ANOTHER.
AND WE'RE NOT MISSING EACH OTHER
BECAUSE WE'RE NOT COMMUNICATING
AND SO THIS IS JUST GONNA
MANDATE THAT COMMUNICATION AND
SO WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK --
FOR A YEAR I VOTE ON THE SUPPORT
BILL.
THANK YOU AND YOU HAVE WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON OR GOOD
EVENING I GUESS MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
GEORGE CENTER FOR MOTION
CONSERVANCY -- AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER THIS AFTERNOON FOR FORTY
YEARS WE'VE WORKED ON CONFRONTED
SOME OF THE BIGGEST HALLENGES
TO HEALTHY OCEANS AND VIBRANT
COASTAL COMMUNITIES.
A DECADE AGO CLIMATE CHANGE IS
REALLY A FUTURE THREAT BUT TODAY
IT IS HERE IN FULL FORCE BOTH ON
LAND AND IN THE OCEAN -- AND
WHILE MITIGATION OF CARBON
EMISSIONS IS CRITICAL TO A
STABLE CLIMATE IN THE LONG TERM
WE NEED TO EXPAND OUR EFFORTS.
TO ADAPT TO THE CHANGES THAT ARE
ALREADY UPON US -- AND THAT ARE
PREDICTED TO CERTAINLY GET WORSE
IN THE NEAR FUTURE AND THAT'S
WHY I AM PLEASED TO SUPPORT A.
B. AT NINE SEVENTY FIVE
CONFRONTING CLIMATE CHANGE IS
GOING TO REQUIRE ALL OF US TO
WORK TOGETHER INCLUDING THOSE OF
US IN CALIFORNIA -- BUT ALSO OUR
FRIENDS AND OUR NEIGHBORING
STATES -- AND OTHER COUNTRIES
AROUND THE PACIFIC OR
CONFRONTING SIMILAR CHALLENGES
TIME IS NOT ON OUR SIDE AND
MAXIMIZING KNOWLEDGE GENERATION.
AND KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER IS REALLY
CRITICAL TO SOLUTIONS.
AT OCEAN CONSERVANCY WE'VE LONG
SUPPORTED EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
KNOWLEDGE DEVELOPMENT AND
KNOWLEDGE TRANSFER AMONG
OTHERWISE INDEPENDENT BODIES
ESPECIALLY AROUND OCEAN CLIMATE
CHANGE.
WE ONE OF THE FOUNDING MEMBERS
OF THE INTERNATIONAL ALLIANCE TO
COMBAT OCEAN ACIDIFICATION.
AND WE HAVE ACTIVELY SUPPORTED
THAT WORK EVER SINCE AND
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A MAJOR
CONTRIBUTOR TO THIS EFFORT --
AND AS A RESULT THE ALLIANCE'S
REALLY ACCELERATING ACTION AMONG
GUN -- GOVERNMENTS AND OTHER
ENTITIES SO AS CLIMATE CHANGE
CONTINUES TO ACCELERATE
CALIFORNIA MUST CONTINUE TO BE A
CRITICAL VOICE ON ADAPTATION
POLICY.
APPLIED RESEARCH AND RENEWABLE
ENERGY THE WORLD HAS A LOT TO
LEARN FROM OUR EFFORTS AND OUR
LEADERSHIP AND SIMILARLY WE CAN
BENEFIT FROM THE EXPERIENCE THAT
MINIS -- OTHER ENTITIES ALSO
ALSO GOING THROUGH SO WE ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT A NINE SEVENTY FIVE
TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
JENNIFER SAVAGE ON THE
CALIFORNIA POLICY MANAGER FOR
SURFRIDER FOUNDATION.
SURFRIDER WAS FOUNDED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR BY A SMALL
GROUP OF SURFERS DETERMINED TO
PROTECT THE WORLD'S OCEAN
BEACHES IN WAVES.
AT LAST COUNT WE HAD ONE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY VOLUNTEER LE
CHAPTERS AT STUDENT CLUBS IN THE
US INCLUDING TWENTY CHAPTERS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
I'M VERY PLEASED TO EXPRESS OUR
STRONG SUPPORT FOR A BI NINE
SEVEN FIVE TODAY.
AND WILL NOT EVERYONE WHO IS
PART OF SURFRIDER SERVICE I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY MOST OF
US DO AND WHEN IT COMES TO THE
IMPACTS OF CLIMATE CHANGE ON OUR
CO SURFERS ARE AMONG THOSE ON
THE FRONT LINES.
READ THE BEACH IN THE WATER IN
THE WATER EVERY DAY COLLECTIVELY.
A MANY OF CALIFORNIA'S BEACHES
AS YOU PROBABLY KNOW ARE
EXPECTED TO DISAPPEAR IN THE
NEXT EIGHTY YEARS DO YOU SEE
LEVEL RISE.
IT'S ALSO LIKELY TO DO MANY IF
NOT MOST OF CALIFORNIA'S ICONIC
SURF BREAKS WHICH IS A RATHER
SAD FOLLOW UP TO AN ACTIVITY
THAT WE JUST MADE THE STATE'S
SPORT.
AND WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE GET TO
PLAY THE COAST MIGHT NOT SEEM
LIKE A PRIORITY ISSUE BUT SEA
LEVEL RISE IS ONE OF THE
GREATEST THREATS TO CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY OUT WAIT EVEN WILD FIRES
AND EARTHQUAKES.
ACCORDING TO A MAJOR NEW STUDY
BY USGS RESEARCHERS AND OTHER
SCIENTIST THEY FOUND THAT RISING
SEAS AND STORMS WILL DEVASTATE
CALIFORNIA AT THE TURN OF THE
CENTURY WITH IMPACTS OCCURRING
AS EARLY AS TWENTY FORTY AND AS
YOU KNOW THE FISCAL IMPACTS OUR
ENVIRONMENT TRANSLATE INTO SOCIO
ECONOMIC ONCE BOTH.
THE COAST AND INLAND AREAS WILL
FACE MAJOR FINANCIAL LOSSES.
WITH ALL THIS AT RISK CLIMATE
CHANGE MUST BE ADDRESSED IN
COORDINATION WITH AT A MINIMUM
OUR NEAREST NEIGHBORS WHICH THE
STATE HAS BEEN DOING THAT ALMOST
WHOLLY THROUGH UNILATERAL
ACTIONS BY PAST GOVERNORS.
AB NINE SEVEN FIVE AND IT'S FOR
ENGAGEMENT IN MULTI STATE IN
INTERNATIONAL ACTIVITIES.
AND ENSURE THAT CLIMATE CHANGE
ADAPTATION EFFORTS CONTINUE INTO
THE FUTURE STRENGTHENING THE
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO THESE
EFFORTS GIVEN THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE NATURAL RESOURCES AGENCY
AN OVERDUE AND NECESSARY
LEADERSHIP ROLE.
WE THEREFORE EXPECT PLEA ASPIRIN
AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
FIVE THANK YOU IF ANYONE ELSE
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
NATALIE KNOCKS ON BEHALF OF SAVE
THE REDWOODS LEAGUE IN SUPPORT.
FOR CALLING ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF FEEL
THE BAY IN THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION IN SUPPORT
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR THREE SIXTY BAY AREA
ACTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY IN
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
OKAY YOU HAVE A MOTION IT UP
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE TIME
RESPECTFULLY ASK FROM ABOUT.
THE CLOTHES OKAY EVEN MOTION THE
SECOND MOVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
I'D IN SIXTEEN EIGHTY NINE
SEVENTY FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CALDERON THE MOTION IS TO PASS
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
STONE I FLORA.
FIVE ALL RIGHT FLORA I SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OKAY THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE TO BILLS
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THIS
LIMóN MISSION TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHERRY PEMBERTON ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
LANDS COMMISSION OR THE SPONSOR
OF AB.
FIVE EIGHTY FIVE WE THINK IT
WILL GIVE THE COMMISSION MORE
TOOLS TO PREVENT AN OIL AND GAS
OPERATOR WHEN THEY MAY TRANSFER
A LEASE TO ANOTHER ENTITY.
FROM LEAVING THE STATE
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE DE
COMMISSIONING AND FINANCIAL
LIABILITY -- WE HAVE HEARD THERE
MIGHT BE SOME CONCERNED THAT IT
MADE THIS INCENTIVIZE THE
TRANSFER -- BUT THE THINGS THAT
IT CODIFIES OUR OUR CONDITIONS
OF THE COMMISSION ALREADY HAS TO
ENSURE WHEN IT CONSIDERS A LEASE
ASSIGNMENT OR TRANSFER SO IT'S
VERY CONSISTENT WITH CURRENT LAN
PRACTICE.
AND IT WILL BETTER PROTECT THE
STATE IN THE FUTURE WHEN THERE'S
A POTENTIAL LEASE ASSIGNMENT OR
TRANSFER.
OKAY THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
IS THERE ANYBODY HERE TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION OF THE BILL.
MANAGER MEMBERS WE CENTERS WITH
THE WESTERN STATES PETROLEUM
ASSOCIATION NO POSITION JUST ONE
OF CONCERN.
WE DID HAVE A QUICK CONVERSATION
WITH THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
AND THE AUTHORS OFFICE.
HOPE TO CONTINUE THAT DIALOGUE
ARE ISSUES -- STEM WITH THE TWO
YEAR REQUIREMENT FOR COMPLETE
THE COMMISSIONING WE BELIEVE
THAT THAT MIGHT BE PROBLEMATIC --
IN CERTAIN INSTANCES THE SEEKER
PROCESS TAKES OVER TWENTY FOUR
MONTHS -- SO WOULD LIKE TO
DISCUSS -- YOU KNOW HOW TO GET
HOW TO APPROACH THAT ALSO THE
THE LANGUAGE MAY BE.
AMBIGUOUS OR OR CONFUSING AS IT
RELATES TO THE TYPES OF
FACILITIES SO AGAIN.
JUST SOME AREAS OF CONCERNS AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE THE
DIALOGUE WITH THE SPONSORS AND
AND THE OTHERS OFFICE OF THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AS ANYBODY
ELSE WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS
FROM THE TWENTY FACING -- THIS
ONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THERE'S A MOTION AND A
SECOND WE HAVE A ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
I TO MATE AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LIMóN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
OR NOT VOTING CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LIMóN AYE LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ. TO TREAT.
BREAST SURGERY AYE STONE
[inaudible]
OWN AYE. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT LEAVE THE ROLE
OPEN AND YOUR NEXT BILL PLEASE
THANK YOU.
I WANTED TO START BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS.
AS OIL PRODUCTION CONTINUES TO
DECLINE IN CALIFORNIA THERE IS
GROWING CONCERN FROM OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS AND STATE
REGULATORS THE OIL AND GAS
INFRASTRUCTURE COULD BE DESERTED
LEAVING THE TAX [inaudible]
THE LEAVING TAXPAYERS TO ADDRESS
THE RISK AND COVER THE COST OF
OIL AND GAS PRODUCERS ACCEPT
RESPONSIBILITY.%
AT TO PLUG WELLS WHEN THEY ENTER
INTO LEASES WITH THE STATE TO
DRILL TO ENSURE COMPLIANCE OIL
AND GAS -- BONDS ARE REQUIRED
FROM OPERATORS AS PREREQUISITES
TO OBTAIN PERMISSION TO DRILL
WELLS IN THE EVENT A COMPANY
WHETHER THROUGH BANKRUPTCY OR
OTHER.
EVENT CANNOT TO FILL THE STATURE
IT THE STATUTORY OBLIGATION TO
PLUG IN A BAND IN THE WELLS THE
STATE CAN COLLECT IN OIL AND GAS.
SURETY BOND TO PAY FOR THE
CLEANUP THE CURRENT BOND LEVELS
ARE WOEFULLY INADEQUATE TO COVER
ME MEDIATION AND THE STATE MUST
STEP UP TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
FROM BEARING THE COST OF
DESERTED OIL AND GAS OPERATIONS.
BASED ON CONSERVATIVE ESTIMATES
COSTS PAYERS COSTS TO TAXPAYERS
COULD BE AS HIGH AS TWO HUNDRED
AND NINETY EIGHT MILLION PER TEN
THOUSAND OIL WELLS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TEN FIFTY SEVEN
DOUBLES MINIMUM BONDING
REQUIRING REQUIREMENTS FOR ON
SHORE OIL AND GAS WELLS TO
ENSURE THAT THE PUBLIC IS
PROTECTED FROM ENVIRONMENTAL AND
FINANCIAL LIABILITIES IN THE
EVENT A COMPANY FAILS TO FILL
THEIR LEGAL OBLIGATION TO
DECOMMISSION.
AND REMEDIATE OIL PRODUCTION
SITES THIS BILL ALSO
STRENGTHENED THE DIVISION OF OIL
GAS AND GEOTHERMAL RESOURCES
DAGR AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL BONDING REQUIREMENTS
BASED ON THE LIKELY COST FOR
FULL REMEDIATION AB TEN FIFTY
SEVEN IS A BALANCED APPROACH
THAT WILL PROTECT TAXPAYERS BY
ENSURING THE STATE IS NOT LIABLE.
IN THE EVENT AN OPERATOR FAILS
TO FILL THEIR DUTY I HAVE WITH
ME TODAY MELISSA FROM METAL FROM
THE CALIFORNIA LEGAL
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND UNFIT
THOUGHT IT ON THOUGH WITH OB ON
A LOT OF ON TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU SO EVER LIMóN -- GOOD
EVENING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE -- MELISSA ROMERO WITH
THE CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THERE ARE
CURRENTLY THIRTY THOUSAND IDLE
OIL WELLS IN THE STATE WITH
NEARLY A QUARTER OF WHICH HAVE
NOT PRODUCED OIL IN THE PAST
TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
IF THOSE THIRTY THOUSAND IDA
WELLS IN THE STATE BECOME
ORPHANED OR ABANDONED IT COULD
EXPOSE TAXPAYERS TO SIGNIFICANT
LIABILITY.
IN ADDITION TO THE STATE'S
EFFORTS TO INCREASE BOND LEVELS
FOR OFFSHORE OIL AND GAS WE MUST
ALSO ENSURE THAT FOR ON SHORE
WELLS WHICH MAKE UP 97% OF ALL
OF THE WELLS IN THE STATE.
BOND LEVELS ARE ADEQUATE AND
THAT THE STATE HAS THE TOOLS TO
INCREASE THOSE BOND RATES IF
NEEDED TO COVER THE FULL COST OF
REMEDIATION AND THAT SECOND
PIECE IS REALLY KEY BECAUSE THE
COST TO PLUG.
IN A BAND AN ON SHORE OIL WELLS
VARIES GREATLY DEPENDING ON A
NUMBER OF FACTORS INCLUDING WELL
DEPTH AND PROXIMITY TO SENSITIVE
COMMUNITIES.
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING THE GLOBAL
FIGHT AGAINSTCLIMATE CHANGE AND
PART OF THAT FIGHT IS TO
THOUGHTFULLY PLANNED AND MANAGED.
FOR THE MANAGE DECLINE AND OUR
RELIANCE ON ALL ON FOSSIL FUELS.
IN TO MAKE SURE THAT LIABILITY
FOR MEDIATION COSTS ARE PLACED
ON THE PUBLIC THE VERY PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY BEEN HARMED.
BY THE POLLUTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL BURDENS BECAUSE BY
THIS INDUSTRY.
AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN IS A CRITICAL
STEP THAT THE STATE MUST TAKE IN
ORDER TO PROTECT TAXPAYERS AND
IT'S PART OF AN OVERALL STRATEGY.
TO THE FOR THE MANAGE DECLINE OF
OIL PRODUCTION IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU IS ANYBODY ELSE WHICH
SPEAK SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE OF THE
FEDERAL NAM BEHALF OF BOTTOM
LINE CALIFORNIA I'LL BE BRIEF
AND JUST OFFER TWO EXAMPLES I
THINK THAT I THINK REALLY
EMPHASIZE THE NEED FOR IT FOR
THIS BILL -- YOU KNOW JUST LAST
YEAR WE HAD A IN THE BUDGET --
OVER A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS
BEING YOUR MARKED -- TO DO THE
REMEDIATION FOR PLATFORM HOLLY
AND RINCON ISLAND.
ALTHOUGH THOSE WERE OFF SHORE --
I THINK IT EMPHASIZES THE NEED
TO TO REALLY BE ABLE TO ADDRESS
THIS -- HEAD ON BEFORE WE WE
FIND OURSELVES IN ADDITIONAL
SITUATIONS WHERE THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HAS TO FOOT THE BILL --
FOR THOSE REMEDIATION EFFORTS
AND THE OTHER THING I WOULD
MENTION TO IS THAT SINCE TWENTY
SIXTEEN WHEN YOU HANDLE -- THE
LAST UPDATE OF THESE --
INDEMNITY BONDS -- WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF NEW ACTIONS AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL THAT ACTUALLY ROLL
BACK PROTECTIONS VOTE FOR THE
WAY THAT WE CAN PROTECT OUR ARE.
SENSITIVE ECOSYSTEMS AND
WILDLIFE -- WITH THE THE CASE IN
POINT BEING THE ROLL BACKS RUN
THE MIGRATORY BIRD TREATY ACT --
BY THE CURRENT TO ACTING I
INTERIOR SECRETARY MISTER BURN
HARD -- AND THE CONTINUED A PUSH.
TO TO REMOVE THOSE PROTECTIONS
SO IT REALLY JUST ELEVATES FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE AND
THE NEED AND THAT.
ULTIMATELY THE DESIRE OF
LEGISLATORS -- LIKE SOMEONE FROM
THE MON TO CONTINUE TO EMPHASIZE
THOSE PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
SO WITH THAT -- RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU OTHER MEMBERS OTHER
PEOPLE IN SUPPORT VICTORIA ROME
WITH ENERGY SEE IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMA SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF A SOUL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS THERE ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
A GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR P. ANTHONY THOMAS
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION -- GIVEN
THE OUR LET ME BE BRIEF AND JUST
GET TO THE POINT.
AND THAT IS -- AS COMPELLING.
AS THE THE TESTIMONY WAS --
WE'VE BEEN DOWN THIS ROADJUST
RECENTLY AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY
NINE CHAPLAIN IN TWENTY SIXTEEN
MISTER WILLIAMS.
DID EXACTLY WHAT FIVE EIGHTY
FIVE IS ATTEMPTING TO DO.
THERE'S A SECTION FIVE THAT BILL
IT TALKED ABOUT THE DOLLAR
AMOUNTS TO TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
FOR EACH WELL THAT IS LESS THAN
TEN THOUSAND FEET. FORTY DOLLARS
FOR EACH WELL THAT IS TEN
THOUSAND OR MORE DEEP AND THEN
OF COURSE WE GO TO THE INDEMNITY
BONDS OF WHICH THE AUTHOR
SPEAKING ABOUT.
HIS WAS SET UP ON A TIERED
SYSTEM I PERSONALLY WITH MY CEO
HELP NEGOTIATE THIS PARTICULAR
DEAL. TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
FOREIGN OPERATE HAVING FIFTY OR
FEWER WELLS IN THE STATE FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS FOR ANY OPERATOR
HAVING MORE THAN FIFTY BUT NO
MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED WELLS.
TWO MILLION DOLLAR BOND THERE'S
A THREE MILLION DOLLAR BOND AND
OF COURSE THERE ARE PENALTIES
FOR NON COMPLIANCE RANGING FROM.
ONE TO FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
WELL.
NOW IF IF IF IT'S THIS IF IT'S
THE GOAL OF JETS TO INCREASE
ANOTHER BOND AND AND ASSURE
DIMOND AND THEN SO BE IT.
BUT IF YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT REAL
POLICY MADAM CHAIR TRUE POLICY
AND THAT HAS TO DO WITH.
IS THIS BEING APPLIED.
FAIRLY AND ADEQUATELY TO PROTECT
WHEN SHE REGARDLESS OF WHAT YOU
THINK ABOUT IT THEN I THINK
THAT'S THE QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE TO ASK YOURSELF AND
HOPEFULLY.
ANSWER IT ACCORDINGLY THIS
INDUSTRY HAS IN FACT HAD THOSE
BONDS TAKEN CARE OF THERE WAS
ALSO A BILL BY FORMER MEMBER LOS
WILK SB -- SIX SIX FIVE IN
TWENTY FOURTEEN IT DID THE SAME
THING SO ARBITRARILY.
OR SPECIFICALLY RAISING BOND
EVERY TWO OR THREE YEARS BECAUSE
OF THE THOUGHT.
BECAUSE OF THE THOUGHT THERE'S
GOING TO BE DESERTED WELLS.
IT IS INCONCEIVABLE ESPECIALLY
AGAIN WHEN I SAY THAT WE ARE
REGULATED UNDER THE MOST STRICT
REGULATIONS IN THE COUNTRY IF
NOT THE WORLD I THINK THE BILL
SHOULD BE HELPED -- I THINK THAT
WE SHOULD HAVE A LITTLE MORE
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT IS BEING
CURRENTLY PAID -- BY INDUSTRY
AND I BELIEVE THAT -- HAVING
THAT CONVERSATION -- COME OUT
AND SHOW THAT WE ARE IN FACT
PAYING ENOUGH I STAND AGAINST A
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THE BILL
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR YOUR
TIME.
THANK YOU IS THERE ANYBODY ELSE
IN OPPOSITION.
HEY SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS MANY MANY MEMBERS.
OKAY WITH THAT MISSILE MOMENT TO
LIKE TO CLOSE.
YES THANK YOU AT THIS IS SIMPLY
ABOUT ENSURING THAT TAXPAYERS
DON'T HAVE TO PICK UP THE COST
OF VITAL WELLS THE COST IS FAR
MORE THAN WHAT THE CURRENT BONDS
ARE -- TO BUY IDLE WELLS IN ECHO
PARK NEAR TO MILLION DOLLARS
THAT'S WAY MORE THAN THE THIRTY
THOUSAND AND THAT IS EXPECTED
FOR THEM SO I THINK.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT PROTECTING
TAXPAYERS DOLLARS AND MAKING
SURE THEY DON'T PICK UP THE COST
OF THESE ABANDONED WELLS.
OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
YES SHE DID.
YOUR SEVENTY MM I DID YES AT THE
BEGINNING.
ITEM SEVENTEEN A. B. TEN FIFTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER LEMOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN
I'VE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
THE AYE LIMóN AYE LOW MOAN AYE
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ EL MELENDEZ
NO RIGHT TO CHEAT.
RESEARCH THE AYE STONE
[inaudible]
JOHN I SEVEN THREE SEVEN TO
THREE THANK YOU THE BILL WAS OUT
MR STONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
THAT -- I'M SORRY.
I MEAN JUST LIKE THEM YEAH.
YEAH RIGHT OKAY.
I HAVE BEEN MANY [inaudible]
CONNECTION.
I REMEMBER YEAH.
MISTER SOME WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH THIS AND I'M HAPPY
TO ACCEPT THE AMENDMENTS.
THAT ARE LISTED IN THE ANALYSIS
THERE ON PAGE.
FIVE AB FIVE FIFTY TO CREATE
SAID COASTAL ADAPTATION ACCESS
AND RESILIENCE PROGRAM.
IN ORDER TO FUNDS CLIMATE
ADAPTATION THAT WE SEE ALONG THE
COAST [inaudible]
CURRENTLY.
THE STATE COLLECTS THAILAND'S
REVENUES FROM OIL EXTRACTORS AND
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND AND SIX
THIS MONEY WAS AVAILABLE. TO GO
TO FUND TO PROTECT NATURAL
RESOURCES BUT AFTER TWO THOUSAND
SIX THIS MONEY WAS SWEPT INTO
THE STATE'S GENERAL FUND.
IT'S PROBABLY ABOUT CURRENTLY
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS OR
SO AND IT'S A BIT IT'S DECLINING
BUT WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS TAKE
30% OF THOSE REVENUES SAID JUST
PART OF THE GENERAL FUND TO GO
TO A PROGRAM. TO HELP TO CREATE
GRANTS TO HELP LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ANOTHER'S ADAPT TO
RISING SEAS AND OTHER CLIMATE
RELATED IMPACTS.
THIS IS MONEY THAT'S ALREADY
BEING COLLECTED INSTEAD OF GOING
TO THE GENERAL FUND LET'S PUT IT
TO GOOD USE.
AND START TO FUND SOME OF THE
CLIMATE ADAPTATION NEEDS ACROSS
THE STATE ESPECIALLY IN THE
COASTAL ZONE SINCE THAT'S WHERE
THIS MONEY IS -- THAT I DON'T.
THAT'S WHERE IT GOES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR EITHER.
ONE OF THE MEAT ON A WITH AUTUMN
ON CALIFORNIA WE WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR AUTHORING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AS WE WE KNOW THAT RESIDENTS --
IN CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED TO HAVE
A RESILIENT FUTURE -- A. B. AS
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER SAID AB FIVE
FIFTY TO MAKE SAID NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS TO HELP.
ENHANCE LOCAL RESILIENCE AGAINST
CLIMATE CHANGE OUR DISASTER BY
ENSURING THAT AGENCIES HAVE THE
ADEQUATE FUNDING NECESSARY. TO
REDUCE THE IMPACTS OF SEA LEVEL
RISE AND FOR THAT REASON -- WE
ASK FOR RE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU IS ANYBODY ELSE WOULD
LIKE TO SPEAK IN FAVOR OF THE
BILL.
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THE
SILENCE ALICE WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT.
THERESA BROKERAGE ON BEHALF OF
THE CLEAN SEIZE LOBBYING
COALITION IN SUPPORT.
LAUREN COMMISSAIRE CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT -- GEORGE
WANTED OCEAN CONSERVANCY IN
SUPPORT. FOR THAT ALONE ON
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
IN SUPPORT.
JAMIE GO ON BEHALF OF A SOUL IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU IS FOR ANYBODY WHO
WISHES TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO
THE BILL.
OKAY SING NOT OVER GO BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE.
NO REQUEST TO SPEAK AT THE I
THINK IT'S AN EXCELLENT BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
FOR WE HAVE A MOTION THE SECOND
CAN WE HAVE A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM SEVEN A. B. FIVE FIFTY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER MARK STONE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN
AYE FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA I
LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO.
MCCARTY. THIRTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO MURATSUCHI.
WROTE TO GI STONE.
STONE I SEVEN THREE SEVEN THREE
THE BILL IS OUT MISTER MCCARTY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT
[inaudible]
RIGHT [inaudible]
YEAH.
BUT IT'S GOOD.
OKAY.
SIX SIX ONE OKAY REAL QUICK HAVE
A FEW AYE IMPORTANT WITNESSES
WENT TO INTRODUCE BUT THIS IS A
DISTRICT BILL BUT RELATE TO THE
FIRES THAT WE ALL EXPERIENCE
BELIEVE IT OR NOT AFTER THE CART.
CAMPFIRE MY DISTRICT DURING A
FEW DAYS HAD THE DISTINCTION OF
HAVING THE WORST AIR QUALITY IN
THE WORLD.
AND THE WORLD THE FIRE WAS
NINETY MILES FROM HERE BUT THE
WORST AIR QUALITY IN THE WORLD
IS RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO.
MANY QUESTIONS LINGER IN OUR
COMMUNITY NOT TO SMOKE WHAT YOU
DO WITH OUR SCHOOLS SHOULD
PARENTS KEEP THEIR KIDS AT HOME
SHE TO GO TO WORK.
WHAT SHOULD YOU DO IF YOU GO
OUTSIDE TO TO WEAR A MASK WHAT
THE HECK IS THAT? THREE THREE
HUNDRED PM TWO POINT FIVE RATING
WHAT'S THAT MEAN INTERNET IN
PLAIN ENGLISH.
Là EVENTS UNANSWERED QUESTIONS
WE HAVE OUR AIR QUALITY EXPERTS.
IN OUR COMMUNITY SAID THIS
MEASURE ASK THEM TO HELP A
BETTER FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
RESIDENTS OF WHAT TO DO DURING
AN AIR EMERGENCY.
WITH ME IS MR ALBERTO AYALA
ARCHIE FOR THE SACRAMENTO AIR
QUALITY DISTRICT OUR LOCAL
COUNCIL MEMBER STEVE HANSEN I
CAN I ALSO ASK IF YOU'RE
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES THANK
YOU.
THAT'S WHAT I LOVE WITH ALL OF
THAT YES THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR TEAM. FOR WORKING
WITH US.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CUTS MEMBER
STEVE HANSEN I AM ALSO THE
FORMER CHAIR OF THEIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND MEMBER
OF THE BOARD AS WELL AS AN R. T.
BOARD MEMBER -- WHEN THIS AIR
QUALITY OF IT HAPPENED LAST YEAR
CONSTITUENTS WERE CONCERNED
ABOUT WAS GOING ON BUT OUR TOOLS
THAT WE HAVE DON'T WORK FOR A
WILDFIRE INUNDATION?
THEY'RE MEANT TO GET PEOPLE OUT
OF THEIR CARS AND RIGHT TRANSIT
BUT SPARE THE AIR DAY DOESN'T
WORK WHEN IT'S A WILDFIRE AND
YOUR CARD THE BASIN AND SO.
WHAT WE NEED IS SOME AUTHORITY
FOR THE -- DISTRICT COURT NAY
BETTER WITH THE OTHER LOCAL
AGENCIES AND WE BELIEVE THIS
BILL -- THANK YOU MISTER MCCARTY
FOR AUTHORING IT.
IS IT A PILOT OF SORTS BUT WILL
COME A MODEL FOR OTHER AIR
DISTRICTS IN THE STATE.
SO THAT WE CAN BE BETTER
PREPARED THE NEXT TIME THIS
GONNA HAPPEN BECAUSE WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE WE KNOW THERE
WILL BE ANOTHER FIRE AND THERE
BE ANOTHER INCIDENT WERE
PEOPLE'S PUBLIC HEALTH IS AT
RISK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OTHER TOYOTA AND
POLLUTION CONTROL OFFICER FOR
THE SACRAMENTO MATCH OUR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT.
SO AGAIN AS A COUNCIL MEMBER --
HANSEN SAID -- THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO HAVE BETTER COORDINATION
AND INTEGRATION REGIONALLY AND
WE ARE WORKING WITH THAT -- ARE
HEALTH OFFICERS -- AS WELL AS
OTHER PARTNERS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE ARE PREPARE WHEN -- THE NEXT
FIRE WILL HIT US WE SET RECORDS
IN TERMS OF AIR POLLUTION IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT WE HAVE NEVER SEEN IN THE
PAST AND FOR THOSE FEW DAYS WE
HAVE THE WORST AIR POLLUTION --
IN THE WORLD.
AND AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE'S A
LOT OF CONFUSION AND I I NEED
FOR BETTER COORDINATION AND
COMMUNICATION AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL IS.
IS GOING TO ALLOW US TO DO SO
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF THE
BILL OR ANYBODY.
AT ALL IS THERE ANYBODY WHO
WOULD LIKE TO VOICE THEIR
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
CALIFORNIA BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
NO COMMENT THREE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS MR MCCARTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU AGAIN
THIS IS THE NEW NORMAL AND
FORTUNATELY WE NEED TO PREPARE
AND THIS IS A SMART MEASURE
ASKING PRIVATE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANKS FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE -- WE HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND I THINK MULTIPLE
MOTIONS MULTIPLE SECONDS WE HAVE
A ROLL CALL PLEASE.
ITEM NINE A. B. SIX SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
EVERY FOR TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU [inaudible]
EGGMAN.
I GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NOT VOTING.
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE
[inaudible]
STONE I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT -- MISTER AMERICA TO
CHEAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE I AM
HERE TO PRESENT AB THREE FOUR
TWO AND I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS.
AB THREE FOUR TWO WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA PROTECT.
FEDERALLY PROTECTED LAND AND
NATIONAL MONUMENTS WITHIN OUR
STATE BY PROHIBITING ANY STATE
ENTITY WITH POLICING AUTHORITY
OVER STATE LANDS FROM ENTERING
INTO ANY LEASE AUTHORIZING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF OIL AND GAS
RELATED INFRASTRUCTURE.
ON STATE LANDS TO SUPPORT OIL
AND GAS PRODUCTION ON FEDERALLY
PROTECTED LANCE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
PURSUING AGGRESSIVE ENERGY
POLICY TO OPEN UP MORE MORE
FEDERAL LAND TO OIL AND GAS
EXPLORATION WITH LITTLE REGARD
FOR THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACTS.
AB THREE FOUR TWO WILL HELP
PROTECT SOME OF OUR MOST
BEAUTIFUL LANDS BY PROHIBITING
THE ISSUANCE OF INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT SUCH OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT.
I AM PLEASED TO BE JOINED BY
BRIAN WIKI WITH THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY WILL BE
TESTIFYING SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS A COMMITTEE.
MEMBER I KNOW WE GIVE THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATION
ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN PROTECTING
OUR PUBLIC LANDS FROM OIL AND
GAS DEVELOPMENT.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION IS
CURRENTLY PROPOSING TO OPEN MORE
THAN A MILLION ACRES OF PUBLIC
LAND AND MINERALS STATE
ADMINISTERED BY THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA TO OIL DRILLING AND
FRACKING ENDING THE FEDERAL
MORATORIUM ON LEASING
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL PUBLIC
LANDS TO OIL COMPANIES.
THAT HAS BEEN IN EFFECT FOR OVER
FIVE YEARS.
THE BUREAU OF LAND MANAGEMENT
ESTIMATES THAT UP 290% OF NEW
WELLS ON FEDERAL LANDS ARE
CRACKED.
WHICH OCCURS LARGELY AT SHALLOW
DEPTHS DANGEROUSLY CLOSE TO
UNDERGROUND DRINKING WATER
SUPPLIES WITH HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF CHEMICALS
DANGEROUS TO HUMAN HEALTH AND
THE ENVIRONMENT.
MOREOVER NEW DRILLING AND
FRACKING WOULD DO FURTHER DAMAGE
TO THE AIR QUALITY OF CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA PARTICULARLY IN THE
SAN JOAQUIN VALLEY AIR BASIN
WHICH HAS SOME OF THE WORST AIR
POLLUTION IN THE NATION.
OIL AND GAS DRILLING AND
FRACKING OPERATIONS CONTRIBUTE
TO THIS POLLUTION WHICH CAN
TRIGGER ASTHMA WORSE AND OTHER
RESPIRATORY CONDITIONS AND ARE
LINKED WITH HEART DISEASE AND
CHRONIC ILLNESSES.
LIKE HOUSEHOLD BUDGET THE PLANET
HAS A FOSSIL FUEL BUDGET AND
THERE IS ENOUGH OIL GAS AND COAL
AND ALREADY OPENED PRODUCING
FIELDS GLOBALLY TO TAKE US FAR
BEYOND THE PARIS CLIMATE TARGETS.
IT DEFIES REASON THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WILL CONTINUE
SELLING OFF PUBLICLY OWNED LANDS
AND FOSSIL FUELS FOR DEVELOPMENT
NOW MORE THAN EVER WE MUST KEEP
FOSSIL FUELS IN THE GROUND.
THE TRUMP PLAN WOULD PUT THE
STATE'S MOST ICONIC LANDSCAPES
AT RISK AS WELL.
IT THREATENS NOT ONLY LANCE
MANAGED BY THE BUREAU OF LAND
MANAGEMENT BUT RISKS POLLUTING
THE AIR AND WATER OF OTHER
FEDERAL AND PRIVATE LANDS IN THE
REGION INCLUDING THE ICONIC
SEQUOIA NATIONAL FOREST.
LOS PADRES NATIONAL FOREST
GREASE A PLANE NATIONAL MONUMENT
AND CALIFORNIA'S BEAUTIFUL
COASTLINES.
WHILE THE STATE MAY HAVE LIMITED
AUTHORITY TO STOP THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION PLAN. TO OPEN OUR
PUBLIC LANDS TO EXPANDED FOSSIL
FUEL DRILLING.
THE STATE SHOULD CERTAINLY NOT
BE WORKING TO FACILITATE THEIR
EXPANSION FOR ALL THESE REASONS
THE CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL
DIVERSITY IS PLEASED TO SUPPORT
AB.
THREE FOUR TWO AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK THE COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC.
OR ANYBODY WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT.
DEVICE CAR FOR NEXT GEN
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
VICTORIA AROUND WITHIN OUR DC IN
SUPPORT.
LOW INCOME ON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE WISHING TEST TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY ANY MEASURE -- ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MISTER MATHIS.
JUST A OUT.
SO YOU WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WE'RE NOT GONNA RUN PIPE THROUGH.
AND ANY OF THE STATE LANDS
CRACKED THAT'S CORRECT SO YOU.
PROPOSING OUT THEY JUST RUN PIPE
ALL THE WAY AROUND THEM.
WHICH WOULD INCREASE THE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT.
THIS BUT THIS IS SIMILAR.
TO WHAT -- YET LESS LATE
YESTERDAY ON OFFER AFTER.
IT IF WE'RE GONNA BLOCKING FROM
GOING.
THROUGH STATE LANDS ARE GONNA GO
AROUND THEM WELL -- THAT.
MAY BE AN OPTION THAT -- OIL
COMPANIES MAY CHOOSE.
TO PURSUE BUT THE THE THE THE
BASIC OBJECTIVE IS.
TO TRY TO MAKE IT AS DIFFICULT
AS POSSIBLE -- TO DRILL AND SOME
OF OUR MOST BEAUTIFUL -- LANCE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ALRIGHT.
LOOKS LIKE THE GO AROUND.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ARE WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND TO YOU DID YOU WANT TO
CLOSE I ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU.
WE WERE ROLL CALL.
ITEM FOR AB THREE FORTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MOUNT FUJI THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN YES FRIEDMAN I
FLORA.
FLORA NOTE CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
THE AYE MELENDEZ THE LENDERS
KNOW MURATSUCHI I READ THROUGH
G. AYE STONE.
STONE AYE SEVEN THREE SEVEN
THREE THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT I WILL PASSED THE
GAVEL TO MY BUT VICE CHAIR AND
BRING US ALL HOME.
HER I. MADAM CHAIR WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY AB.
TWO EIGHTY FIVE THANK YOU MISTER
VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS A
TRANSPORTATION CONTINUES TO BE
CALIFORNIA'S GREATEST
CONTRIBUTOR TO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS.
DIRECT EMISSIONS FROM THE TAIL
PIPE OF CARS TRUCKS OFF ROAD
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES AND MORE
ACCOUNT FOR ALMOST 40% OF THE
GHG INVENTORY IN.
TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN A 2%
INCREASE FROM.
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE REQUIRES THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION TO INCORPORATE
CURRENT GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS SUCH AS SB
THIRTY TWO AND THE STATE'S AIR
QUALITY PLANS INTO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
THIS UPDATE TO CALIFORNIA'S LONG
TERM TRANSPORTATION PLANNING
WILL IMPROVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
OF TRANSPORTATION EMISSION
REDUCTION PROGRAMS.
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ROCKY RUSSIAN WITH
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR AND
WILL BEAR WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU GOOD
EVENING MY NAME IS ROCKY RUSSIAN
WITH COLLEGE FOR CLEAN AIR.
THE HARMFUL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
IMPACTS OF HELP LET ME --
TAILPIPE EMISSIONS ARE
IRREFUTABLE.
WE ARE HEATING UP OUR CLIMATE
MAKING PEOPLE SICK.
TRANSPORTATION SOURCES ACCOUNT
FOR APPROXIMATELY 80% OF SMOG
FORMING KNOCKS EMISSIONS 90% OF
DIESEL PM AT APPROXIMATELY HALF
OF OUR GREENHOUSE GASES.
THESE POLLUTANTS FILE THE AIR WE
BREATHE AND CONTRIBUTE TO A WIDE
RANGE OF NEGATIVE HEALTH
OUTCOMES.
CARBON POLLUTION FROM OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM DRIVES
CLIMATE CHANGE RELATED
CONDITIONS.
SUCH AS EXTREME HEAT DROUGHT AND
WILDFIRES YET THERE'S A SERIOUS
DISCONNECT WITH OUR AIR QUALITY
IN CLIMB A GOLD AND ARE
TRANSPORTATION PLANNING.
THE RECENT SB ONE FIFTY REPORT
COULD NOT HAVE BEEN MORE CLEAR
WE ARE ON THE ROAD TO FAILURE IN
MEETING OUR FUTURE GHG
REDUCTIONS.
AND CLIMATE MANDATES.
UNLESS WE SOLVE THE
TRANSPORTATION HOUSING PLANNING
CONUNDRUM THAT WE FACE.
COLLEGE CLEAN AIR SPORTS AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE BECAUSE IT WOULDN'T
SURE THAT THE CURRENT CLEAN AIR
AND CLIMATE STANDARDS ARE
ACCOUNTED FOR WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION PLAN.
THERE'S CRITICAL NEED TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA'S TRANSPORTATION
DECISIONS AND INVESTMENT SUPPORT
REDUCTIONS IN THE POLLUTANTS
THAT THREATEN THE HEALTH OF TOO
MANY CALIFORNIANS.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE WOULD PLAY AN
IMPORTANT ROLE IN MEETING THIS
NEED AND COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR.
ASKS FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
HI GOOD EVENING WILL BEAR AT THE
AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT AB TWO
EIGHTY FIVE IS A STRAIGHTFORWARD
MEASURE TO UPDATES THE ESCAPEES --
CONTENTS THE BILL INSURERS THE
STATE'S TRANSPORTATION PLAN
ACCOUNTS FOR TREATMENT OF OUR
FEDERAL CLEAN AIR STANDARDS IN
OUR STATE GREENHOUSE GAS
REDUCTION RESPONSIBILITIES.
WILL ALSO IDENTIFYING
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE
CRITICAL GRANT PROGRAM ALIGNMENT.
IN PORTLAND AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE
CREATE SPACE FOR THE
CONSIDERATION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE CONCERNS WITHIN THE PLAN.
RECOGNITION THAT MANY CAN
COMMUNITIES ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AND
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY
TRANSPORTATION DECISIONS AND
ASSOCIATED POLLUTION BURDENS
TRAFFIC POLLUTION IS ASSOCIATED
WITH CAUSING ASTHMA TEXAN
CHILDREN.
IN A WIDE RANGE OF OTHER HEALTH
IMPACTS THAT NEGATIVELY AFFECT
CALIFORNIANS.
GIVEN THE URGENCY OF ACHIEVING
OUR HEALTH PROTECTIVE AIR
QUALITY CLIMATE STANDARDS IN A
TIME WHEN TRANSPORTATION
EMISSIONS ARE INCREASING IN OUR
TRANSPORTATION INVESTMENTS ARE
NOT WELL ALIGNED WITH OUR HEALTH
EQUITY IN CLIMATE GOALS.
AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE PROVIDES A
POSITIVE STEP FORWARD PLANNING.
TOWARDS PLANNING ASSISTANT WILL
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM FOR
CALIFORNIA SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
YES VICTORIA ROOM WITH AN RTC IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WITH YOU AT THE CENTER
FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION.
CNN ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
THIS ONE THIS -- IF I'M READING
THIS CORRECTLY THERE IS ALREADY
PENALTIES -- FOR VIOLATIONS OF
DEFENSIBLE SPACE SORRY THAT'S
THE OTHER OIL SORRY OKAY SORRY.
HOLD MY POWDER TILL THE NEXT.
ALL RIGHT ANYONE ELSE.
PERFECT MANAGER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM TWO AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA NO FLORA NO CHAU.
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO WAY OUT.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE AYE.
SEVEN THREE ALL RIGHT OKAY I'M
SURE THE GO ONE MORE A. B.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN YES I THANK YOU
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN AS WE KNOW WE'VE HAD
HORRIBLE WILDFIRES IN THE STATE
WILL MOVE THE BILL.
OKAY I'M AT Là JUST FOR THE
RECORD SAY THAT -- THIS IS
REALLY TO BEEF UP THE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS -- WHOLE --
HOMES OF REQUIRING THE NEW IS
BUILDING CENTERS ARE OFTEN
IGNITION RESISTANT BUT ONLY IF
THE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS ARE MET.
AND WHAT'S NEW ABOUT THOSE FIRES
WITH A LOT OF THE HOUSES THAT
BURNED WERE NEWER HOUSES THAT
DID HAVE A LOT OF THE MORE
RESILIENT A FIRE CODES BUILT
INTO THEM BUT WHAT WE LEARNED
WAS THAT THE VEGETATION THAT WAS
RIGHT WITHIN THE FIVE FOOT.
THIS FIVE FOOT BUFFER WAS WHAT
IGNITED THE HOUSES AND THAT WAS
NOT IN THE CURRENT -- DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS SO THIS
NARROWS IT DOWN TO REALLY TRY TO
GUIDE PEOPLE TO LOOKING AT THE
SPACE BETWEEN ZERO AND FIVE FEET
OF YOUR HOUSE BECAUSE EVEN IF
YOUR YARD DOESN'T BURN YOUR TREE
DECEMBER AND IF IT AMBER BLOWS
INTO A BUSH SITS RIGHT IN FRONT
OF YOUR WINDOW.
THAT COULD BE ENOUGH TO BLOW THE
WINDOW OUT AND ALLOW FIRE TO
MOVE INTO A HOME SO WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH CAL FIRE.
WITH THE ALL OF THE DIFFERENT
STAKEHOLDERS AND YOU KNOW THESE
ARE OURS ARE MEASURES THAT -- A
LOT OF THE EXPERTS BELIEVE ARE
REALLY NECESSARY TO START
INSTITUTING TO MAKE OUR HOMES
MORE FIRE RESILIENT.
WITH ME TODAY TO SUPPORT IN IT
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS LIZ FOR
FOSS BURKE FOR THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY AND RICK SAID TOLD
ME A FARCE ADVISER FROM UC
COOPERATIVE EXTENSION TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU BOTH FOR COMING GREAT.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS LIZ FORCE
BURKE AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE NATURE CONSERVANCY WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN LAST YEAR
CALIFORNIA'S OF THE WORST
WILDFIRES IN HISTORY SETTING NEW
RECORDS FOR THE LARGEST MOST
DESTRUCTIVE AND DEADLY US.
IN THE FACE OF MAKE THE FIRES WE
HAVE A RESPONSIBILITY TO INVEST
IN AND CREATE FIRE RESILIENT
COMMUNITIES.
BUT IF YOU'RE CONSERVANCY IS AN
ACTIVE MEMBER OF THE FIRE
ADOPTED COMMUNITIES LEARNING
NETWORK A NATIONAL GROUP WORKING
TO BUILD SUSTAINABLE WILDFIRE
RESILIENCE CAPACITY IN FIRE
PRONE COMMUNITIES.
THE COALITION IS COMMITTED TO
HELPING PEOPLE IN THE WILD AND
URBAN INTERFACE ADAPTOR LIVING
WITH WILD FIRE.
AND REDUCE THEIR RISK FOR DAMAGE.
FOR COMMUNITIES THAT ARE STOP
MOTION HIGH FIRE RISK AREAS WE
MUST MAKE THE MORE RESILIENT TO
FIRE SAFE BUILDING STANDARDS
DEFENSIBLE SPACE PROGRAMS.
EVACUATION PLANNING AND
PREVENTION OF HUMAN CAUSED
IGNITIONS AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN
MAKES IMPORTANT CHANGES TO
IMPROVE DEFENSIBLE SPACE
REQUIREMENTS AND COMPLIANCE
ENSURING WE ARE ADOPTING
CALIFORNIA TO DEAL WITH THE
ESCALATING FOR A FIRE.
WE ALSO BE MORE RESOURCES AN
EXPERT TO COULD HELP WITH FIRE
PREVENTION ACTIVITIES.
AB FIFTEEN SIXTEEN IMPROVE THE
TRAINING OF LOCAL DEFENSIBLE
SPACE INSPECTORS AND PROVIDES
OPTIONS FOR CONSERVATION CORES.
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
AND FIRE CITY COUNCIL TO CONDUCT
DEFENSIBLE SPACE FOR HOMEOWNERS.
LET'S STOP MAKING HISTORY AND
START MAKING OUR COMMUNITIES
MORE FIRE RESILIENT THROUGH
IMPORTANT MEASURES LIKE AB.
FIFTEEN SIXTEEN THANK YOU TO
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE AND WE
ARE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS.
MY NAME IS RICK IS TELL ME I AM
FORCE VISOR OF PC DIVISION OF
AGRICULTURE NATURAL RESOURCES
BASED ON A SHASTA TRINITY AND
SISKIYOU COUNTY.
YOU SEE SUPPORTS EFFORTS TO
ESTABLISH A NON COMBUSTIBLE ZONE
AROUND STRUCTURES IN HIGH FIRE
HAZARD.
DANGER AREAS.
OUR RESEARCH AND MY OWN
EXPERIENCE DURING THE CAR FIRE
HAVE SHOWN THAT THE THREE TO
FIVE FOOT ZONE IS A CRITICAL
AREA TO PROTECT -- WENT WHEN
WE'RE TRYING TO REDUCE HUMMING
MISSION POTENTIAL.
BY ADDRESSING THIS CRITICAL
VULNERABILITY IN OUR HOME OUR
KERN FIRE DEFENSE STRATEGY WE
WILL REINFORCE OUR EFFORTS.
OF OUR AGENCY COLLEAGUES WHEN
THEY GO ABOUT PROTECTING HOME
STRING WILDFIRE.
AT THIS POINT IF THE COMMITTEE
HAS ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT YOU SEE
AN ARTS ONGOING EFFORTS
SURROUNDING -- NEAR HOME FIRE
DEFENSE OR OUR CURRENT RESEARCH.
I AM HAPPY TO HELP.
ANSWER I CAN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
KRISTIN MURPHY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
RESOURCE CONSERVATION DISTRICTS
IN SUPPORT.
BRIAN -- ACUTE THE CENTER FOR
BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY IN SUPPORT.
SYLVIA SO LEASE SHAUN BEHALF OF
ALL STATE INSURANCE AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT CNN ANY OPPOSITION TO
THIS BILL.
SEE AN NINE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS THE CARD.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
AT DEJA VU I I KNOW WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS WEATHER IS THAT AT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OR WHEN
YOU'RE HIGHER BILLS ARE ARE ALL
THE ABOUT.
A SOON.
THE BILL THAT WE SPOKE ABOUT
BEFORE I RECALL AT THIS MAKES
SENSE IS JUST WONDERING.
WHO WOULD BE AGAINST THIS AND
WHAT WHAT WITH THE PUSH BACK IF
ANY?
IF ANY BE AGAINST THIS WOULD IT
BE I GUESS I PROPERTY OWNERS
WOULD LIKE IT BUT THERE ARE
OTHER ANY ORGANIZED GROUP
SERVING ORGANIZATIONS WOULD
OBJECT TO THIS.
WE'RE NOT AWARE OF ANY ORGANIZED
OPPOSITION BUT THIS THIS BILL IS
REALLY INTENDED TO ALSO WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC ABOUT THE DANGERS OF
HAVING -- THIS COMBUSTIBLE
MATERIALS AROUND THEIR HOMES AND
CERTAINLY THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
SOMEONE WHO HAS YOU KNOW ONE
SMALL PLANNED AND THEN.
I'VE BEEN JUST DOING WINDSHIELD
SURVEYS AND DRIVING AROUND MY
NEIGHBORHOOD WHICH IS A HIGH
FIRE SEVERITY ZONE AND THE
NUMBER OF HOUSES THAT ARE
LITERALLY WRAPPED.
IN FOLIAGE -- YOU KNOW IS A IS
REALLY ASTOUNDING AND WHEN I
TALK TO HOMEOWNERS AND YOU KNOW
I I PUT MYSELF IN THAT CATEGORY
PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE WHAT THE
DANGERS THEY JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND.
THAT IT'S REALLY DIFFERENT TO
HAVE A PLANT TEN FEET AWAY FOR
YOUR HOUSE IS TO HAVE ONE THAT'S
LITERALLY.
RIGHT UP AGAINST YOUR YOUR HOUSE
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT THE
COMMUNITIES USE THIS TO TO GO
OUT AND EDUCATE THE PUBLIC.
AND START TO SORT OF IDENTIFY
THOSE HOMES ARE MOST AT RISK AND
SEND THEM NOTICES THE WAY THEY
DO WITH OTHER TYPES OF HAZARD
AND BRUSH CLEARANCE ISN'T AND
GET THE WORD OUT.
THIS ONE IS.
THANK YOU OKAY SO NIGHT TWO
QUESTIONS -- ONE IS.
I I THINK YOU ALLUDED TO IT IN
YOUR COMMENTS BUT THERE IS
ALREADY -- A PENALTY ASSOCIATED
WITH NOT HAVING THIS DEFENSIBLE
SPACE YOU'RE SAYING -- IT'S
DIFFERENT BECAUSE YOU'RE.
YOUR SHORTENING.
THEAMOUNT OF SPACE IN BETWEEN
THE HOME AND AND FOLIAGE CORRECT
WELL THERE'S TWO DIFFERENCES THE
FIRST IS THAT THERE IS NO THE
CURRENTLY IS ZERO TO FIVE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE ZONE.
SO THIS DOES CREATE A NEWS ON
BASED ON WHAT WE SAW IN THE LAST
COUPLE OF FIRES AND SECONDLY
RIGHT NOW THERE'S A CIVIL
PENALTY AND LEAN AUTHORITY BUT
HELL FIRES NEVER USED IT HOWEVER.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO GO TO COURT
SO THIS CREATES AN
ADMINISTRATIVE -- REMEDY FOR
THEM BUT AGAIN WITH THE GOAL
TOWARDS GETTING COMPLIANCE --
YOU KNOW NOT TO WHAT DO YOU MEAN
BY THE MINISTRY OF ROMANI AND I
UNDERSTAND.
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTY THROUGH
AN ALLERGY PROCESS.
RIGHT SO IT'S IT'S A IT'S A
PROCESS WHERE THEY CAN HAVE
ADMINISTRATIVE CIVIL PENALTY
WHERE THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO TO
COURT TO DO IT THEY'RE STILL A
PROCESS AND THEY'RE STILL AWAY
FOR THE HOMEOWNER TO RESPOND BUT
IT'S THAT DOESN'T INVOLVE THE
COURT SYSTEM TO DO IT.
OKAY SO YOU'RE SAYING THAT
THEY'VE HAD THIS ABILITY TO
PLACE A LIEN ON THE HOME THEY
HAVE THAT NOW.
THEY JUST NEVER USE IT AND SO
YOUR OBJECTIVE LEAST PARTIALLY
IN THIS BILL IS TO MAKE IT
EASIER. TO HAVE A LIEN PLACED ON
HOMEOWNERS PROPERTY IT'S NOT FOR
A LEAN IT'S FOR THE FINE.
CORRECT.
YEAH AND IT'S FOR THE FINES AND
TO GET COMPLIANCE WHEN PEOPLE
ARE OUT OF COMPLIANCE OKAY IN --
SO WHEN YOU WERE TALKING MUCH
DRIVING TO YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD
NOTICING A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE
YOU KNOW DIFFERENT TYPES OF
PLANTS AROUND THEIR HOMES -- I'M
JUST HOW ARE YOU HOW ARE PEOPLE
GOING TO KNOW THAT THEIR OUT OF
COMPLIANCE WELL THEY WOULD BE
NOTIFIED THE SAME WAY THAT RIGHT
NOW I I I I'LL JUST USE MY OWN
EXPERIENCE.
EVERY YEAR THE CITY OF GLENDALE
DOES HAVE THE FIRE DEPARTMENT DO
THEY DRIVE AROUND THE HIGH FIRED
JONES THEY START SENDING OUT
NOTICES PEOPLE SAYING.
YOU KNOW FROM WHAT WE SAW YOUR
OUT OF COMPLIANCE YOU'RE NOT
THAT I WOULD KNOW PERSONALLY BUT
YOU'RE A YOU KNOW WE THINK THAT
YOU NEED TO REMOVE SOME OF THE
BRUSH IN YOUR LANDSCAPE.
AND SO THEY DO ACTUALLY NOTIFY
PEOPLE.
AND CAL FIRE DOES NOTIFY PEOPLE
IN THEIR RESPONSIBILITIES OWN SO
THERE IS NOTICING THAT GOES OUT.
OKAY SO THEN -- EVERYONE IS A
GUARANTEED BEING NOTIFIED IF
THEY'RE OUT OF COMPLIANCE BUT
WHEN AN OPPORTUNITY TO REMEDY
THE SITUATION BEFORE THEY GET
FINED ABSOLUTELY AND WHAT IS
THAT TIME FRAME.
LET'S NOT I GUESS IT'S WHATEVER
IT IS NOW RATED YOU'RE NOT
CHANGING THAT IT MIGHT CHANGE BY
DIFFERENT MUNICIPALITY OR WHO'S
THE RESPONSIBLE AGENCIES SO CAL
FIRE FOR THEIR RESPONSIBILITY
THEY DO THAT IN THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES ON A LOT OF
MUNICIPALITIES.
DO IT THEMSELVES BECAUSE THERE
HAVE THEIR OWN YOU KNOW THEIR
OWN A PROCESS.
OKAY -- THANK YOU.
WELCOME.
YES THIS MATHIS SO.
WE WE YOU SAY YOU GET A
NOTIFICATION.
I ON A HOUSE YOU'VE HAD FOR
TWENTY YEARS YOU SPENT.
A TON OF INVESTMENT.
NOT ON THIS LANDSCAPE NET
NAGGING NOTIFICATION THAT YOU'VE
GOT TO GET RID OF IT
[inaudible]
SEOUL.
WHAT IS THE FINANCIAL
RECUPERATION FOR HAVING TO
REMOVE THAT?
BE BECAUSE NOW NOW WE'RE WE'RE
TELLING PEOPLE THAT I'VE HAD
THIS LANDSCAPE FOR WHO KNOWS HOW
LONG HEY GUESS WHAT YOU NEED
PULL ALL THAT OUT.
SO WE WITHOUT.
THE ANY ABILITY TO PULL NOW SO
NOW WE'RE JUST EXPECTING PEOPLE
TO GO READ ABOUT SOMETHING AND
INVESTMENT THAT THEY'VE MADE.
THAT THEY'VE BEEN TOLD FOR
DECADES IS IS AN INVESTMENT TO
INCREASE OUR HOME VALUE.
AND SO.
I MEAN IS THERE FINANCIAL
INCENTIVE IN YOUR BILL THAT'S
GOING TO HELP PAY FOR THIS.
ORDER IF IT'S AN OLD TREE THAT'S
BEEN THERE.
I MEAN TO SOMETIMES TAKE A SOME
OF THE STUFF OUT IS EXTREMELY
COSTLY ESPECIALLY IF IT'S RIGHT
NEXT TO THE HOUSE.
THEN YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT ROOT
SYSTEMS THAT ARE GOING.
UNDERNEATH THE FOUNDATION -- SO
I MEAN IT IT THESE THIS CAN GIVE
VERY VERY COSTLY VERY QUICKLY --
A ADDED RE CONSTRUCTION AND
REMODELING HOMES AND FLIPPING
HOUSES AND BETWEEN DEPLOYMENTS.
IN.
I MEAN FIXING A FOUNDATION IS A
NIGHTMARE.
SO IF YOU'RE GONNA GO START
PULLING STUFF OUT.
I MEAN IS THIS CAN QUICKLY GOING
TO THE THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS THAT
WE'RE ASKING PEOPLE TO DO.
OKAY SO FIRST OF ALL -- WE ARE
NOT -- IT RIGHT NOW SAYING THAT
YOU CAN'T HAVE ANYTHING WITHIN
THE FIVE FEET WE THE BILL
DIRECTS -- THE VARIOUS YOU KNOW
EXPERTS SORT OF COTTON SORT OF
WELL I'M A LOOK AT WHAT EXACTLY
WE SHOULD BE RECOMMENDING BUT
ALSO TO FOCUS ON SORT OF THE
MOST FLAMMABLE MOST DANGEROUS
MATERIALS.
BUT I WOULD SAY THAT IS
EXPENSIVE IS REMOVING THIS
MATERIAL WITHIN FIVE FEET FOR
YOUR HOUSES IT'S NOT GONNA BE
NEARLY AS EXPENSIVE AS REPLACING
YOUR HOUSE IF IT BURNS DOWN IN A
FIRE.
SO THERE IS A YOU KNOW KIND OF A
RISK ANALYSIS THAT HOMEOWNERS
NEED TO BE DOING WHEN THEY LOOK
AT THIS AND IF YOU.
GET A NOTICE FROM ONE OF YOUR
AGENCY SAYING THAT YOU HAVE A
REAL A HAZARDOUS CONDITION AND
YOU'RE ALREADY LIVING AT A HIGH
FIRE.
SEVERITY ZONE WHICH THIS BILL
ONLY IMPACTS.
YOU REALLY NEED TO DO THAT COST
BENEFIT US AND BENEFIT ANALYSIS
AND CERTAINLY YOU KNOW SOMEONE
WHO GETS NOTICE WAS A COUPLE OF
PLANTS IS NOT A BIG DEAL BUT IF
YOU'VE GOT.
A REALLY FLAMMABLE TREE RIGHT UP
AGAINST YOUR HOUSE.
PEOPLE REALLY DO NEED TO BE PUT
ON NOTICE BECAUSE PEOPLE DO NOT
REALIZE HOW HAZARDOUS THAT IS
THEY JUST DON'T NOW SO A LOT OF
THIS IS ABOUT EDUCATING PEOPLE
SO THAT THEY CAN NO AYE THOSE
KINDS OF ANALYSIS YOU TO DO THAT
DO THAT ANALYSIS AND SELF.
ABSOLUTELY BUT THE MEN WERE ALSO
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
WERE YOU KNOW.
SAYING THAT PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD
TO PAY THEIR OWN TRAFFIC TICKETS.
SO HOW SHOULD WE EXPECT THEM TO
REMOVE TREES THERE ARE -- FIRE --
RESPONSIBILITY -- AREAS THAT
HAVE COME UP WITH WAYS OF
INCENTIVIZING AND FINANCING LOW
INCOME HOMEOWNERS TO REMOVE
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND THERE
ARE CITIES THAT DO THAT AS WELL
WHERE THEY HAVE FOR LOW INCOMES --
HOMEOWNERS AND SENIORS -- ALL
KINDS OF HAZARD ABATEMENT
PROGRAMS THAT ARE AVAILABLE SO
THERE ARE LOCAL INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE IN MANY PLACES
AND I CERTAINLY WOULD SUPPORT.
MEASURES TO INCREASE THE
AVAILABILITY OF PEOPLE TO DO ALL
KINDS OF HOME HARDENING --
BECAUSE THIS IS GOING TO BE A
PROBLEM ALL ACROSS THE STATE AS
WILD FIRE RISK INCREASES I MEAN
WILL HAVE THE SAME CONVERSATION
ABOUT HOME HARDENING ABOUT
REPLACING ROOFS ABOUT.
YOU KNOW ALL OF THESE DIFFERENT
MEASURES YOU KNOW I THINK IS AS
HIGHLIGHTED.
ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND DEFENSE
YEAH SPACE EIGHT MY FIRST JOB
WAS DRIVING A THREE WHEELER WITH
THE TRAILER CLEARING DEFENSIBLE
SPACE ON THE COUNTRY -- IN IN MY
ROLE COMMUNITY WHERE I GREW UP
SO I I KNOW ALL ABOUT IT VERY
WELL -- BUT I ALSO ONE OF THE BY
I ALSO KNOWS VERY COSTLY IN
WITHOUT HAVING A FUNDING.
TASKED WITH IN THE BILL TO
REALLY HAVE A MECHANISM THERE.
TO HELP THESE FAMILIES OUT TO DO
THIS I I CAN'T SUPPORT IT INTO A
SALE ALSO SAID THAT A BIG PART
OF THIS IS TO CHANGE THE CODES
FOR NEW CONSTRUCTION A NEW
LANDSCAPES THAT ARE PUT IN AND
YOU KNOW THAT'S NOT SOMETHING TO
BE IGNORED BECAUSE LANDSCAPE
DESIGNERS.
ARE STILL DESIGNING NEW NEW
LANDSCAPES TODAY IN THESE ZONES
WITH PLANTING RIGHT IN THAT FIVE
FOOT -- AREA.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
FROM A FIREFIGHTER -- SORRY MR
SOME GOOD WE JUST ADD IN THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT I'VE ACTUALLY
WORKED PRETTY CLOSELY WITH MILES
WHO WAS OR THE SECOND I'LL TELL
YOU HOW IT'S GOING TO GET USE.
EVERY NEIGHBORHOOD KNOWS THE
HOUSE.
LOCAL FIRE AGENCIES NO THE HOUSE.
THAT FIRE SAFE COUNCILS NO THE
HOUSE THAT THEY'VE BEEN TRYING
TO GET CLEANED UP AND THAT ONE
HOUSE WHO REFUSES TO CLEAN UP.
AND ADDRESS OF THE THE
DEFENSIBLE SPACE IS A THREAT TO
THE ENTIRE NEIGHBORHOOD SO YEAH
IT'S A COST TO THAT HOUSE BUT
IT'S A COST TO THE ENTIRE
NEIGHBORHOOD IN THESE FIRE.
RISK AREAS WHEN THEY GO UP SO I
DON'T SEE LOCAL AGENCIES ARE CAL
FIRE.
USING THIS IRRESPONSIBLY THEY'RE
GOING TO THEY CONSTANTLY ARE
WORKING WITH HOMEOWNERS THEIR
COSTLY WORKING WITH
NEIGHBORHOODS TO GET THEM TO
CLEAN UP THE RISKIEST AREAS AND
THOSE LAST FEW HOMES THAT
REFUSED TO PARTICIPATE.
AND THAT PUT ITS THREAT THE REST
OF THAT NEIGHBORHOOD ARE THE
ONES WHO ARE GOING TO BE.
THIS TOOL WILL BE USED. TO TRY
AND MAKE SURE THAT THEY ARE
BEING RESPONSIBLE THAT'S THE
LEVEL OF RISK THAT THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT I DON'T SEE IT
BEING USED.
SORT OF **** NILLY AND JUST FOR
FOR EVERYONE AND IT'S
ASTONISHING WHAT SOME HOMEOWNERS
ARE ARE REALLY NOT WILLING TO DO
THAT BUT THEMSELVES AND OTHERS
AT RISK AND THIS IS HOW THIS WAS
GOING TO BE USED AND I THINK
IT'S GOING TO BE VERY EFFECTIVE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANYONE ELSE.
CNN MANAGER WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION AT THE END OF THE
HEARING.
THIS.
AS SECOND PLEASE CALL THE ROLL I
AM TWENTY SIX A. B. FIFTEEN
SIXTEEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FRIEDMAN THE MOTION IS TO PASS
AS AMENDED AND REFER TO
UTILITIES AND ENERGY COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA FLORA I'D CHAU CHAU AYE
EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA ITEM ON
THE MOON I MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
HI MCCARTY AYE MELINDA'S.
DILLON DOES NOT VOTING.
WE'RE OUT TO CHANGE.
ROUTE SIXTY AYE STONE.
STONE AYE. NINE ZERO I AM SURE
THAT BILLS OUT.
HEY WITH THAT.
WE ARE GOING -- TO CALL FOR A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR COMING OF ROLL CALL
PLEASE.
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. TO PASS
AND REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WITH CONSENT
RECOMMENDATION MEMBERS FRIEDMAN
HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA I CHILD CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA GARCIA ISLANDS.
Là MON I MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MURATSUCHI.
WROTE TO GI STONE.
STONE NINE ELEVEN ZERO OKAY CAN
WE START AT THE TOP BECAUSE WE
HAVE BILLS IN THE BEGINNING THEY
DON'T HAVE MOTIONS OR SECONDS AS
WELL.
WE HAVE A LIST OF THOSE.
ITEM ONE AB ONE FORTY FOUR BY
TWO SECOND.
OKAY COULD WE HAVE A ROLL CALL.
AB ONE FORTY FOUR AGUIAR-CURRY
DO PASS AND REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I FLORA
FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE AYE ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN
ZERO THAT THOSE OUT.
ITEM TO AB TWO EIGHTY FIVE BY
FRIEDMAN DO PASSED REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT --
IS SEVEN TO THREE WITH THE CHORE
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU
[inaudible]
SHALL I EIGHT THREE EIGHT THREE
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THREE AB TWO NINETY SIX I
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
ROLL CALL PLEASE.
AB TWO NINETY SIX BY MEMBER
COOLEY TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA AYE GARCIA AYE
LOW MOAN.
THE LOAN I MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY AYE
MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO RIGHT TO CHEAT.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
ON I TEN ONE TEN ONE THAT THOSE
UP.
MAYBE THREE FORTY TWO ITEM FOR
MURATSUCHI DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE THIS
SEVEN TO THREE ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
CHOW AYE EIGHT THREE EIGHT THREE
THAT BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T FIVE AB FOR TWENTY THREE
GLORIA DO PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE FOR THE ONE WITH THE CHORE
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
TROUT I LIMóN.
LOW MOAN I MCCARTY HI MCCARTY
AYE MELINDA'S.
LENDERS NO ROUTE SEARCHES.
READ THROUGH GI. EIGHT TO EIGHTY
TWO THAT DOLLARS OUT.
ITEM SIX A BEFORE THIRTY WAS
TESTIMONY ONLY.
ITEM SEVEN AB FIVE FIFTY TWO BY
MARK STONE.
DO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN TO THREE WITH THE
CHORE VOTING I ABSENT MEMBER
CHAU.
CHOW AYE.
EIGHT THREE A THROUGH THE BILL
ITSELF.
I AM A AB FIVE EIGHTY FIVE BY
THE MOM TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE CURRENT
GOAL IS.
SEVEN ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHILD.
CHAU I MELENDEZ.
THE LENDERS KNOW. EIGHT ONE
EIGHT ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
I DO NINE A. B. SIX SIXTY ONE
MCCARTY DO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE.
NINE ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS CHOW.
CHOW I TEND ZERO TEN TO ZERO
THAT GOES OUT.
ITEM TEN EIGHTY SEVEN NINETY TWO
BY TEEN TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FOR THE
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA.
THE VOTING FLORA NOT VOTING CHAU.
CHAU II LIMóN.
LIMON I MCCARTY BY THE CARTY I
FOR A TO G..
ROTH TO GI. EIGHT ONE EIGHT TO
ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM ELEVEN I NEED A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
WHO WAS THE SECOND?
RESEARCHING OKAY THANK YOU THE
VIETNAMESE.
YEAH ITEM ELEVEN AB EIGHT
FIFTEEN IGOR CURRY DO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I
FLORA FLORA AYE CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA. THIRTY AYE
LOW MOAN HI Là MON I MATHIS.
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY AYE MCCARTY
AYE MELINDA'S MELENDEZ AYE
MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO I AM YOUR
LEVEL IS OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT THIRTY SIX
BY WICKS.
THANK YOU.
ITEM TWELVE AB EIGHT THIRTY SIX
WEEKS TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN AYE
AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA AYE CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LOW MOAN AYE MATHIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ
AYE MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI AYE
STONE.
STONE I ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ELEVEN ZERO ITEM THIRTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT THIRTY NINE MULLIN I DO
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
HELLO EGGMAN ARE SWITCHING THANK
YOU.
I AM THIRTEEN AB EIGHT THIRTY
NINE MULLIN DO PAST REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FRIEDMAN AYE FRIEDMAN AYE FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
THE LOAN I MATH MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
LENDERS KNOW MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE STONE.
STONE [inaudible]
I TEN ONE THEN WHEN THE
BUILDINGS ARE NINE ONE NINE ONE
BILLS UP.
ITEM FIFTEEN EIGHTY NINE THIRTY
SIX ROBERT RIVAS TWO PASSES
AMANDA REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS FIVE TO
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I WITH
THE CONSENT.
ABSENT MEMBER FLORA.
NO.
FLORA NO CHILD [inaudible]
CHAU I MCCARTY.
THIS IS AB.
NINE THIRTY SIX MCCARTY AYE
MELINDA'S.
WHAT MADE?
YOU.
ARE IN THE SIXTEEN ITEM FIFTEEN
A. B. [inaudible]
NINE THIRTY SIX MELENDEZ NO
[inaudible]
MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI I EIGHT
THREE EIGHTY THREE THAT BILL IS
OUT. TWENTY SIX ITEM SIXTEEN AB
NINE SEVENTY FIVE CALDERON TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT -- IS SIX TO
ZERO WITH THE CHORE VOTING I AS
A MEMBER CHAU.
TROUT I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOW MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH THE I NINE ONE THE BILL
IS OUT. NINETY ONE I DON'T
SEVENTEEN AB TEN FIFTY SEVEN BYE
LE MONDE TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE. SEVENTY
THREE WITH THE TRIBE VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBER CHILD.
SHALL I EIGHT THREE EIGHTY THREE
THE PHYLLIS OUT.
ITEM EIGHTEEN AB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO KALRA TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFER TO JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CAR
ABOUT TWO TO THREE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU.
SHALL I EGGMAN.
EGGMAN NOT VOTING GARCIA.
GARCIA NOT VOTING LAMONT
[inaudible]
LIMON I THE MONA.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MURATSUCHI.
RED TO GI [inaudible] SIX THREE
SET UP. SIX THREE SIX THREE THE
BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T NINETEEN A. B. ELEVEN
NINETY FIVE O'DONNELL DO PASS AS
AMENDED REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT GOAL IS FORTY
ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA I'D CHAU [inaudible]
I LIMóN.
Là M<c.cyan> NO.</c>
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY NOT VOTING [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
AND AS I MURATSUCHI.
RIGHT TO CHIU NOT VOTING. SEVEN
TWO SEVEN TWO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT HOLDEN I DO NEED
MOTION A SECOND PLEASE.
I DON'T KNOW.
SOMEBODY I'LL JUST.
ITEM TWENTY THREE A. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT HOLDEN TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FRIEDMAN HI
FRIEDMAN I FLORA.
FLORA NO CHAU.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA I LIMóN.
LIMON AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
MATHIS NO THE I. MELINDA'S.
LENDERS NO.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE.
RED SURGERY AYE STONE.
STONE AYE EIGHT THREE EIGHT
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
I DON'T TWENTY FIVE A. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BY BURKE
TO PASS AS AMENDED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
CURRENT VOTE.
FIVE TO ZERO ABSENT MEMBERS
CHILD.
CHAU AYE EGGMAN.
EGGMAN AYE GARCIA.
GARCIA AYE LAMONT.
LOW MOAN AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
I 11-3. TWENTY EIGHT CONSENT.
AFTER SEVEN MINUTES.
OKAY SO I CAN RUN.
THEM WITH ITEM TWENTY THREE
THERE ARE TWO DIFFERENT SHEETS
THAT MIGHT THE CONFUSION. ONE OF
THE COOLEST PART OF SEVEN OFF OF
WEST EXAMPLE SATURDAY.
WHICH IS THAT WHEN YOU TO
DEVELOP.
OKAY WHAT WOULD LET'S FINISH THE
ONE WE'RE ON WHAT WE'RE WAITING
ON THE WHEN WE RUN.
HE WAS.
YEAH WE'RE READY TO DO BURKE DO
WE JUST FINISH THE OTHER.
ONE OKAY YEAH.
WE JUST SAID BURKE BURKE OUT OUT
ELEVEN ZERO QUE QUE NOW WE'RE ON
ITEM. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT ROBERT
RIVAS TO PASS REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CURRENT BEAU IS FIVE
TO ONE WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
HAVE SOME MEMBER FLORA.
FLORA NO CHILD.
CHAU AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NO MURATSUCHI.
RED TO GI.
EIGHT THREE AND IF THOSE OUT.
YEAH THAT'S GOOD UNLESS YOU WANT
TO GO BACK TO ITEM TWENTY THREE
BUT FOURTEEN TO LEARN.
THANK YOU. FOR EXAMPLE
[inaudible]